good morning sorry it took me a second
there it's uh it's still a little bit of
wake up time here in um
Indianapolis
um but I'm doing good I hope you're
doing good too I've got to go over to
projectforawesome.com live so that I can
see the um the chat
um great there I am
all right
there's a mix between we're here because
then we're hummus because
hummus the unexpected star of the 2023
project for awesome nobody saw it coming
um but hummus has emerged
um did anything else happen overnight
that I need to know about
in terms of drama
um
things falling apart things coming
together we had a lovely chilled morning
with rosiana I love to hear that that's
I think that's that's the that's the
thing that rosiana
um brings to the p4a every year is a
lovely mix of
joy and chill
uh I just got a nice good morning
message from um our friends at this star
won't go out
um include who who may include the Earl
family
um
always great to hear from this star
won't go out and um one of my favorite
Charities to vote for at
projectforawesome.com uh for those who
don't know
in 2010 a long time nerdfighter and uh
project for awesome volunteer Esther
Earl died of cancer at the age of 16.
and this story won't go out was founded
in her memory to give financial support
to families of kids living with cancer
and it's done amazing work over the last
13 years and we feel so lucky to still
have the Earl family and all the Vistar
won't go out family in our lives and in
our community so thank you for being
here
um we think of Esther all the time but
we especially think of Esther during the
p4a because it was a big part of what
she loved so
um yeah a big part of what she loved
about nerdfighteria and
and I think like is a big part of what
most of us love about nerdfighteria so
yeah um thinking of Esther with warmth
and sadness and all the same things all
all of all of that stuff at the same
time I guess
um
yeah it's
I wish you were here
as I'm sure you all do
so
um there was a Dr Pepper Bean pickle I
think I saw that
um
I think I saw that
that was upsetting
you know Hank's whole thing where he'll
just
I think it's because he has ulcerative
colitis he's like there's no reason not
to go hard you know I'm gonna be
suffering no matter what I suffer every
day
might as well go
really really hard
uh overnight Brennan and Sam had to
witness Hank's crimes against the banana
Loca Community I don't know that I know
what banana Loca is
um it sounds like a liquor
but I'm not positive
um
all right so oh and there was lemon
whips Hank yeah where Hank joined the uh
Legion of celebrities who've gotten lip
fillers I did see I did see that I did
I was working on the stream during that
period
um
oh it's glory Earl
uh who's here so thank you Lori and if
you want to support uh This Storm won't
go out during the money we raised during
the second half of the project for
awesome it's easy easy to do so you go
to project for awesome.com you search
for this star won't go out and you'll
see there that there are
um that there are videos about this star
won't go out and that's how you um
that's how you find uh this star won't
go out videos
um or you can also search for tswgo that
might work even better and um there's a
video by this star won't go out
um and I'm gonna vote for that one right
now so
um that's how you do it uh so
it's a great organization that supports
families facing Childhood Cancer but
there are so many and there are also so
many other great organizations
um that you can support at project for
awesome.com and even if you can't donate
your votes matter because they decide
where the money that we're currently uh
well the money that we're gonna raise
beginning in three hours goes uh so
please vote we've had 25
000 votes at project for awesome.com
which is an awesome awesome start really
exciting but we'd love to get that
higher and also it's just a way of
supporting people who made projects for
awesome videos who you know went um made
themselves vulnerable and talked about a
charity that they care about it's a nice
thing if if you have a few minutes to go
and watch some of those videos leave
encouraging comments and learn about
Charities doing good work around the
world and hopefully feel a little bit
more hopeful it's so easy to feel
um
despair these days uh maybe it's always
been easy to feel despair but it's
especially it does feel especially easy
right now
um it feels like things are overwhelming
and overwhelmingly bad uh but then when
you interact with um people and
organizations who are working together
to try to make the world suck less you
begin to sense that
um you know that it is possible to
reform these systems to make things uh
better and we know that it's possible
because we've seen it happen you know we
don't always see it happen progress
nothing inevitable about progress
nothing permanent about it
um there's nothing permanent about
anything but it is possible to see a
positive change in the world and to see
progress and to see systems reform
um to include and represent more people
I think about the fact that um
until the mid-1960s in the United States
millions of people were denied the right
to vote uh based on their race I think
about the fact that
um until about a century ago uh Millions
more people in the United States were
denied the right to vote because they
were women and um and so we we can see a
world with positive change I think about
the fact that
20 years ago uh there were tens of
millions of people dying of HIV AIDS
because not because we had no way to uh
treat it effectively but because we uh
we're not getting the drugs that are
needed to treat the disease to the
places where the disease uh was and how
we changed that we changed that with
activism with fundraising
um and that saved the lives of millions
of people
we can continue to make that kind of
progress and build systems that are more
resilient that that include more people
help more people together and so that's
what the p4a reminds me of every year
and it does make me feel hopeful even
when um you know things are also like
the reality of suffering and Injustice
is extremely extremely profound
so that's um that's what I'm thinking
about this morning
um we're closing in on 1.76 million
dollars raised in the 2023 project for
awesome
which is incredible
um so I have I have a little um I have a
little Google sheet that tells me what
we raised every year and 1.76 million
dollars puts us above all but four of
the 16 project for Awesomes so already
been a hugely successful p4a and I'm so
grateful to everybody who's donated
everybody who's encouraged their like
friends and family to donate and also
everybody who's voted at project for
awesome.com it's just such an
encouragement
um it's just it's just such a it's such
a good reminder to me that like the
voice in my head that tells me that
everything is for nothing is not telling
the whole truth if that makes sense so
I'm drinking some awesome coffee this
morning
it's very good
um I don't like to uh
I don't usually like to to get high on
my own Supply but I make I make a I make
a uh exception for for awesome coffee
it's so good
um I've always liked that phrase like
not about drugs but about like um like
making stuff creatively like you know
like don't read your own work with that
with the like enthusiasm and generosity
that you would read other people's work
like don't like get get too in love with
your own uh Voice or whatever
um but yeah I don't know I don't I don't
I don't actually know if that's good
advice or if it's just uh if it just
Rhymes there's so many times in life and
we will get to uh the project for
awesome but there's so many times in
life when um I think something is deeply
and profoundly true and it turns out
that it just rhymes
you know
um I see this a lot in like music lyrics
um
you know and like it turns out that it
just like really fits the meter you know
like when 21 Savage says how many
lawyers you got a lot I'm like man
that's deep but is it deep or does it
just really fit the meter or like when F
Scott Fitzgerald says um
uh uh talks about
um
that when when Europeans saw the coast
of America they were face to face for
the last time in history with something
commencing it to commensurate to man's
capacity for Wonder like that's not true
um but it really is a good one like it
feels true you know because it's so well
constructed
um stranger danger I mean sometimes
strangers could be dangerous I don't
know I tell my I I tell my kids not to
uh you know be nice to strangers but
also be cautious
um
uh yeah so if it rides Our Lives is
another great example you know um from
my covid cars versus covid era uh but
yeah you have to be really careful
not to think that things that rhyme are
true
so compelling
I think that about Shakespeare all the
time like there's some stuff in
Shakespeare that like obviously doesn't
hold up it's 400 420 years old or
whatever
um but I think about it all the time
because I'll be like man that's deep
safe in their Alabaster Chambers and
then I'll be like are they are they safe
in their Alabaster Chambers
or is the present like constantly coming
for the for the past
um yeah yeah so anyway
um I got to be careful about that uh
just because it's a good line doesn't
mean it's true uh I also find this in my
own work like when I write a good line
or like when I write a line that like
fits a meter or or has that like you
know that that sort of aphoristic
quality to it I have to be like wait a
second though is it is it true or is it
just good do I just like it
um
uh but then again like lots of things
that 50 meter are true
um like I bet 21 Savage does have a lot
of lawyers
so yeah
um I missed the vision board well I kind
of missed the vision board too man I
hadn't thought about the vision board in
a long time that was
that was that that was a funny era of
vlogbrothers the vision board man yeah
it was it was a lot of work like I'd
have to wake up at like six o'clock on a
Tuesday morning and spend like three
hours
um it's been like three hours working on
the vision board it wasn't a good use of
my time but it was very funny
um yeah nerd writer says kill your
rhyming Darlings always nice to see you
um Evan thank you for being here if you
haven't seen uh by the way nerdwriter uh
who is uh an original project for
awesome supporter
um also uh has written a wonderful book
called Escape into meaning a wonderful
book of essays uh that um
is about kind of the the joys that come
from writing and paying attention and
and having thoughts through writing and
paying attention to pop culture and art
and it's really really good
um I I can't do it justice but I think
you should check it out
um
let's do a live vision board all right I
mean it's probably not the best way to
raise money but I'm interested let me
find them I think I still have the
vision board here I do that's a good
start
um I have you can
you can see how often I edit it
um
by uh so this is this is uh this is the
original vision board
um from back in the day I think it was
only like a year ago uh and this is this
is an if you look in the background you
can see an outline of how we got to 35
million dollars in our project to
radically reduce maternal and child
mortality in Sierra Leone
um there's there's there's PIH major
giving there's
um one-time gifts
there's I don't know what that is
there's John and Hank there's matching
yeah so
um pretty pretty incredible that we've
managed to raise so much money in order
to um wipe this vision board clean I'm
gonna go ahead and take
this copy of Bananagrams which I made a
video about probably like three months
ago and then just kept down here and I'm
gonna this is a this is actually a a
deluxe Louis vuitton-esque edition of
Bananagrams with a sort of silky banana
holder and I'm gonna go ahead and just
use that to wipe nope it's not very
effective I'm not sure that I did this
with a dry erase marker I think this
might have just been a regular old
marker huh all right uh okay I also have
a towel
maybe the towel will be better oh the
towel is is slightly better still not
great
oh boy this is gonna be now this is a
workout right here this is
physical
oh boy oh boy that's that's just pushing
very limits of the triceps
oh my God
all right I don't know how clean we're
gonna get this vision board
realistically is there does anybody does
anybody have a have a uh some vision
board advice try some hand sanitizer
I don't think I have any down here would
diet Dr Pepper do the trick
um if you leave it out it will dry well
I left it out Matt so there's no going
back from that I just saw
um
the trick is to write over with a fresh
dry erase oh let's see if that works
that was Miriam who said that thank you
Miriam
um I saw I saw on Tumblr that Miriam
said that the project for awesome is the
is the only good weekend of the year or
something like that it was it was
probably more profound and funny than
that that does work Miriam
whoa whoa
oh man this is now we're cooking with
gas
now is that true or is that just uh
clever now we're cooking with gas I feel
like we should make it now we're cooking
with electricity because we've got to
discover that's man that's big gas out
to get us
ever since Hank made that video about
gas stoves I've been duly horrified that
I was completely duped by the gas stove
industry so now we're cooking with elect
now we're cooking with induction
solar powered induction now we're
cooking with
oh
good God
all right
I got it clean
I gotta clean thanks to Miriam's great
trick
um
all right now we're cooking with
electricity
now we're cooking on an induction stove
um there's some uh there's some crazy
stuff happening in the Arsenal Aston
Villa Game by the way
um this is this is uh this is these are
two teams absolutely desperate for a win
all right what's going on my 2023 vision
board
um cooking with gas was literally a gas
Lobby slogan see Cheyenne that's how
they get you they make it fit the meter
and you think it's true
all right
now we're cooking with
electricity did that hurt more than the
punch no the punch hurt very bad it was
I felt the punch for hours
um Chris my best friend just said look
across the river but I can't I'm hosting
the project for awesome Chris
I assume he's right across the river
like waving waving at us okay
um okay so we're gonna start with uh
the 20
project
for
awesome and we're going to put in a
hashtag just to keep it fresh keep it
real 2009.
P 4A 2023 boom great start
okay
um now we're gonna do cooking
with
solar
derived
electricity
it doesn't fit the meter but it's better
okay so we're on to it we're off to a
roaring start here
oh Arsenal just scored while I was
writing cooking with electricity
um who scored
it's a big moment in the title race for
people who love arsenal
um did you mention that you have a
category on Jeopardy on February 20th
now
No in fact I saw your email about that
worry and I'm sorry I didn't respond to
it yet but um
I I didn't know until you emailed me
like I I had recorded the category so I
knew about that what a what a finish
um Good Golly Miss Molly
uh that was a heck of a whoa dang oh I
think it actually went off the
goalkeeper so it hit the post
oh and then it hit the goalkeeper in the
head and went into the goal oh it's a
humiliating own goal oh no oh God it's
the greatest own goal of all time it's a
perfect finish oh it's my favorite kind
of goal the only bad thing about it is
that it was uh Emmy dibu Martinez you
know Emmy dibu Martinez
um he uh held the goalkeeper of the
World Cup trophy up against his uh
midsection and then thrust with it
um
now we're cooking inductively that is
better okay
that's better I'm going to replace
cooking with to to now we're cooking
inductively thank you now where
cooking
in
deductively
all right so we gotta we got a good
vision board out here
um what a goal what a what a goal then
um that that that nice Ukrainian boy is
excited
um this is great
okay uh I'm not sure if it's a if it's
an own goal it is an own goal
technically
um because it wasn't a shot on goal it
wasn't going to go in if DB Martinez
wasn't there
um look at now Aaron ramsdale I kind of
want Arsenal to win the title because it
would be the first time that a former
Wimbledon player has won a premier
league title Aaron ramsdale
um used to be a Wimbledon player he was
he like kept us up single-handedly the
goalkeeper
um when he was like 18 years old and now
he's Arsenal's starting goalkeeper and
he he still comes to Wimbledon games
like if he has a weekend off he'll still
come to uh to plow Lane and I just I
just uh loved him and so I kind of want
Arsenal to win the title just for him
um
okay uh all right what else we got here
I'm so confused well I just got here hey
so this is the 2023 project for awesome
uh it's a charity fundraiser we
nerdfighteria has done every year since
2007 except for uh 2020. and
um we raise money right now we're
raising money for save the children and
Partners in Health to organizations that
work around the world
um on to help bring about a more just
world and support the world's most
vulnerable people uh we've raised
1.762 million dollars uh via project for
awesome.com donate thanks to everybody
who's donated and also all the people
who
um join the matching fund so that we
could raise all this money and now I'm
making a vision board in extremely slow
motion uh racks on racks on racks yes
racks on racks on racks and my vision
board is not a traditional vision board
um it's not what I want to happen
although maybe it is because I do want
racks on racks on racks and I know
you're confused because you don't know
what racks on racks on racks means but
racks is an American Roast Beef
restaurant that was huge in the 1980s
that is almost completely disappeared oh
deebu Martinez has come up for a last
second corner kick if DB Martinez scores
a goal here this will be one of the
greatest games in the history of the
Premier League it's Emmy Martinez the
goalkeeper a goalie goal is the only
thing more exciting than an own goal in
soccer a goalie goal is one of the most
thrilling it's not going to be a goalie
goal it's one of the most thrilling
things you got to shoot shoot the the
net is empty you gotta shoot the bull oh
shoot the ball shoot the ball the net is
empty
oh yeah he's gonna dribble it in it's
four to two it's a beautiful day for
Arsenal it's good for the goal
difference
um I'm excited for Aaron ramsdale look
at look at the togetherness in that team
that's what that's what I want all right
racks on racks on racks I like how
everybody's now just knows what to say
um
about racks uh James just mentioned
Jimmy glass can I tell you guys the
story of Jimmy glass real quick before
we finish this vision board so was it
Carlisle United
I think it was Carlisle United
so
there was this team called Carlisle
United okay and they were in the bottom
tier of professional football league two
uh in England the the lowest TB
elimination on the board
um yes
and
TB
now
it's ludicrous that a million and a half
people are going to die of tuberculosis
this year it's
it's horrifying
um
so Jimmy glass so Carlisle United had to
win their last game of the season in
order to stay in League two and not get
demoted down to being a
semi-professional team
and they had to they had to win
the last they and then they their
goalkeeper got hurt the week before and
so they got this goalkeeper on loan from
Swindon town named Jimmy glass
Jimmy glass like he didn't look like a
goalkeeper really he's sort of a big
dude
um sort of a uh
just sort of just sort of a round
rounded individual you know
um
and
the game goes
they're tied
they have to win there's despair there's
just brokenheartedness there's tears in
the stands as as the Carlisle fans begin
to understand that they are going to get
relegated that they are going to be out
of the football league that they are not
going to be a professional team anymore
that after 95 years of being a team in
the football league they are going to be
relegated out of it uh the fans know
that once you're out of the football
league you can you know you can just you
can just drop all the way down into
disappearing basically uh it's a it's a
brutal brutal thing uh it's an absolute
devastation for for a for a football
club to be relegated out of the football
league it's a much bigger deal than
being relegated out of the Premier
League or for that matter I would think
winning the Premier League because it's
this moment where like your Club goes
from being like a full-time professional
team to being Semi-Pro
and it's this huge moment it's the last
minute of uh extra time the goalkeeper
who's only been there for like two weeks
Jimmy glass trots up
the ball is kicked there's some
hullabaloo in the Box it falls not to
Jimmy glass's head but to his feet and I
probably don't need to tell you that
goalkeepers especially in the 1990s were
not known for their use of their feet in
scoring goals it falls to his feet and
Jimmy glass shoots the most perfect ball
into the net Carlisle United are saved
from relegation the club is basically
saved from dissolution all in that one
moment and the fans just pour out onto
the stadium they raised Jimmy glass up
which is no small feat they raised Jimmy
glass up this man who's only been part
of the club for like two weeks and they
uh
they like carry him atop their hands all
across the stadium at Jimmy glass is
like what the hell just happened to me
it's the most it's you got to watch it
you got to watch it on YouTube it's the
most beautiful thing and now Jimmy glass
is like an insurance salesman
um he never really had a career in
professional football but he did have
one of the greatest moments that a human
being can ever have
um he did it's it was magic
um so I really hope that season three of
Ted lasso ends with a goalie goal
because it is the most magical of goals
but what a result for Arsenal
togetherness I mean right now my friend
Daniel Alarcon is just going nuts he's
so ha he might be in tears he's probably
like hugging his kids I just I love to
think of my friends who love soccer and
like their moments even if it's not my
team
like my friend Craig who's a Watford
supporter I'd love to think of his
moments
um when I watch Watford I think about
how it feels for Craig like even when
like Watford beat Liverpool a couple
seasons ago I was very upset but I was
also like man I can't help but be a
little happy for Craig
so um this is uh this is yeah I that's
why I love football is because of the
narratives and like the narratives only
emerge like once every five years like
you only see a game like that like once
every five years but I there's something
in my heart that believes it's going to
happen each time you know what I mean
like
um like when I went to see rexham play
Sheffield United and everybody was like
we can't possibly win this game I was
like no you can't win this game but I
think you will like I can't in my heart
I always believe that David is about to
beat Goliath that the most amazing thing
is about to happen
um I don't know I just always believe
that uh
yeah so TB talk
um football stories and vision boarding
um did anyone get Bingo from that okay
um
will there be more map perks I'll pay
the big bucks yeah uh we can put up more
map perks
it's Carlisle United I might be wrong
about the football club I'm just trying
to tell a story Ashley you know like a
lot of times when I'm telling a story uh
with my friends or something Sarah or
one of my friends will interrupt to be
like that's not how it happened and I'll
be like guys
don't ruin the vibe with the facts
I'm trying to tell a story
um gotta put hummus on the board I'm
gonna put hummus on Sideways hummus
gotta make sure I spell hummus correctly
Jimmy glass was my last Bingo spot
actually
um hummus
it is Carlyle all right good you gotta
watch I mean honestly mute the stream
and watch the Youtube video of the
moment when Jimmy glass scored that goal
it's one of the greatest I might have to
watch it right now it's just it's just
incredible like you just you feel I
instead of Jimmy glass I just typed in
hummus
[Music]
[Laughter]
um and I love the fact that he's called
um
he's called I'm gonna watch it I'm gonna
watch it right now so they Trot up for
the corner kick I'm watching the
Carlisle's Great Escape Jimmy Glasgow
they tried for the corner kick the fans
are like you can do this here comes
Jimmy glass he's not quite as round as I
remember him but the fans are just like
this can happen we can do this this is
possible and here he comes and then the
ball is like saved and then Jimmy glass
I mean on the volley that is so
difficult I have no idea how he did that
and then the fans just storm
storm
the field they're in tears they can't
believe it they're trying to get off the
field and nobody's allowing them to it's
just it's magic like I I don't know what
it would be like to be in a
like have a moment like that Wimbledon
had one game like that we were almost
relegated out of the football league the
year that we got into it
um
and
but it was a little it was much less
dramatic than that basically in the like
60th minute Danny Cadwell
um got a penalty and Danny Cadwell
um
made the penalty and so we stayed in the
football league but it is it's just uh
I mean the drama
a football it's just beautiful and I
know everything else also has its drama
you know like I don't doubt for a second
that you know at every yeah it's like
it's a soap opera right and like I have
I have friends who watch uh like my
mentor watches uh Days of Our Lives and
has for 50 years and it's the exact same
thing like it's wrestling it's all the
exact same thing
um great finish there so um anyway yeah
all right
um Jimmy glass
I'm gonna put up I'm gonna put Jimmy
glass up on the board here Jimmy glass
Jimmy glass
Carlisle United
okay it's just a great this is going to
be a great Sports morning for me I've
got my uh Sarah's cousin he's going to
her first AFC Wimbledon game
um so I'm always excited about that I'm
always excited when I can get somebody
to plow Lane for an AFC Wimbledon game
because I really think that if you go
once you're a fan for life
um so yeah I think you got it if you
live in England or like go to England
you gotta go to an AFC Wimbledon game
it's like 25 bucks and it's the time of
your life
time in your life all right we're
starting to get a fairly good vision
board here together
um
and I will be uh I will be selling this
vision board
uh I don't know how but 100 gonna sell
it uh
so okay so um sorry John I'm in Wales
well yes and me I know how impossible it
is to get from Wales to England because
I just did it
it was it was four different trains
um rosiana and Sarah were joking have
you all seen that Japanese
um show that's on Netflix where
um there's a little child and they're
sent on a um they're sent on an
adventure they're told to like go to an
errand like walk to the um
walk to the grocery store or whatever
and like buy a banana
um
uh commit to the bit should go on the on
the on the
on the vision board as well that's
that's an important one we've got to
commit to the bit so that there I don't
remember what that show is called but
it's um basically it's called old enough
and they pin
um they like pin a little like you know
like sign onto the kid that says like
I'm on an adventure or whatever rosiana
and Sarah were joking that like when
they when when rosiana put me on the
train in London to like go to Wales that
I needed like one of those little pins
and then I was I was like the kid and
old enough who was like because it was
like eight nine pm on a Friday night and
I get on this train and they were like
you're gonna have to make three
different transfers and we know that's
right at the limit of your capability
um and so I like and it was right at the
women of my capability it was terrifying
um to try to uh
um
it was terrifying to try to uh find all
these trains and then on the last train
it's like midnight
I've been I've been awake for like 22
hours it's midnight I'm like in and out
of Consciousness holding all my stuff
and uh the train goes from Chester to
wrexham
and I think yeah Chester direct some
it's only like a 30 minute train trip
but uh
um and me I hope you don't take this
personally but like the quality of the
midnight Friday night
um train from Chester to wrexham it's
not like the newest train you'll ever be
on
um
but um
uh but yeah so I um uh I'm on this train
and it's it's it's not that crowded but
for some reason everybody who is on the
train is in my car and they're like all
talking to each other as if they've been
friends their entire lives but they're
telling each other like extremely
personal stories and they've just met so
like they've they've literally begun a
conversation in Chester and by the time
they get to wreck some they're like
talking about their deepest darkest
Secrets they're like they're friends
they've they're like they've been
friends for life and I was just like wow
um
I don't even know that I would like say
that stuff
you know to my spouse
so yeah uh oh my God those trains to
whales used to be buses well that is a
big Improvement
um 16 weeks to Glory yeah I'm gonna try
to I'm gonna try to Envision that into
being
um 16 weeks
the glory then I'm going to put a spiral
in here just that's that's just the vibe
I'm gonna do like dude
it's not my best spiral but it's a
spiral
um
anyone know if the raxling adventure
reward is part of the um
vision board perk at the end of this bit
oh yeah I want to do 10 uh how many maps
have I done Nikki
um I I would like to do more maps but I
also don't want to run out of maps
um you know I've done 20 total Maps
already
oh all right let's do five more Nikki
and and make them more expensive
um no we can save I I'll have to go
count but I think I have over a hundred
so I should be able to part with
35 of them
I mean it'll be sad
but it's possible yeah let's do that
that sounds good okay so
um while I've been Vision boarding uh of
course like the project for awesome has
has steamed on and
um I don't even know if I have a co-host
for any part of this
um I don't really I don't I don't know
what's happening because I've just been
Vision boarding and chatting but we've
raised 1.767 million dollars so I'm
going to go ahead and put that into my
um
into my little uh 1.7 because I think
we're getting close
1.767 million dollars incredible
um so this means that we are uh forty
eight thousand dollars away from having
raised 19 million dollars in the history
of the project for awesome so that's
pretty cool
um let's uh let's let's try to get there
um we're also now only uh about
eighty seven thousand dollars away from
our goal of seven hundred and seventy
seven thousand seven hundred and seventy
seven dollars and seventy seven cents at
the um at the tiltify and I want to
thank some of our uh recent donors who
include Dano and Jillian and Juliet and
Reed and Jennifer and Kate and Nicole
and giliar or gilliar uh I never I never
know whether to go with a heart or a
soft G also Anonymous just donated it
said another p4a another mystery perk
Anonymous donated three times actually
Tessa just donated us did Carly still
pushing for eat the menu at racks with
Keith I don't think Keith is going to be
into that
um
I listen here's what I'll say I I will
buy the entire menu at Rex you know I'm
not sure that I'm gonna have more than
one byte of any part of the entire menu
at racks but I don't think they have
that big of a menu
at least they didn't in the 1980s I
don't know I you know
um I've seen a couple pictures of people
who've been to racks people in
nerdfighteria who've been to racks and
um it doesn't look that good
it really it really doesn't look that
good but I'm excited to try it anyway uh
vendy says uh happy visioning and uh
Catherine just donated as did Ashley and
Austin and Sarah so thanks to everybody
who's donated
um here in the 2023 project for awesome
um all hype for the European P for a
crew Hannah Chico Joe with three
exclamation points uh manrique Tessa
Carly Stefan and eliska and Anonymous
all just donated as did Hummus
and three exclamation points Mary May
Megan Aaron Carrie Kim Clarice Zach and
Aaron who says this is such a wonderful
Community I love being able to directly
support these causes and all the money
that you donate especially if you get
the Jarvis is coming up on next hour the
maps are up so Aaron get to project for
awesome.com donate if you want one of
those Maps
um and also anyone else uh they're maps
that include that have aglo New York on
them which is a paper Town famous Paper
Town
I mean I don't know insofar as any paper
town is famous
and um I collect them I have I well I
should say I had the world's largest
collection of maps made by the general
drafting company of New York State
between 1937 and 1970. um although that
may change now that I'm selling a lot of
them for the 2023 project for awesome
but that just means that I can um go
back to the thrilling world of um trying
to collect more of those Maps
um I found them all over the place not
not just on uh auction sites but also
like uh at uh map stores there's stores
for map nerds and I've got a I've got a
guy uh who knows that I'm interested in
these Maps
and so he'll reach out to me sometimes
and be like hey I got one of those maps
and I'll be like great I will buy it uh
I just love them uh it's 16 weeks to
Gloria dear Hank and John thing not
exactly uh so I
I don't know if you've heard about
YouTube boxing but I'm fascinated by it
I um I'm actually right now uh here's an
interesting detail for you I'm I
hesitate to show you how incredibly
filthy this uh this room is but uh so
right now that's my tripod uh that I'm
um that my camera that my computer is on
that I'm live streaming from and you can
see here these four books
are all um books about boxing so this is
uh a book about uh the Joe Lewis uh Max
schmelling fight
um this is a book about Mike Tyson
um I think this this book I think this
book is really good I think it's cut
time it is yeah that's a really
interesting book
um and uh what what else do we got I got
um
uh I got Cinderella Man by Jeremy shop
um oh this is one of my favorites Walter
Dean Myers book about Muhammad Ali uh
called the greatest Walter Dean Myers
the greatest writing about the greatest
and then I've got
um two ton which is the story of uh Joe
Lewis and Tony galento
um
yeah
I uh
this wasn't my favorite book
um it's not my favorite boxing book but
it's good you know all boxing books are
good in their own way so um I used to be
the boxing reviewer for bookless
magazine and
you know boxing look uh there's no
justifying the violence uh fox say this
is the first thing I'd say about it
um but there's this there's this great
poem about it uh let me see if I can
find it I used to read it all the time
in the like um like when Esther and and
cattitude would uh would be um
um yeah here it is by Richard katrovis
when uh
oh no that's like a painting
um
oh yeah here it is here it is here it is
yeah so I used to read this poem
um in the old Blog TV days uh I just
because I it was from a book about it
was from a book of poems about boxing
and um
uh I really I like the poem uh I don't I
I'm very uh I I am of course deeply
trembled by boxing
um but I also think Muhammad Ali is a
great fighter I think vasilia lomachenko
is a great Fighter
um and uh
I think Clarissa Shields is a great
fighter I and I find there is a kind of
like there is a there is something in it
for but it's
but it's bad right like there's the
tension for me
um
um chat GPT thinks we're in NPC that's
that's uh that's true and it's good for
the vision board chat GPT thanks
I'm
an NPC
which is a source of concern for me
because I do not want
chat GPT to think I'm in NPC anyway
um
uh this poem uh has has in it like one
of my favorite uh lines
um
uh for fights redeem our sense of being
at once in and out of Nature and so map
the human route across the razor's edge
of slow Extinction such as the truth of
all destructive action transcending
histories of consequence and serving
therefore as a modeled lens unto the
bifurcated human heart whose one true
nature is to break apart
and that idea of things that serve as a
modeled lens onto the bifurcated human
heart is really interesting to me
um I think uh lots of things are like
that a lot of works of art are like that
a lot of um
sports are like that and so
anyway I was the boxing reviewer for
bookless magazine for a number of years
most of you have probably heard the
story of how I became the boxing
reviewer for bookless magazine so I
won't retell it but
um that's part of why I find YouTube
boxing so fascinating is that like
there's this history of boxing as a sort
of uh celebrity spectacle even way
before
um YouTube uh boxers and and just when
it seemed like that was all dead and
done for uh Here Comes YouTube boxing to
resurrect this ancient idea of having
celebrities
um fight each other like and in the
process become bigger celebrities and
having it be like one of the ways that
celebrities who don't have access to
traditional means of um of wealth
Generation
Um generate wealth and that's a very
dark history because it often involves
people you know who uh like if you think
about how do famous people get a lot of
money
um they get a lot of money either by you
know getting some some small slice of
the money that's generated by a much
larger Corporation by for instance like
being in a movie uh that benefits Warner
Brothers uh shareholders far more than
it will ever benefit the celebrity or
they get money by uh writing a book that
benefits the publisher far more than it
will ever benefit the author
um and so like traditionally people have
had to like participate in uh generally
have had to participate in this sort of
like capitalist exchange where uh the
corporation who controls the means of
production is always going to benefit
more than the peop than the people who
are doing the creation uh and so
boxing was sort of a dark
but at the same time efficient way for
people who maybe didn't like that
strategy or else like weren't able to
access it because those systems have
biases they're racist they're
misogynistic they're classists weren't
able to access those systems effectively
um and so you know would would wouldn't
instead do these um sort of boxing
exhibitions
often were like set up to not to make
sure that nobody got really hurt
and then we have YouTube boxing which
like resurrects all of this old late
19th early 20th centuries ideas about
like people committing violence against
each other as a way of generating uh uh
capital for their fame or capitalizing
on their Fame and I just think it's wild
I don't think it's I mean I just I it's
it's astonishing to me
um that it's happening you know like
that
surely I thought we were Beyond this but
we're not
um and so I thought it would be
hilarious if Hank and I boxed each other
and Hank is like it would be hilarious
up until the part where one of us got
punched in the face and then it would be
much less funny
um
and I was like oh yeah that's a good
point it probably wouldn't be that funny
like I think our community would be like
into the idea until or like some people
in our community would be into that idea
until they actually saw like Hank punch
me in the face and then they'd be like
nah man this is real messed up like this
is so messed up and so even if we were
um so even if we were participating in
it like only for Partners in Health and
it was raising a ton of money because
like you can't I mean some of these
things like with with the in-person uh
the in-person experience the
pay-per-view experience people make you
know over a million dollars so if we
could make over a million dollars for
Partners in Health like that's a huge
amount of money it's really hard to
raise that kind of money aside from the
project for awesome like it's you know
it's a lot of work to try to raise that
amount of money
um and uh
and so that part of it's compelling but
the part of it where we and so that part
of it's compelling but the part of it
where we'd have to hit each other is
just that's beyond the pale you know
like it would be so bad for uh it'd be
so bad for the community it'd be it'd
just be it's not the vibe you know like
we've worked really hard and like y'all
have been so supportive over the years
in not making it a rivalry like in never
making it about Hank or John always
making it about Hank and Sean
and so we were like no this is the wrong
it's the wrong approach but then we're
like What if we did like a 16 weeks to
Glory thing where for 16 weeks we
trained and trained and trained and then
it ended with some kind of physical
contest it's maybe not boxing and
somebody suggested a uh like an obstacle
course like one of those inflatable
obstacle courses and we were like that's
great that's amazing
um and then other people suggested uh
you could also like play chess or
something and I don't know Hank and I
can't play chess but like maybe we could
learn in 16 weeks to glory and maybe we
could do fencing
um and maybe we can do yeah so it'd be
bad for Martha so we can't do it that's
Martha just said it'd be bad for me it'd
also be bad for us be bad for everybody
but like an obstacle course wouldn't be
bad it'd be fun it'd be funny it'd be
weird one of those gigantic inflatable
obstacle courses that's like a child's
uh birthday present you know like you
you like some parents rent them for
their children
um
and uh so yeah we were like maybe 16
weeks the glory can happen the big
impediment to 16 weeks to Glory
happening is no longer that we don't
have the good idea because I think we
have a really good idea it's like the
quadragicon plus it's like the
quadragacon but more organized
um and um
and it's it's really potentially very
funny and lovely and like and it's it it
feels you know vastly more like
nerdfighteria than these exploitative
acts of violence and um and I just love
the idea the big impediment is that Hank
Green having 16 weeks to do anything is
unimaginable like I could I could do it
I could
um I could spend 16 weeks like getting
fit and learning how to play chess
I probably couldn't learn how to play
chess I don't have a spatial awareness
for it but um
but Hank can't I mean Hank Hank is Hank
is at the edge and cassette because Hank
is at the far edge of what's possible
right now
um so yeah it's the the problem with 16
weeks is not the glory it's the 16 weeks
too
um yeah so I I think chess is really fun
and beautiful and I like watching people
play chess but I don't um I'm one of
those people who when I close my eyes
and I try to picture an apple I don't
see anything like I just I don't I I
don't I don't see anything like the
other day
um and I don't have a sense of I don't
have a map in my head so I don't have
any sense of direction in order like in
a lot of a lot of cases in order to
drive somewhere in Indianapolis I drive
to my old house because I know the route
from my old house
um like if my if I don't have GPS that's
what I have to do
and I don't um like if I if I like Sarah
will be like sometimes Sarah will be
like So Close Your Eyes what color is
the rug and I'm like how could I
possibly know that my eyes are closed or
like I yeah it's just it's it's a it's a
weird thing about me
um that I used to feel really
embarrassed about but now I understand
that it's just like it's just it's just
not there whatever that thing is that
people have just isn't there so when I
look at a chessboard like I know how all
the pieces move and I know where I could
move all the pieces but I have no idea
what's going to happen to moves from now
um no idea like I watched like Magnus
Carlson play chance and people are like
that's so beautiful and I'm like I agree
I mean he he knows it's going to be mate
in seven
what
I don't even know when it's going to be
made in one I get like utterly surprised
when I'm playing chess against some like
seven-year-old like uh Chris and
Marina's kid plays chess with me
sometimes and he'll be like that's
Checkmate and I'll be like is it
like
um yeah so
there's just nothing there nothing and I
I don't know if that is part of why I
write
um
I don't know it must be
because there are words there like I can
think of how to describe things but I
really I I mean this is something I
struggle with in writing fiction even is
that like it's really hard for me to
describe a room I am not in
um you know like like I wrote a lot
about the corner of 86th and ditch
because I was sitting in a Starbucks
looking at the corner of 86th and ditch
like I was looking at that gas station
where Gus is trying to buy cigarettes I
was uh looking at the Applebee's where
Asia and Daisy um you know are are in
the parking lot having a fight
um I I see these things
um imaus says what is happening hey this
is the 2023 project for awesome an
annual fundraiser that nerdfighteria has
where we've raised over 1.75 million
dollars uh here in the first 22 hours of
our 48-hour
um charity Extravaganza you can learn
more at project for awesome.com or don't
donated project for awesome.com donate
in fact let's thank some recent donors
it's 10 o'clock I gotta turn on the
Wimbledon game
and I'm not even halfway done with this
vision board oh I'm just I'm not I'm not
doing a good job hosting this morning
all right hold on let's get the
Wimbledon game on that's Priority One
all right where am I gonna oh oh I can
put it over here amazing all right so
I'm gonna put the Wimbledon game on
right over here
let me I'll show you my set oh no oh no
oh god oh no panic panic stations
that's okay can you can we play them uh
oh it seems Frozen nope it's back all
right so I think I can just do that and
then all right let me show you my setup
here this is pretty I don't want to brag
but this is pretty impressive
um Jarvis is joining in 15 minutes great
always a pleasure to be in his company
uh so this is the setup there's there's
the Wimbledon game it's just on that
little phone but I'll be able to see if
there's a goal there's like a there's a
scoreboard and everything
okay
um what oh no something's off about this
there's
there we go I think that's a little more
balanced okay
um we gotta finish this um AFC Wimbledon
I think they're playing Hartlepool
just one of those places that sounds
made up
um I'm gonna write Panic stations
um do like is panic stations a real
thing do you think do you like
do actual
like does the army ever say like Panic
stations
or do they have a different phrase for
it
um
I don't know
um yes Jarvis Johnson is going to be
here in 15 minutes
Panic stations uh we got to fill out
this uh we got to fill out this oh
Valerie Valerie 2776 is here
The Original Pizza John
always nice to be in your company
um anybody else got
um oh um
I'm gonna write raxcellence
because that is the new Excellence we no
longer go for excellence in this family
we go for excellence
okay that's good I would say that we're
a little over halfway there
um trans writes on the vision board yes
thank you
it's interesting when I go when I go all
Captain when I don't I don't I don't
understand that
um but but there's something to it okay
um
oh that moment that Alice tasted diet Dr
Pepper was um was just magic it was just
magical uh so far AFC Wimbledon are tied
with Hartley pool
uh but they're playing at plow Lane say
it's like mostly full it's hard to get
excited about heart go pool
um
uh what's a vision board okay so this is
a vision board traditionally vision
boards you know are like people being
like um
here's my vision for the future or
whatever but my vision board is just
it's just um
yeah just like this
um oh I got one I'm gonna write um uh
a modeled lens
onto
the
bifurcated
human heart
whose
one
true
nature
is to
break
apart
still a good line I don't know if it's
true but it's a good wine
um I love I love a line like that
Jimmy glass is on the board Jimmy glass
and Carlisle United are on the board
um it's heart toll pool no it's heartgle
pool it's got to be heartless pool
um heartla pool right it's not heartle
pool Hartlepool sounds like a fake place
uh excited for Jarvis Johnson what a
lovely surprise I agree uh much love
from Saudi Arabia thanks Sam uh
okay does anyone else have um oh
prescription goggles that's good
um
I'm just a prescription snorkeling
we're getting there we've almost got a
vision board together I'd love to have
this done before Jarvis gets here
because I think it'd be weird for him
prescription snorkeling
[Music]
um given entropy isn't everything's one
true nature to break apart it's true
it's true that's why um that's why these
things that help us to understand that
everything falls apart are helpful but
everything also comes together
or at least came together you know what
I found out recently most of the
hydrogen atoms in your body right now
which is a lot of your body are um came
were created in the first two minutes of
the Universe
um
your your hydrogen
is
big
big bang
stuff
yeah so about like two minutes into the
universe when things started to cool
down a little bit we got uh hydrogen
atoms and most of the hydrogen atoms
that are inside of your body were
created then
um what is a vision board well I don't
really know what a vision board is but
this vision board is a collection of
things that I either want to happen or
don't want to happen or find interesting
or was thinking about
um
I I think that my my handwriting isn't
very good which I think is going to hurt
the um the price of this uh vision board
but you know we're doing our best all
right we need like three more things for
the vision board maybe those can wait
um
but yeah your hydrogen is really really
old which means like in some ways like
at least part of you is around at the
very very beginning like part of you is
13.8 billion years old
which is really really really weird to
think about
um like your consciousness of course
isn't 13.8 billion years old but some
parts of you are
um some parts of you are about two
minutes younger than the universe
or maybe even a minute 45.
um I already have tuberculosis
um on on the vision board uh I'm not
going to root for wrexham promotion
necessarily Gustavo because those those
folks are just going to Rampage through
League two
um it's a real it's a real worry for us
um
Hartwell pool nickname is the monkey
hangers because they hung a shipwreck
monkey during the Napoleonic Wars
thinking it was a French spy
surely that's not true foreign
that's not true
[Laughter]
possibly be true
that can't be true
isn't that true did they hang a monkey
did they imagine others complexly
did they did they really hang a monkey
did they hang a monkey during
during the Napoleonic Wars because they
thought it was a French spy
[Music]
did they think it was a person did they
think that French people were monkey
like what how did that work
I talked about it on my podcast oh I
don't remember any of the things I ever
said in the podcast I I have no memory
of of ever saying that
um I have no memory of that that is
um yes uh the
um French
yes
Napoleon's
monkey
spy
uh
uh take
I've done this all wrong by the way
take
a journey
of
meaning
Hank being on a journey of meaning is
one of my favorite
um jokes I made a video about it I made
a video about it called the monkey
hangers no way there's no I can see that
I mentioned it in a podcast but there's
absolutely no way I made a video about
it
that's impossible I do remember God dang
it I did make a video about it
I made a video about it oh my God who is
that young promising handsome and I
think miserable person when when was
this video uploaded I can always I look
miserable in this video even though I'm
like uh very young and thin and I was I
was miserable oh my God I can always
tell that was like the worst part of my
mental health
um of the last 20 years right then
um November of 2015 was the worst
um so no wonder I don't remember it I
was very unwell uh I can't believe I
made a whole video about the Hartlepool
monkey and I have absolutely no not only
do I have absolutely no memory of not
making that video
I have absolutely no memory no memory of
Hartlepool being called the monkey
hangers because they
hung a monkey during the Napoleonic Wars
thinking it was a French spy
uh uh yeah
but oh my gosh I was miserable then the
video is called monkey hangers and I
mean I haven't watched it I'm gonna
watch it later but um yeah that's wild I
was not a uh I was not not not in a good
space that was like from like
September to like late December 2015 was
just the worst
um it's weird too because like I was on
top of the world from the uh from the
from an outside perspective that's often
the case though
um
you know like my career was going so
great and yada yada yada and like I was
uh
yeah I was not well oh yeah yeah I
um talk more about Hartlepool oh my God
I ca I can't talk more about heart I
don't know how to watch something on
stream I'm not I'm not a twitch streamer
y'all I don't know how to like do the do
that thing that people do where they
watch something on screen
um but uh oof 2015.
I can't believe I made a video that I
don't remember that is weird that's
weird that I made a video I don't
remember at all
God
I mean I have made a lot of videos but
still it's very weird
um yeah not
not remembering
most
of 2015.
it's it's going on the vision board
um
ants
hope
feathers
uh my son just texted me he just got a
phone and he texts me YouTube shorts all
the time
usually YouTube stories about Dungeons
and Dragons all right I did it just
before Jarvis gets here I did it
um I uh
uh I I made I made a vision board it's a
complete vision board
um I'm not gonna say it's a major work
of art but now we're cooking inductively
NTB now not remembering most of 2015
Panic stations raxellence trans right
through human rights prescription
snorkeling chat GPT thinks I'm an NBC
commit to the bit hummus hummus racks on
racks on racks all right there's my
vision board
um
I don't know if anybody's gonna buy that
but we can I'm not afraid to put it up
is what I what I what I will think
2015 is around when I started watching
um
vlogbrothers yeah Henry has a phone
because like when now I don't know if
this is universal but like all of all
and like I know that we shouldn't do
things just because all of Henry's
friends do them and like all of our
friends do them but like everybody gets
a phone when they turn 13 in
Indianapolis it feels like like
everybody
like all of Henry's classmates got
phones when they turned 13 all of the
like all the kids in the neighborhood
got phones and I just felt like
I don't know plus like now I I he does
so much stuff like after school or like
over at a friend's house that like I
need him to be able to call me
um so
yeah uh Aditi said it's good to know
where your kids are etc etc and that's
exactly what it is like it's good to
know where your kids are etc etc but at
the same time I feel very weird about
him having a phone but I also feel weird
about him being a teenager uh so yeah
yeah he's 13 and when you're 13 like you
know you got to start to figure out how
you're going to use technology and all
that jazz I got an email from Google
that was like hey he's almost 13 and
when he turns 13 he can have his own
control of his own Google account and he
can make his own YouTube account and he
can subscribe to his own YouTube videos
and it's just like man that's weird God
that's weird
um
yeah it's just it's just weird uh Sarah
got a flip phone when she was 13 so that
makes me feel better but yeah Henry's a
teenager uh it goes fast y'all it goes
real real fast
um
so I don't know if when Jarvis will be
joining us but uh he'll he'll just kind
of pop in
um yeah
I know so yeah Google uh that's the rule
though there's like a law that like once
you're 13 you can be marketed to
basically and Google's excited about
that moment you know like for for Google
that 13th birthday is the single most
important birthday in a human being's
life because now they can be targeted
like at last
but
uh when did I get a phone poof uh good
question Gustavo I got a phone very late
so I was I was very technophobic which
will surprise absolutely no one um who
was here yesterday as I was trying to
figure out how to bid on the Adventure
Time watch which nobody else was having
a problem with I of all the people who
are on the internet as their job I am
the worst at the internet
like I'm just unbelievably bad at uh at
Tech stuff I'm a terrible video editor
epically bad I've made zero improvements
in the quality of my video editing in
the last 10 years
um and uh anyway I uh I got a phone so
here's the story of how I got a phone
um oh okay Jarvis is here we're queuing
him in I'll tell the story of how I got
a phone afterwards Here Comes Jarvis
hopefully hello hey hello how's it going
is this working is everything working
you sound great you sound like a proper
twitch streamer you've got that that's
real good yeah I've got the setup don't
let the looks deceive you I think um so
it's 7 A.M here and I woke up pretty
recently and so I have I don't want to
say how recently
um I have have you ever woken up with a
much deeper voice than you'd normally do
oh yeah yeah so that's what I I feel
like I can do like the Don LaFontaine
like in a word oh no I can't actually
I'm losing my voice a little bit it
turns out uh but you can you know what
you sound like though you sound like a
uh like a like an evening DJ on our
radio station yeah
smooth jazz yeah smooth jazz yeah
exactly
it's got I mean I it's working
so I was watching the stream
um for you know since I've been awake
and what I've had a couple of
observations I wanted to talk to you
about it great
um one
uh I do think a vision board is for like
planning it like your outlook on like
the world and your like your goals and
stuff and I do believe you just wrote
things down
foreign
tuberculosis okay
um I want to not remember most of 2015.
oh okay yeah I want feathers
um I take it all back you're not wrong
you're not wrong I have a different
approach to Vision boarding from most um
productivity YouTubers and that makes
you a Visionary if you think about it
that's right that's right
um the fact that Henry is almost 13 is
made me very conscious of the passage of
time
because I think I've been watching your
video since before he was born
oh well I mean first off thank you but
also I am yeah I mean I feel conscious
of the passing of time because I
remember when you were like uh like a
child uh oh yeah I'm not a real child
but like when you were like in your very
early 20s just starting out I remember
like meeting you at an early VidCon and
and you being like kind of uh just like
so sweet and a little nervous and Big
Time now I watch your videos and I'm
like oh God they're so good
I okay so this is gonna I I want to
bring something to your attention and
because uh another thing I observed is
you complete you forgot about a video
you made yeah when I say that when I say
the name page railstone does that ring a
bell yeah that that
was I mean Paige railstone was so far
ahead of its time I I agree you know who
made Paige railstone Karen Cavett who
now has like the most successful jigsaw
puzzle Channel on YouTube
oh that's amazing yeah I
I remember like uh it was like 2009 on
like Ustream yeah
typical streaming you know it was not
twitch it wasn't Justin TV it was like
no something else
it was YouNow or Vlog TV or something oh
you now that really rings a bell wow
yeah yeah you now would pay people like
a thousand bucks a month to like stream
for 100 hours and we'd be like what a
deal
I do think that like I have the utmost
respect for twitch streamers like as a
career app because it is one of the most
grueling
I mean I do like I do I I'm gonna host
12 hours of the project for awesome in
48 hours and at the end of it I'm gonna
like sleep for a day and a half yeah
there's a lot of streamers who host 12
hours out of every 48 hours every week
every day every two months understand
yeah and now I have friends who just
like they're like oh yeah I'm gonna be
streaming for the next eight hours and I
I as someone who has tried to do that do
not understand how it works because I'm
I like being able to take breaks I like
being able to like like sort of pull the
power plug and kind of like like sink
into your chair
yeah one of the I so I've I've thought
about making this video
um
over the years and I don't know that I
ever will because it's logistically
quite complicated but I sometimes
um I sometimes like stop recording in my
mind before I before I hit the button uh
and so you can see my body challenge
because you're you're sort of like even
when even when you're not like
performing performing you're still in
sort of a performative space you're
aware of the fact that you are watching
you don't want to say anything
um that you you know you wouldn't want
your mother to hear like you know you
got all that stuff going on in your mind
at the same time and then when you
whenever you stop you do like yeah I
mean I think I think a lot of people can
relate to this who
work from home and do like Zoom calls
with work you know you want to present
yourself as like uh you know your your
business up here and then maybe you've
got your like pajamas you know like
below the frame and uh you maybe don't
want to be there because there's
probably too many meetings at your job
and uh yeah I I've been on that side of
it too and it but yeah and you get off
that Zoom call and you have that same
feeling of like roof yeah exactly the
idea of not having that feeling for
eight straight hours is unimaginable to
me like if I was in an eight hour
meeting
um I would turn my camera off yeah I
would take a nap I would fall asleep
know like yeah I would fall asleep I
would like have a little like machine
that makes your keyboard uh just like do
one thing every 10 minutes
um right oh yeah it keeps it away
yeah I would have yeah I don't have a
gif that played on my camera that like
made it seem like I was awake right
right like were you not every 20 seconds
yeah yeah it it is it is really hard to
imagine
um especially like that twitch streamer
life like it just seems so difficult to
me I agree but
but they you know like people must get
in a flow where it must be worth it to
them I think so and but I the reason I
um brought that up is because I think
now we're starting to have conversations
about the like
the labor involved in all of those hours
because twitch has these incentive
programs for ads and they're like hey
you know you get a 600 bonus if you just
stream an extra 200 hours this month and
I'm like does that even does the map
even work out on that do those hours
exist in the day yeah right right
and and um it's it's you know we've made
progress as uh in terms of like making
it a more stable career but I think that
many streamers do not feel like that
stability despite the fact that they've
got you know hundreds if not thousands
of people who show up to their to their
streams every day but
I guess this is the the life we chose I
I you know I'm sure you remember a time
before YouTube monitor like YouTube
being seen as the incumbent stable
career right yeah yeah yeah that is is
now super interesting right like people
on Tick Tock are always like follow me
on YouTube
um because that's where I meet people
like I gotta figure out my YouTube and
I'm like well it seems like you've got
some stuff going but I understand why
yeah well and then like the the money of
it is so weird like the the way that I
mean and this is something that I've
learned a lot about from from you and
the way that you talk about the the
Creator economy as I guess it's called
but like the
the divorce between Fame and and wealth
is so weird that like you know Gabby
Dunn tells a story or get get Gabe done
sorry tells a story about
um
uh working like at a at a clothing store
and having people come in to like
say hello yeah and like have a fan
moment but being like but I'm I work at
the Gap
I I can't have you here at work
I had be that person I've experience
this in a small way not in my own life
but parasocially because there is a uh a
Japanese reality show called Terrace
House
that is essentially like the real world
um except for it's a bunch of like
Japanese early like like 20 somethings
trying to find their their purpose in
life it's very wholesome in general wow
but one of the people on the show was a
barista and they had like won some like
latte art competitions and stuff and I
was visiting Japan for whatever reason
and I was like oh it'll be it'll be cool
to go to the cafe that this person like
used to work at and then they were just
there and there were people like who
like were taking photos with them and
stuff and I was like this is so bizarre
yeah they're at work
because like they have to work
it now it feels like you're a mascot or
something that you have two Beverages
and one juice box and one is a Starbucks
company that's beautiful yeah
I um I was scrambling to I I don't know
what it is I I'm comforted by the juice
box
I love it I think it's great
um yeah that is it's so it's so and and
and I I agree with you that like we have
not yet totally we've not yet even
really begun to Grapple with all the
complexities and unintended consequences
of this of this Creator economy but a
big part of it is that people are
um people I think especially like when
the dream comes true uh or people have
to Grapple with the reality that the
dream is very very far away from the
dream they've been sold and that it's
it the the hours that you're asked to
work the things that you're asked to
give up the like level of privacy and
and and personal life and that sort of
like public anonymity that we all feel
or most of us get to feel when we go to
the grocery store like giving that up
and not getting
Financial Security in exchange right um
is a is a weird weird thing and and so
we've got all these people working 80
hours a week making
a middle income kind of life without you
know without building toward like it's
not like being a a lawyer or an
anthropologist
um where you're hopefully like building
toward tenure or partner like
uh there's not a lot of people who are
70 who do this there's not a lot of
people who've been doing it for 30 years
and so we don't even really know what
the long long long-term career looks
like for most rifle exactly it's a it's
a very hard thing to like that gap
between the expectation and reality is
also
why creator
spaces and and sort of places for
creators to like meet and talk are
really important because yeah you know
uh it's a very alienating experience
um to probably a lot of people in your
life because everyone's like you made it
why aren't you happy about this you know
or or why do you have problems it seems
like you've you know done everything
yeah yeah you're supposed to yeah and um
and it it is still like the you still
experience the range of human emotion
and and you you do kind of lose a little
bit of the like empathy from from
um from your audience if you're like woe
is me but it's like oh but you're the
big person on the screen you know
right yeah and and they're kind of
they're kind of right to struggle with
empathy on some level they are right
yeah absolutely man it is really good
and like your problems are better than
your problems used to be but it's it's
funny we were talking about that um that
Hartlepool video which I had completely
forgotten existed because that was the
that was the hardest period of my adult
life other than the period where like I
was in just a state of of of collapse
and and was in big big trouble in my um
in my early 20s
um and it was 2015. I
I had like literally lived my dream you
know like everything I ever wanted in a
writing career had happened and
um and I had Financial Security total
Financial Security for the for the first
time in my life uh I had you know like I
was selling more books than I ever could
have imagined selling I was uh thin I
was able to afford a Burberry uh suit I
went to Burberry I bought a suit
um
you know life was really good except
that I was in like real trouble like I
was in real real trouble and really
really miserable and it was scary it was
awful it sucked and you're right I
couldn't talk about it
um which was part of what sucked about
it
and also I didn't understand it you know
like I didn't understand I was miserable
because I I was so happy to I I was I
was I knew that objectively all this
stuff was amazing and was great
I just happen to also be seriously
seriously depressed and I really didn't
understand that until
um until I started to get therapy and
got um
started to take medication and like
eventually what I realized was that um I
had lived someone's dream but I hadn't
really lived my dream you know like my
dream I was kind of living my dream
before the Fault in Our Stars came out
when nerdfighteria was awesome and Paige
and we were making page railstone right
right there was yeah there was this like
that was a weird time because I remember
I was in college
when uh the fall North stars came out
and I like it was a thing where you were
doing the thing where you were signing
pre-orders
um and so I like pre-ordered the book I
got it and then it like became this big
thing and I was like Oh you mean like
our little internet thing you know what
I mean yeah for you too I was like why
is our little internet thing um now like
in in pop culture I don't I don't know
um and that so that was part of it but I
think the other thing was that like I
didn't
um I didn't like now now I feel much
more comfortable with it because I can
say like oh well like the reason that
happened is so that we could do this
project with PIH the reason that
happened is so that I focused for two
years on on making crash course and not
worry about making having a job
um you know and just like go full time
into
you know doing doing crash course and
and trying to make educational video uh
and I can so I can see it see it in
retrospect and say like oh I'm really
really glad all that stuff happened so
that I could do this stuff that I love
but at the time like I was I I didn't
feel that I wasn't able to feel that I
wasn't you're the fog of everything you
know yeah yeah yeah and it was really
overwhelming and kind of scary and I
felt like I couldn't tell anybody about
it
um so yeah it was it was hard but also
like these are the biggest it's hard too
because they're the best problems you
can have right like I mean but like if I
if I died
um which wasn't impossible like right I
I I I would still have died you know
right no it's true it still would have
you know
yeah I think I think um it is
like I've experienced you know my own
versions of these sort of keeping up a
public appearance while like privately
I'm like dealing with something very
difficult and
I think one of the things that
I am very grateful and you mentioned
this to have access to is like mental
health care like I you know
um yeah
I've been I think I've been in therapy
maybe you know five six years now and I
wouldn't say that I have like any sort
of like in my head therapy was like I
have a major problem that I need to
solve but in reality it's like I have a
lot of little problems and I and those
things can and sharing that context over
years and over time with you know uh my
therapist has helped give me a lot of
clarity and understanding about my own
experience
um yeah and also like kind of helped me
even get
context like longitudinally I guess you
could say like when you look back at the
progress that you've made
to myself it's very much like looking at
a mirror and going to the gym every day
where you don't notice the change uh if
you if you're like um let's say you're
losing weight or or toning your body or
something you might day in and day out
look at yourself in the mirror and look
at the same person in the mirror but
then you go to Thanksgiving dinner or
something and you see your mom for the
first time and they go oh my God you're
so skinny or oh my God you look so
different that is like the experience I
have of my therapist where they can go
couple years ago we talked about a very
similar scenario and that triggered you
in a particular way right I want to call
out the progress that you've made you
know and I'm like whoa that's cool
because I took all that for granted yeah
I mean I I I that's very much the
experience I just had when I saw the
like first five seconds of that video
that I don't remember making from
November of 2015.
you know like I saw that guy and I knew
instantaneously like I I knew like three
frames in like oh my God like that guy
had a chiseled Jaw but um he was in big
trouble
yeah
he was uh really really really really
really miserable and um and and and
really seriously depressed and
overwhelmed with OCD stuff and um so
yeah it sometimes it does take that um
sometimes it does take take that you
need that long-term view you know um to
be reminded that that it's possible I
had that experience recently actually
because I was um
went hiking with with my friends in in
Red River Gorge this uh beautiful place
in Kentucky it's like Yellowstone but in
Kentucky and um I was uh like walking on
the edge of a 600 foot cliff and I was
anxious but I was doing it and I I
thought to myself man it used to be I
couldn't like stand on a chair right you
know that's those types of things it's
like uh that's something that like maybe
to the outside from from a complete
bystander that may not look like a big
thing but in your head because you were
aware of like the distance between those
two actions and like how much progress
had to happen between those two things
you can really experience that like
rewarding feeling of progress
right yeah yeah and I think it's
important to note that like you know
unfortunately in the U.S because of the
way and and I think this is true in much
of the world because of the way mental
health is uh sidelined and marginalized
and thought of as like less important
than physical health even though like
for the record they're all the same
thing like yeah you know like in Sierra
Leone and in a lot of countries in West
Africa um epilepsy is treated by
psychiatrists and at first I was like
that's so weird like epilepsy is not a
psychiatric disease it's a neurological
disease and then a Sierra leonean
psychiatrist said to me like well
they're all neurological diseases you
know like depression is also a
neurological disaster yeah LPD is also a
neurological disease like you have this
framework in your head even though you
yourself like are a mental health
patient that like right you have a
framework that like mental health
diseases are somehow like a little less
real or like a little less
um a little less important and right and
it's invisible right yeah and part of
the reason that so many people don't
access to mental health care and part of
the reason we don't take it as seriously
as we do we don't fund it as seriously
as we need to
um and so unfortunately so many people
who would benefit from
um therapy and medication are unable to
access it and we need to see that as
like a global problem that we globally
need to address together
um in poor countries but also in in rich
ones where there's still that inequality
of access right a 100 I mean
well said I think that there's like
there's
I I'm not an expert here but like the
way that I view the world it's like
there's two there's two challenges
there's like a social one and then
there's like an access practical like
access one because there is like social
stigma that even in the face of access
people are unwilling to seek help you
know that's like I'm sure we've all got
those like family members who are afraid
to go to the doctor or not afraid to go
to the doctor but just like I don't need
it right or it's like kind of ignore
um ignore problems that they had like I
had um
like without going into too much detail
very close family members of mine that
experienced
very kind of textbook
um
uh symptoms of
like you know hearing voices seeing
things paranoia that like affected my
life in a very negative way and and
because there's no one anywhere to sort
of get that person the care that they
needed
um the people in that person's life were
kind of I don't want to say victims but
sort of
uh yeah by the actions that that of that
person took yeah and it's so hard to get
people care
um in the US at least when they really
need it like when it is an emergency it
can be so so hard and yeah that has
negative impacts on families it has
negative impacts on and and and and it
it ends up having like you know horrible
horrible impacts on society as a whole
um and that's part of it we just we have
to we have to take this more seriously
and since the 1980s we I really think in
a lot of ways like we've we've taken
steps backwards which is super
frustrating in terms of access to mental
health care and like being able to
really intervene you know help people
who are in crisis
I think it's starting to change I mean
there's you know there are great
organizations out there who are working
to make that change and um but but it
has to it also has to happen at the at
the government level like it also has to
happening level like you can't you can't
build a Health Care System only with
private money
um as America has found out over and
over again yeah I mean I
I do want to call out I think the chat
is pointing out that you reached a new
Milestone 1.8 mil gay
good job using the phrase the chat oh
yeah that's I look I don't stream for 12
hours but I do pop in every now nice
work in using chat I gotta start doing
I gotta started
the comments are telling me because you
know right you know uh the this is like
I I wouldn't say this is like the
world's biggest problem but one thing
that we tried to do at patreon when I
was there was to try and like remove
like gendered language from like
addressing a group so like like guys you
know that's what you think as a company
we could like kind of avoid it and so
you get all these team gang you know
like all that all that kind of stuff and
uh I love chat and I love y'all because
the journey y'all has been on yeah is
incredible because I
I always said y'all growing up because
I'm right me too I grew up in Alabama
and so yeah yeah so and very natural for
me to say say y'all and then um I like
got older and I was like oh no I can't
say y'all because it's embarrassing and
people are gonna I'm people are gonna
know I'm from Alabama and now
um I've come all the way back around to
y'all what a great word it is
oh one second
uh oh well we were just talking about
turning off the camera when you can't
take it anymore
yeah this is I just unplugged the power
I had a battery die on me
it's all right we've all been there yeah
um yeah well this has been an
unexpectedly deep and joyful
conversation why you know we try to I I
think we like got to have the experience
the whole cycle of everything I have one
last question for you before we part
ways great what did it taste like to
blend the Happy Meal do you remember it
oh yeah
um you know what it made me like looking
back at it because I so I have this
disease called eosinophilic esophagitis
where some people get it really really
bad and they can't like eat
um solid food really and then they have
to blend their food and like I'll tell
you what I wouldn't blend a Happy Meal
I'd go for like spaghetti and meatballs
probably or something something with
some acid meat oh yeah but oh sweet holy
Jesus it was so bad like because you
could taste the like the fat almost like
kind of separated from the other
towel the wickeds were like pulled out
of both the hamburger and the french
fries so you sort of tasted them
separately almost like a sort of white
horror
um
yeah not good
oh man
um well now once you leave I'm going to
tell the story of Paige railstone
um because I think lots of people don't
know it but it is it's at all thank you
for reminding me of Paige railstone
because wow we were really we were ahead
of the curve on that one there's a lot
there's a lot to be said about that I
mean it was pretty V tubers it was
pretty like real streaming personalities
yeah um yeah it fooled uh Akinator that
um oh yeah that like 20 questions
yeah yeah and that's still around
is it really it is it is like I knew I
made it when I came up on Akinator and I
was like me and Paige railstone like
this
I love it
I love it uh Jarvis it's such a pleasure
to be in your company congratulations on
all your success keep up the good work
um I'm just such a fan of yours and
getting to uh follow your work and know
that we played a little part of your uh
growing up just means the world to me oh
I mean likewise and congrats and it's a
you know an honor for me to be a part of
project for awesome because it's
something that I've you know watched
from the sidelines for so many years so
keep up the good work
um and enjoy the rest of the stream I uh
Reserve yourself as much as you can and
um
Wimbledon wins the game and that'll be a
little boost for you yeah uh uh fingers
crossed
all right cheers all right
uh that was Jarvis Johnson everybody uh
long time nerdfighter
um long time uh YouTuber an amazing
person
um such a such a fan of Jarvis
um so
page railstone back in 2009 in the Blog
TV days in the Esther Earl cateitude uh
days of vlong brothers and uh we
had this idea to make a fake person to
create a person who doesn't exist using
Photoshop like blending together a bunch
of faces to create a new face and this
was before way before deep fakes
um but we had this idea and then Karen
Cavett of Karen puzzles designed page
railstone who was a DJ
um you know like one of those like 2009
electronic music DJs
um and she had her own Facebook page uh
and slowly we like tried to convince the
internet that she was real and
um
and uh it worked like Paige railstone
still has a Facebook page and like if
and and it's the only uh like Facebook
page that I administer and so every
couple weeks I'll get an email from
Facebook that's like page railstone has
two new followers
so yeah that was a lovely conversation
and went in so many unexpected uh
directions and I'm so grateful
um to Jarvis for um being so open I hope
I I hope I didn't seem um
too out of touch with my uh my my
complaints about celebrity but it was
just interesting to have that
um coalesce with that experience of
seeing myself in 2015 making a video I
didn't know about
um
that was really uh really
strange and Powerful for me
um is tiltify down for anyone else panic
panic stations Panic stations
okay it's not down for me
um I'm gonna get this John and rosiana
exclusive podcast about tomorrow and
tomorrow and tomorrow and see if I can
actually buy it
um make sure that I can donate here and
I'm going to use the PayPal if that's
okay and make sure that tiltify isn't
down because that would be uh cause for
some concern somebody just told me that
AFC Wimbledon are winning which is true
and it's about to be half time
um that's great did anyone see the goal
um
did anyone see the goal was it was it
good was it hideous was it sort of
prototypically
um
hideous
um those are my favorite AFC Wimbledon
goals were like you don't even really
know who scored because it was just
nasty it was just a nasty goal mouth
scramble
um okay it's not down for everybody it's
just down for you sorry about that
um
yeah so uh I just bought a podcast so
that's good
um we're at 726 almost 727 000 raised I
by the way I have to belated the
um launch one of one of these fellas
into the world
kapow
um to say thank you for helping us get
to
1.8 million dollars
um raised
um
uh
uh we're gonna do uh before I leave
we're gonna do one
um featured video uh so we're at 1.8
million dollars uh let's launch the
vision board perk
did she really say that all right we're
going to launch the vision board perk at
five thousand dollars
and then if it doesn't sell we'll uh
we'll lower the price this is my vision
board
I will send it to you
I don't know how to make sure that it
doesn't
um like in the sending
die
it was made with dry erase markers is
there a way to permicize dry erase
markers
um yeah I don't know uh
but um
but yeah if you want to donate to
Partners in Health and save the children
um and know where the money that you
donate is going all of it will go to PIH
and save the children you do have to
donate in the next hour after that
um we will be
um the audacity to sell whiteboard with
potentially erasable ink at five
thousand dollars I love it well there
you go I'm doing it
um Saran wrap it spray it with hairspray
so many of you have ideas but none of
you seem that confident in your ideas
um Sarah will have tips that's a great
Point Sarah will know what to do
um hairspray fixative hairspray all
right uh we'll figure it out we'll uh
we'll try to make it permanent
um yeah uh chat GPT thinks I'm an NPC uh
it's got everything it's got everything
it's got hummus it's got racks on racks
on racks
um it's the greatest vision board of all
time and it's the only vision board that
you can buy at project for awesome.com
donate
um so uh
yeah um spray it with fixative Sarah
probably has some all right great thank
you uh somebody just followed page real
Stone on Facebook so I'll get an email
about that
we're at 1.8 million dollars and there's
only one hour and 10 minutes left for
you to donate and make sure that the
money that you donate goes to uh
Partners in Health and save the children
it'll be split between those two
organizations and then at noon eastern
time the second day of the project for
awesome will begin when we begin raising
money for Charities chosen by you the
nerdfighter community via your votes at
project for awesome.com thank you to the
over uh 27 000 votes we've had so far
we're gonna watch a new featured video
now
um at um at project for awesome.com
um the vision board perk is up by the
way uh we're gonna watch a new featured
video at projectforawesome.com uh it's
for this star won't go out it was made
by this star won't go out and we're
going to watch it together now
foreign
great you guys just missed my uh my
whole tearful
um
discussion because I was muted
so that's that's Peak project for
awesome
it's like I'm in tears and I'm muted
um what I was saying
um was how grateful I am
um how I misaster
[Music]
I miss Esther
um and made me seeing that video made me
think about those um those early p4as
and how instrumental she was um to them
and along with her forensic attitude and
um other folks
um
and uh just made me so grateful that you
um you found that calling and that you
um
you have uh done so much good with the
star won't go out you've been able to
reach so many families and help them
through the
same experience that you went through
um not just financially but also
um accompanying them emotionally
spiritually
um through that really really difficult
um journey of taking care of a kid with
cancer so thank you uh Lori and Wayne
and everybody at this store won't go out
for the incredible work that you do and
I hope that um you'll consider voting
for this star won't go out at project
for awesome.com
um it's a pretty simple procedure to
vote for a charity that you want to get
the money that we raise during the
second half of the p4a
you click the red vote button
I think first you have to prove you're
not a robot and then you click the red
vote button but yeah I um
I I uh I miss Esther you know you got to
meet Esther Earl when you were a baby no
Esther who um passed away of of cancer
and they founded the star won't go out
in her honor I remember you were a tiny
little baby you were in your crib and um
Esther and some of her friends and maybe
uh Wayne and Laurie too were like on a
uh like a group Skype call and uh I was
like here let me show you baby Henry and
you were like a tiny little baby and you
remember that little white crib probably
you know that Alice had it's the same
Corvallis had the
chewed up yes you would chew on the
corner of it and then when you were like
14 months old you figured out how to
um how to crawl out of it and then you
would crawl out of it and it was like a
real
it was a real American Ninja Warrior
thing you crawl out of it and then you
would come into our bed surprisingly I
still remember how I did it you do yeah
oh wow that is surprising that's cool I
would like pull myself up over it yeah
and then I would flop down to the side
and I realized that that hurt so I um
climbed up on the uh
the top railing the top railing I stood
up and I um
flopped onto the um dresser
and that's right that's right that's
right
um and then you would come get in bed
with me and Mama
yeah
um
why don't you do that anymore
because I'm not in a crib
it goes so fast friends
I love you buddy
um
yeah so
uh yeah thanks thanks again to worry for
making that video and
um
yeah
any chance we get another punch somebody
just asked hopefully
[Laughter]
um
that hurt uh so bad like I I told you
this last night but like two hours later
I was like oh God I really hope that
wasn't a Houdini situation Henry won't
be able to live with himself
like I was genuinely worried about that
um Naomi says I'm crying about the
passage of time me too Naomi
me too
um we're gonna be joined very shortly by
our next hosts
um Vanessa and Matt
uh that'll be great of um uh who are
just just great podcasters and people
and uh
uh Professor Potts actually hosted me at
Harvard
um to give a lecture
that was one of the most fulfilling you
were there
remember yeah that nice room yeah
um one of the most fulfilling uh
uh writing opportunities I've ever had
like I don't usually get to write about
um or talk about
um my faith and my relationship with um
how I think about
uh suffering and Injustice through the
lens of um
of my faith and so it was really
um it was really cool so we're going to
bring them on now
um or as soon as we can get all that
stuff sorted and um there we go
it's Vanessa and Matt right
hi hi we can hear you hi
um you both sound and look great
well that makes sense
thanks thank you
that seems reasonable uh Henry
how are you
gray streams
um yeah thank you in advance for hosting
the project for awesome I am a little
tired
you look amazing
you're being very generous and I really
appreciate it um what are you drinking
actually
yeah well
oh beautiful and are you drinking coffee
Vanessa I think of you as a coffee
person
I am a coffee person and I hate green
tea and likes to tease me
he likes to say that I'm racist because
she's racist
oh yeah no that makes sense
um
I'm not a huge fan of green
being racist design but I mean
I'm a coffee person but I'm also an old
person so too much coffee hurts my tummy
yeah 11 11 A.M is a little late for
coffee for you yeah
I have to tell you I do I think of you
as being incredibly young
um
at least in terms of like how good your
writing is
um I think of both of you as being very
young because you're so wise and usually
I associate wisdom with old people but
um but yeah you're very you're very
young
so young we're the same shot
yeah I know but I'm not as wise as you
or as accomplished it's not like I'm a
professor it's not like I wrote playing
with Jane Eyre you know like
John
I would have spent all the time in the
world with you go away this is a break
for you all right I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go watch the second half of the AFC
Wimbledon game and um forced my son to
cuddle with me yeah
you have to
go okay no God it's like his friends are
watching the stream and he's like this
is this is this is a nightmare all right
dftba
have a great stream thank you all
thanks bye
sorry I know you would rather hang out
with John but I really feel like that's
why we're here so he can have a rest and
we can hang out with all the awesome
great people
so I like hanging out with both of you
that's all
invited him to our local Hometown and
didn't tell me so I was on a trip and
didn't get anything with him
I told you you said oh can you bet him
maybe on a trip okay anyway
so we should start should we start let's
start
I'm Vanessa
uh I'm Matt Potts and we host a podcast
called Harry Potter and the sacred text
and I think we just need to address the
hippogriff in the room before we do
anything else appear which is that we we
hate JK Rowling's transphobia like we
and then the recent news has been very
upsetting to us and very upsetting to
our listeners one of the things that we
try to do on our podcast is to read
Harry Potter against Jane I'm sorry
against JK Rowling right we actually
think that the books although the books
are problematic at times too and we talk
about that we think that the books
actually have some of the resources for
us to speak back against the
exclusionary kind of comments and
behavior of JK Rowling so if you were
profoundly disturbed by Jay Curry
rolling we are too and we want you to
know that's the case what we do on the
podcast is we read Harry Potter as if it
were sacred text and what that means is
like sacred text we think are and John
agrees because he came to our church and
talked about it segretecs are also
imperfect also have problematic things
in them but we see them as Resources by
which we can speak back against those
automatic things so we just want you to
know that that um that's where we are
and we we express solidarity with all
those who are who are who have felt
harmed by and threatened by
um by these comments and this
transphobia and um yeah and we hear you
and we see you and we know it's
problematic and also we encourage folks
to not buy JK Rowling stuff to get books
out of libraries we we know it's a
problem and no it's complicated but but
that that texts are complicated and that
one thing we can do is try to use text
to speak back against Power since that's
one of the things we want to podcast and
we just wanted to start with that
especially given the news of the last
few days
I also just want to add Matt when JK
Rowling came out with her first like
tweets
um that were exquisitely anti-trans
although they were definitely for this
in December of 2019 we put whether or
not we should keep making the podcast to
a vote without listeners
um and uh we can we've shared the data
before and we can share it again but
two-thirds of folks wanted us to keep
going and it was really interesting
because that was exactly the number
across CIS people and trans people
and so it was a really beautiful thing
to have our community but part of the
decision that this felt like a safe
space
for them to still claim their love for
the Harry Potter series because we will
be so critical of it and we will take it
treat it the way that we treat all
sacred texts which is they are
incredibly flawed
um and so
and it's been really meaningful to be
that that safe space for some people but
we did we lost a lot of listeners and we
totally understand why
um but oh and Paola wants us to know
that our perk our audio perk is live now
and so if you donate to project for
awesome you get the audio perk bundle
you are gonna get Matt and I talking
about do you remember what we did for it
ghosted
ghosts at Hogwarts so we talked about
ghosts at Hogwarts and you just want to
sign up for that and you just want to
donate for project for awesome we love
project for awesome we've been
partnering with them
70 years now and yeah so definitely
donate for at projects what's the deal
with ghosts why are there ghosts and
some people go to King's cross station
Etc it's like it's a whole it's a whole
ver it gets deep into the Weeds on on
Harry Potter
um yeah so so what we do on the podcast
is we as I said we read Harry Potter's
Digger text but we do more than just
like say oh it's sacred read it we
actually look to religious traditions
and like they're in all these long
practices you know
scriptures have been flawed forever and
people have been using them to try to
make meaning forever and they've
developed these reading practices by
which they can make meaning from these
texts
um and so you know we do we my family is
comes from both Buddhism and
Christianity so we do Buddhist reading
practices we do Christian reading
practices Vanessa's comes from a Jewish
background and she so we use Jewish
reading practices
um today we're not going to talk about
Harry Potter
uh today we are going to talk about uh
Vanessa has chose my favorite movie I've
chosen a favorite movie I think we
compare these are silly movies these are
not serious movies and we're going to
treat them incredibly seriously yours is
very philosophically
seriously just got nominated for Best
Picture
well okay
okay so we're going to take this
we're gonna take these pieces of pop
culture and then we're going to take
these ancient sacred reading practices
and use these reading practices to
analyze these pieces of Pop Culture my
movie is
Top Gun the original 1986 film Top Gun
starring Tom Cruise Anthony Edwards Val
Kilmer Etc
Kelly MC
Kelly Kelly
yes Kelly McGillis
Kelly McGillis yes so we're the new Top
Gun Will you mind do you want to name
yours too first or should we do Top Gun
first because I'm really curious
um so mine is gonna be Groundhog Day
another Perfect movie with a problematic
artist in it but it's a perfect movie
can everybody please put in their chat
in the chat what movie they would pick
their sacred quote from I'm curious
I would like to know because you and I
are very passionate about these films
but I would love to know
what what what the other people so on
the podcast we always do it I think we
might be
seriously dating ourselves also by
choosing these movies
let's choose two great movies from the
mid 80s
oh my God these are Mamma Mia Julie and
Julia clueless Lord of the Rings The
Martian
let's just
let's just make movies why don't you
just read the chat for the next 50
minutes
okay
I forgot do you want us to do 30 second
Recaps but okay fun wait can I first
share an anecdote so my I'm on a Texas
yeah my brothers and sisters-in-law and
it's called Phil the groundhog Phil
and
um every Groundhog Day we spend all day
texting each other quotes from Groundhog
Day
and every morning because I'm on the
east coast and they're all on the west
coast I start us off by by saying too
early for flapjacks
and it is my favorite holiday tradition
we ate hundreds of texts one of my
sisters-in-law unsubscribed within the
first half hour of being on the text
thread she was like
so Groundhog Day Back to the Future oh
my God okay so Matt 30 second recap do
you want me to go first with Groundhog
Day or do you want to go for this with
Top Gun and then I do Groundhog Day so
yeah so you'll be wrong okay three
seconds I'll be gone happy 30 seconds
and then no no I'll do Groundhog Day 30
seconds you'll do Top Gun 30 seconds
we can both recap both and then do the
practice whatever you want to do you're
in charge you're the boss
uh let's do Groundhog Day
okay so everyone
yeah well can I just tell everyone the
quote First that I'm gonna do
yeah
okay so the quote that I'm gonna treat
is sacred from Groundhog Day is well
what if there is no tomorrow there
wasn't one today
so that's my quote
I'm going to do a 30 second recap of
Groundhog Day everyone
Matt will you count me in
yeah I'd be happy to count you in
three two one go
so Phil Collins is a local
um weatherman he goes to Punxsutawney
every year to do the groundhog and um he
gets trapped in a Time Loop and he has
to keep reliving this one day until he
loves it right meantime he falls in love
with the Andy McDowell but she can't
remember that they're falling in love
day after day eventually what happens is
he lives the perfect day he saves at
least two people's lives he um fixes the
tire for two old ladies he helps two
kids go to WrestleMania and he gets to
go into the next day February 3rd
I did it
nice all right do you want to count me
in and I'll do I'll do the same you'll
time yourself
all time myself
so that people can know how well you're
doing I could stress you out okay I can
do that for you I'll do that for you
next time I'll do it for you next time
you do it for me I'll do it for you next
time okay great Matt
on your mark get set go
so Bill Murray is a real jerk of
weatherman and he goes and he's he's
really loathsome actually and then he
sees the groundhog and then he wakes up
and Sonny and share playing and then the
day happens again again and he and he
and he hits net Gunderson and he thinks
he's God and he can't die and the
groundhog drives for a while and then he
gets really good at piano how long is he
there and he speaks very good french to
Andy McDowell and uh and uh but then he
just learns to just appreciate the day
and enjoy the day whether or not it goes
on and then it's only when he has that
realization that he wakes up and it's
not Sonny and share and he has a new day
and the future
Ned
um there are so Harold Ramis has
actually answered the question of how
long he was there and the assumption is
about eight oh really
okay I was thinking it was thousands of
days so that's right that you're
doing some
I said I'm a God I'm
mad
who you loved it this much this makes me
so hot I love it so much I have a pet
theory that Groundhog Day and Lost in
Translation are actually the same movie
like the same structure the same bones
with just stuff built on them and I love
both movies
oh my God fascinating I need to re-watch
lesson translation it was a movie that I
loved with an ex-boyfriend and so you
know when we broke up
watching but it was 20 years he got the
movie in the in the divorce yeah he
helped a movie in the divorce
um but it was a college boyfriend and
I'm 40 now so I think maybe it's time to
move on and re-watch
and you have a Japanese friend who lived
in Japan for two years and I do had
those experiences
yes who thinks I'm racist because I
don't want to eat
one okay so Matt I'm gonna lead us in
the spiritual practice of our day
um yeah so thank you someone in the chat
Charlie Walton in the chat articulated
something that I noticed too you said he
wakes up on February 3rd and it's no
longer sunny and Cher it is still sunny
and Cher it's just a different point in
the song
oh you're right sorry thank you Charlie
Charlie yeah
so many good we have so many Legally
Blonde quotes in here and it's made me
very happy okay
so I'm going to lead us in the sacred
reading practice of part days pardes is
a four-step Jewish reading practice and
we're going to do this sentence well
what if there is no tomorrow there
wasn't one today
and so I'll just walk us through as we
go
Step One is shot where we ask ourselves
the intended meaning of the sentence
Matt do you want to start us off you
seem to be talking is it someone you
love who you're talking to off screen my
dad is going for a walk so I was just
saying goodbye to him as he goes for a
while you damn I'm at my dad's house
yeah
uh okay so this is obviously once I'm
trying to remember what where like he's
in the time loop I can't remember who
he's talking to when he says this I bet
Charlie remembers Charlie can you tell
us who he's talking to when he says this
I mean he's yeah
to Andy McDowell she says let's talk
about this tomorrow
oh that's right that's right this is
like when he's getting the end he's like
oh I'm wrong no I'm wrong he's on the
phone with the phone company being like
can I get a line an outside line I'm a
celebrity in an emergency
and they say try again tomorrow
and he says what if there is no tomorrow
there wasn't one today
Charlie am I right oh is that right
Charlie okay so then
the intended literal meaning is like
yeah the intended literal meaning then
to answer your question is
uh I need a line right now because I
only have the next
whatever 20 out 60 hours left in this
day
12 hours left in the state to solve this
problem and try to get some help that's
the intended
and this is like at a point this is at a
series in uh um in the movie where he's
trying to get help and everybody is
saying oh let's talk again tomorrow so
he goes to a shrink but this is early in
the time of this is relatively early
he goes to a neurologist a neurologists
think I can get you an MRI next week he
goes to us a therapist
neurologist I'm just looking at Charlie
answered us but I'm pretty sure I'm
right for Charlie was Charlie still
funded by my by my mistake that Charlie
left is Charlie Charlie is a sacred text
okay so step two parties is remez and um
the idea with REM is that this this
sentence is indicative of other parts of
the text that we're treating as sacrine
so the example that I like to give is
that if we were doing a line from the
Bible about the Ark of the Covenant we
would look at the word Arc and be like
oh there's also Noah's Ark so oh that
helps us think about how a covenant is
like a ship that can bring us from one
place to another and so we're going to
do the same thing here with this amazing
Groundhog Day quote where we are going
to pick one word
and we're going to trace it throughout
the text to see where else
um how it can inform our understanding
of this text
so Matt I'm going to read you the
sentence and you can pick the word oh
um should I let the chat I'm gonna let
the chat pick what word
yeah yeah I bet and I will agree
yeah so but really again anyway
the chat is on a little bit of a delay
so we might have to this might be a
mistake but we're gonna sit in quiet we
can hold some things for a little bit
um okay that'll be another spiritual yep
yeah
the text is well
oh yeah there's like a 30 second delay
sorry Paola okay okay I'll just do
something I'll just do something
everybody tell us what oh I talked about
that for so long that the answer is
coming in
okay we'll read it again whatever it is
everyone says tomorrow then it's
tomorrow
this is amazing one person said today
okay well what if there was no tomorrow
there wasn't one today
tomorrow I choose tomorrow that's the
word I choose
good that's a really good word that is
really really okay
I mean it happens a lot I mean obviously
the most obvious example this is where
else in this text it happens I mean
obviously when they're at a different
point of Sunday and share song
yeah right that's the actual tomorrow
tomorrow actually happens at the end of
the movie
and he says it right he says to Andy
McDowell they're in bed together and you
know what today is and she goes no what
and he says today is tomorrow
and like he's so happy he just doesn't
even know what to do with himself
because today is tomorrow
and that's various I'm wondering I don't
I can't remember maybe our maybe in 20
to 30 seconds our our viewers can tell
us
um but I wonder if at the beginning of
the movie if there's some like kind of
uh foreshadowing where he talks about
something he will do tomorrow before he
gets to Punxsutawney you know what I
mean like because he's being a real jerk
and doesn't he have like mob possibly
like he's trying to go to some other
City to be a weather anchor she's
anticipated in a future in some way
right
yeah so I wonder if there is a reference
to that somewhere early in the film
there might be just to kind of you know
he likes to sandwich it right
he just wants to get out of Punxsutawney
like that's his big thing is like he
doesn't want to spend he does not want
to spend another night in Punxsutawney
and instead but don't be open credits
start with him
the opening credits start with him like
finishing his update in Pittsburgh and
then driving yeah
and then they drive to and then they
right and then they drive to
Punxsutawney and like maybe he talks
about something that's going to happen
tomorrow I don't know
so you disagree with my sense of wonder
is that what you say what you're saying
yeah
I disagree with everything about you
like green tea
um
the
um yes hi everybody for those of you who
are just joining us I'm Vanessa Zoltan
and this is my best friend Matt Potts he
really is one of my very best friends
sounded too sarcastic and Matt and I are
doing something
that's not amazing yeah no I didn't mean
it like that
um
from one of his favorite movies Top Gun
I am bringing a sentence from one of my
favorite movies Groundhog Day we are on
step two of the Sacred reading practice
of part days on Groundhog Day quote the
quote is well what if there is no
tomorrow there wasn't one today the
other thing I want to say is that
um
one of the things that Phil has to do in
the movie is except that he can't save
everyone in a day
he figures out that he can save this kid
from a falling tree he can do the
heimlich maneuver on this guy so he
won't choke on steak but there's a
homeless man who he tries to save over
and over again and can't
because there's just like systemic
problems that you can't address in a
single day no matter how perfect your
day is
um and I think that there's I forgot
there's like this whole sequence where
he spends all his everyday trying to
save that one guy
yeah yeah
um so sometimes one day isn't enough no
matter how
big of a day it is okay step three
sounds like you're doing step three
already
oh
should we stay on step two longer
no no I'm saying I think that you got
your step three you just well anyway to
explain with step one oh you got it
sorry sorry so step three of our days
um is where Matt and I treat this very
sacred text
so say goodly that we're gonna pretend
to preach a sermon from it we're going
to tell you if I was on the pulpit and
this was the text that I was given on
like a day where this church is filled
or in my case synagogue this is the this
is the sermon I would preach
and so the text one more time everybody
is
what if there is no tomorrow there
wasn't one today
you want me to do myself you're right
Matt that a version of
no I I was gonna do mine because I think
you really set me up for mine I think
that I would talk about
that they're
there is no
Purity we can only do our best
and there's you can't fix everything and
I you know I love his final day because
he saves the day that unlocks tomorrow
because it's not just that he runs
around saving people he also like
practices the piano and practices his
French and makes a snow sculpture like
you know it's not just running around
saving people there's also a lot of like
art and bonding and dancing
um and I think there's a really
beautiful balance to that so just
knowing that the world is already
imperfect and there's only so much we
can do so we might as well do everything
we can but also try to find joy
what about you
I think I would I think I would preach
something about their no not being any
tomorrow but tomorrow is actually a
projection of the president it's
actually not a thing that exists right
and that is actually it never is right
that it's an idea we have always in the
present it's never an actual thing and
how Phil gets out of the time Loop is
when he stops trying to get to tomorrow
when he just yeah because he's really
anxious to be in this kind of
relationship with Andy McDowell and when
he's like you're gonna wake up tomorrow
and I'm gonna start over again and
that's okay because I don't need you to
be anything tomorrow morning I am
grateful for you right now that's how he
gets out of it ironically right and one
of the beautiful things about this you
know I mentioned to everybody that um uh
I've come from just half my family's
Buddhist
um is that the original screenwriter for
this for this movie if you're old enough
to have owned the DVD with the with the
uh the director's commentary the
original screenwriter was actually
trying to write a Buddhist parable about
the Buddhist approach of time and the
movie started actually right in the
middle of the time Loop it gradually
revealed later that that there was this
background and they just for narrative
reasons they decided to do it a
different way but like he was actually
trying to talk about the way Buddhists
think about time how there is no past
there is no future oh there is the
present and the past and the future are
projections that we make from the
present and so this idea like what if
there isn't it tomorrow there wasn't one
today there never is a tomorrow all we
have is today and to try to really dwell
under that that would be my sermon
oh so beautiful and I so we don't like
to treat sacred reading practices like
they are a competition but Cass one Cass
put her sermon in the chat
things feel hopeless the things we do to
help other people always matter
and that showing kindness
no no
okay
um so anyway I thought that was really
beautiful cast thank you for sharing
that
[Music]
um
and thank you Matt that was beautiful
what you said too
and thank you Vanessa that was before
you said twice
okay everybody do you see what gets
edited out of our podcast harassment
in dirt
okay I didn't warn you to wear our
matching sweatshirts Matt but I am hurt
that you didn't do it that I was gonna
wear our matching sweatshirt I thought
we were gonna wear a matching purple
v-neck sweaters
I forgot I'm a Ravenclaw
yes
yes I'm a gravenclaw
so don't laugh at that don't encourage
that joke okay step four days is sewed
so technically mean secret but we have
recently found this way of articulating
what sewed means that we really like
which is that we have done the sacred
reading practice we've done all of these
steps with this text the text one more
time is what if there was no tomorrow
what if there is a no tomorrow there
wasn't one today
and we've talked about it so we've
shaken loose all these ideas in our
heads so we're going to just take a
minute to think about it and see if any
sort of like new revelation occurs to us
now that we've had this in-depth
conversation
so I will read the sentence one more
time
what if there is no tomorrow there
wasn't one today
so does all the hardest for me as you
know Vanessa yes because it's supposed
to be something that's hard to get to
it's supposed to be something that that
that's hidden in it and that makes it
makes all the beautiful things that you
know Cass and you and others have said
which are not necessarily on the surface
but they're not really qualifies and so
because we found them right like what's
the thing that's like hasn't quite come
out yet we have to find it now this is
hard
because I'm just trying to fill airtime
because I don't have one do you have
anything I mean just that when he says
today is tomorrow he's wrong right
um today's school today is just now
February 3rd and so he you know yeah the
last line of the movie is that he's
decided not to move he looks at her and
goes let's live here
um actually the last line of the movie
is we'll rent to start so he's still
skeptical about their make the future
but
yeah but right like I we hope that he
the implication is that we hope that he
keeps living this way even though it's
not tomorrow yeah
I think you know the soda chicken lose
for me is there's something that you
said earlier on that I thought was
really great
um and that joining it with what Cass
said is how like he's trying to get help
from folks and everyone's like oh I'll
help you tomorrow I'll help you tomorrow
I'll help you tomorrow right and and one
of the things he's so frustrated with in
the early part of the time Loop is that
he cannot get help today right like
everyone's like oh there'll be time to
help you tomorrow
and and that's and I'm just my soul is
pairing that with his experience with a
homeless person right right because he
gets to this point where he can't save
that person but he can care for that
person today and I think he just gets to
the point where he's at peace caring for
that person today and not saying oh
homelessness is a really big problem
we'll do something tomorrow systemic to
say to this person all that stuff needs
to be done to be sure not saying we
don't need to do it but that also there
is also something to do today you can
say that the problem is huge but and you
may not even be able to save the
individual person but there is still
something you can do today there's
always a way to help someone in the
present and not just put it off until
you're better equipped or better
positioned or will have a better
solution like if we wait to have the
best solution we will never do in the
present what we can do that's what
Phil's looking for and that's what he
learns to offer by the end of the day
yeah it's obviously not too much time
lamenting what I could have done
yesterday right
because like maybe there'd been an
intervention with this man earlier he
would have survived but like
yeah okay like now what though yeah
we're here now what do you do yeah
you're with us now yeah
um I love that sewed what a what a
wonderful film what a wonderful family
yeah
something occurred to me that I wanted
to say and it's gone now so never mind
so let's do let's do your movie
sure should we move on to my movie
I'm doing Top Gun so we're actually I
didn't realize that we actually did
develop a theme which is like sort of
beloved text with problematic Central I
know it is also super problematic
yeah also super mathematic uh yeah and
so again we're not for many Behavior
creators we're saying that there are
resources within FX to speak back
against Behavior we don't like okay so I
there are so many good lines in Top Gun
uh some of them are very funny I think
funny
um uh
but I chose it I this is the one that
stuck with me it's not really a funny
line I hope you get to some of the funny
lines just in our conversation uh I
chose uh the line
every time you go up there it's like
you're flying with a ghost
you're flying with a ghost that's the
line
okay
I have to recap first right yeah just
come scare oh you're gonna tell me later
Tom scarrett says it right after
no Goose says it
oh
[Music]
interesting
we're doing a different practice
is that I haven't seen this movie in far
too long
that's okay I it's I only saw it once
last year when Maverick Captain Maverick
came out so it's not super fresh for me
but I think we'll be able to have a
conversation about it I haven't seen
Groundhog Day in a year either so yeah
which is why I got a sunny engine
everything wrong also yeah okay are you
gonna copy in and timing
okay
Top Gun in 30 seconds three two one go
okay so they're flying and they're out
in the middle of somewhere and some migs
coming and and cougar gets scared and
then uh and they stir them off but they
go back the cougar can't land so it
matters land Cooper lost the tournament
wins now you're number one they go to uh
Miramar and they he tries to seduce his
teacher and then she's like it was
inverted and then uh and then they keep
competing and competing and and that
induced you pretty well but they don't
do quite well enough but then Goose dies
and then he has to fly any graduates and
they go back out and then I'll be your
wingman anytime and then uh the movie's
over
thank you
I didn't even mention the volleyball
[Laughter]
you did the opening fight sequence I'm
gonna go and then Val Kilmer's
um flip the ball and then his sidekick
guys
okay and then slider howls that's right
okay all right I'll count you in
oh my God and then Tom Cruise shows up
at Kelly mcgillis's and is like I need
to shower and she's like what the hell
the rudest thing ever no no I'm hungry
no you cannot shower I'm hungry
yeah so
I'll have to know that when I fly my
crew and my planes come first okay sorry
uh
three two one go
so Tom Cruise and Anthony Edwards are
not supposed to make it to Top Gun but
something happens at the last minute and
turns out that they're the best and
they're real hot shots but they're
sloppy and everybody is really annoyed
because they're not safety conscious and
they're not really team players they're
only team players with each other and
Val Kilmer is there and he hates um Tom
Cruise and Tom Cruise tries to sleep
with his
um with his uh teacher and they do you
don't know you close your eyes anymore
and they fall in love and then Goose
dies and then Val Kilmer is like we need
you to fly again and they fly and
everything's okay American victory you
know violence capitalism
you don't need to close your eyes
you don't bring me flowers you don't
need to close your eyes
yeah yeah did everyone
did everyone understand yes I was I I
understood I just think that's a better
title for that song
so we're gonna the practice we're gonna
do for Top Gun is pardis is a Jewish
practice out of the Jewish scriptural
interpretation tradition we're going to
do a practice called lectio Divina which
comes out of the Christian monastic
tradition so Christian monks used to
pray with Christian scripture using
lectio Divina there's something funny in
the chat yes I have to read you this
I've never seen Top Gun but it sounds
like something bad happens to a goose
yes something bad happens to a goose
and Maverick and Iceman are all their
like call names goose is a person call
signs yeah call science sorry so so uh
in lecture Divina it's a four-step
process of much like paradise this is a
practice that that monks used to use in
um in monastic settings so there's Many
religious women in monastic settings
with prayers if you're doing this and
they would take a line and do a
four-step reading process with the line
which it had to do with reflection and
prayer and meditation we have a
particular version of it we do on our
podcast and that's the version we're
going to use to to consider this line
from Top Gun and so the first step of
lectio Divina
um which just means divine reading in
Latin with something else funny in the
chat Vanessa
I've also never seen Top Gun and I don't
want to say that your recap wasn't
helpful but dot dot dot
that's right their Recaps aren't meant
to be helpful to be clear
really I thought they were meant to stop
make us sound foolish
that's what I thought that they are
that's why I thought they were such a
great success yeah
can I just say people are like
geese I hate geese sad when Goose dies
in the movie
vegetarian who's like some geese can't
die
I hate geese sorry I'm so sorry
um
you've had bad experiences with peace
peace have attacked you several times no
yeah I just don't like them I thought
you had I thought
but where does this resentment against
geese come from what is that goose ever
done to you they poop everywhere and
then my daughter this is true of every
animal
no Vape well that sounds like a Rory
problem that sounds like a dog problem
no it's true they do but all creatures
poop every creature poops he's pooped
and then they take their time
pooping is not natural I never poop
exactly there's a deep cut for our Hank
and John listeners okay I will let you
do your lectio Divina now
okay uh so the first step of electivity
is we we look at the literal meaning of
the line what is going on in the line so
I will tell you the line once again it's
every time you go up there it's like
you're flying with a ghost so Vanessa do
you remember what is literally going on
you don't remember what's literally
going on right but I don't and I I so
goose
yeah Goose says this to Maverick and
this is after they so uh Maverick and
goose are behind you only get points for
first place there's no points for second
place at Top Gun Top Gun is a fighter
pilot school in the Navy and you
graduate and you if you win you get
points you have to get a certain number
win each like every day they go out and
fly and pretend to get in dog fights
then if you win that day you get points
and you accumulate a certain number of
points to graduate the best flyer there
is Val Kilmer
slash Iceman and his
um his uh
was it his uh what's the person in the
back his flight officer is named slider
and then Goose Tom Cruise and Anthony
yeah
um but Rio is real that's the person in
the back radar intercepted the Mavericks
are together they're in second place
they really want to win there's a big
robbery between Maverick and Iceman and
they are supposed to be supporting One
Pilot right they are in a support
position and then they see one of the
instructors fly away and Maverick's like
you're good I'm gonna go after that one
and he goes after that one and he thinks
he's about to get him but eventually
everybody gets killed because he left
the position and they're feeling very
discouraged they get chastened and um
um scolded by the instructors
and goose is like listen man I don't
need to yeah Andrew says like listen I
got away from kids I don't need to win I
just need to graduate so he's asking him
to be less Reckless he's asking Maverick
to be less Reckless and he's actually
going to be more careful and to consider
his future too because they fly together
and he's like it's like every time you
go up there you're flying with a ghost
right
well I think that might be where we talk
about what's next oh the next part step
two can I just say that I forgot oh not
really yeah you're no that's because
step two and like the difference sorry
go ahead yeah
um I forgot my favorite
quote from Top Gun
which is what is that not because of how
it's written it's because of how it was
performed Meg Ryan okay
is perfect in this film
which is great in this movie yeah and
she yells Goosey big stud take me to
better lose me forever but she's so
drunk
and it's so fun it's great I love it
it's great
it's a great line sorry yeah it says
what she says he's what he's having
hamlock is it
okay so I guess you know the step two we
should talk about these other things do
there are all these other references to
ghosts like in this like the their code
names for their Detachment of fighter
presidents as a Ghost Rider I'm negative
Ghost Rider the pattern is full there
are all these things about ghosts and
you're right Vanessa this is part of the
literal meaning too we learned that
Maverick's father
died under undisclosed circumstances
classified circumstances in Vietnam and
that the official CIA story was that it
was his fault but what he learns what
Maverick learns later on is actually his
dad is being super heroic but because
they were fighting in a place they
weren't supposed to be because they were
in Cambodia rather than Vietnam the CIA
would not confirm that it had happened
and wanted to put the blame on
Maverick's dad so he actually is trying
to accrue something when he's up in the
sky I believe right he's trying to prove
that he's not a traitor like his dad
because he thinks his dad was
um exactly well not a traitor just not
just his dad was defined orders that was
yeah that's right yeah
um okay step two of Leto Divina as we do
it is we think about
um we take a word from the line and then
we we um instead of in parties we think
about how that line or how that word
shows up in the the text we're
considering we think about where it
shows up throughout culture so all other
kinds of books movies TV whatever so we
need to choose a line so I don't know
should we wait 30 seconds it sounds like
people don't know Top Gun as well as
Groundhog's Day so maybe uh maybe you
should just choose one
um
I people will people will catch up by
the time that I finish the sentence so I
would like to know where else they said
ironically
you see it in the text that won't be
named Harry Potter right Harry is
literally flying with the ghost of his
father on his broom also so you chose
ghost you chose the word ghost already
don't we choose a word and then see
where it shows up no it's just what
story it reminds you of oh I'm sorry the
other texts it reminds you of allegory
because you're thinking about how it's
done really in Christianity maybe that's
that might be I think I'm pretty much
sorry go ahead
so it reminds me it reminds me of the
Harry Potter books where Harry is flying
in part to fly with his dad and then
also there are ghosts
um that is where I'm currently stuck in
my brain what about you I'll think of
another one every time you go up there
it's like you're flying with the ghost
I mean any kind of absent father
any kind of absent father media would be
right
um or any kind of absent anything God
you know Manchester by the Sea what a
depressing movie that's not an absent
father but just like how like the
memories of things that we lost so that
we can't how they haunt us oh that's a
terrible thing
um I'm also thinking of ghosts how about
the movie Ghost I think about the
pottery wheel Whoopi Goldberg yes
there's a ghost
um somebody picked it reminds them of
rent the musical that
um there's a character named Angel who
dies and they're wondering how to live
up here
um
so yeah once someone passes away or even
like when you're not physically with
someone like what how are you trying to
make them proud and live up to them
you and I spend a lot of time with
producers talking to us as we as we
record things and Ariana has been
producing me like four hours a week for
seven years now
and I really I can just hear her like
you like start that story over can you
start with the thesis of the story and
not with some random detail that No
One's Gonna understand you know like the
way that even friends right just like
live in your ear even if they're not
producers
but right this would probably be better
if she was
for sure
right like
like uh telemachus being left behind and
waiting for his father to come back and
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
I mean oh you need to say like Ulysses
right Jane Joyce's Ulysses because the
Odyssey is the echo of the ghost behind
that novel oh yeah
I have a lot of reading goals in my life
and one of them is to never read Ulysses
or Finnegan's wake
good luck with that I I hope you do it
40 years I'm doing it
all right I want to read a suitable boy
right like I want to tackle some huge
books
but not yours
okay I think it's like I don't know
Ulysses is a pretty
pretty good
I don't care I just like really really
don't care
please put in the chat I think you would
like to ever read everyone that you're
like
I I think you would like the last
chapter of Ulysses a lot
okay
what's that how long is the whole book
and then how long is the last chapter
the whole book is I don't know 600 Pages
or something and the last chapter is 30.
yeah no I'm okay see thanks
okay I really want to know some oh
somebody said Anna Karenina you're wrong
okay
um I love animal Matt
step three of lectio
yes sorry so in step three of Lucky yo
right uh we speak about uh what this
like where we see this line in our own
lives
right every time you go up there you're
flying with a ghost it's like every time
you go up there you're flying with a
ghost
where we see it in our own lives
I just want to read I like big books too
actually actually you know that I prefer
it's very short books yeah you like this
short story is more than three pages I'm
not gonna read it
another great book to
book to an infinite job can never read
a great one to never read
I guess I have to say like I I think
Ulysses has the reputation as a dude
book and I and I don't I think that it
can get that reputation because of some
of the way it's received but I do think
it's it it's it's pretty it's good at
the end
okay
maybe I'm never reading Finnegan's wake
I'm sticking to that one don't pick his
way don't reach it against Wick I agree
um okay so what does this reminder
it's what does it remind us of in our
own lives
every time you go up there it's like
you're flying with a ghost well to get
real intense real quick everyone I uh
too
I'm the grandchild of four Holocaust
Survivors and so
I have recently started therapy
and I was like well I think living in a
scared State all the time pays off
and my therapist was like
does it
so we're exploring the levels at which
I'm still living with the lessons that
my grandparents learned in the Holocaust
and when those are helpful
and when even if they're helpful living
in an alerted high state of stress all
the time is like good for me
so just like intergenerational trauma
inter and not even intergenerational
trauma always just like
intergenerational
stuff right like
your grandparents
you know did something a certain way and
so your parents reacted way on the other
side of the pendulum and you're trying
to be somewhere in the middle we all
have this stuff the way that
intergenerationally these things haunt
us
and it can be dangerous I think to
Goose's point right like it can be
dangerous it can take us out of the
present
yes oh my gosh it's
hard Ace and latio are merging
uh okay so Matt what about you I'll read
it for you every time you go up there
it's like you're flying with a ghost
what does it remind you of in your life
mine's gonna get heavy too I'm sorry uh
um so I I told everyone listening you're
watching that we're at my dad's house
um I my mom died last fall uh after a
long and difficult
um Circle so you can see a thousand
cranes that that my family and friends
made for her
behind us my mom's Japanese and that was
a it's a cultural thing obviously if you
don't know about it you make a thousand
creams for good luck in Japanese culture
there's a famous children's book about
it called Sadako and the Thousand Paper
Cranes about a child who died from
cancer due to radiation from the atomic
bomb
um
and what I literally think of as sort of
I I I'm a as John said I'm a professor
at heart and I invited him to come give
a lecture at Harvard I invited to give
him my capacity as the minister of
Harvard's church I'm also a minister and
um and he did and one of the things I do
as a minister is like I preach at church
a lot and
um uh I go up into a Pulpit and I preach
and I have to say since my mom died like
a that's one of the moments when I
noticed her absence you know I don't
I don't notice my mom's absence every
moment of every day I remember my mom
everything of course but you know I'm a
busy person I have a I have a lot of
things going I don't notice her absence
every moment every day but
um my mom sewed some of my investments
my mom cared a lot about she was very
proud of me and she would listen to my
sermons from far away when I'd preach
and so often when I go up into the
puppet I think of that but I also kind
of feel like
I I feel just being honest I feel like
I'm a little bit beyond the the point at
which this is said to Maverick in the
movie he has not yet decided to move on
from that he's still trying to prove
something to his absent father or person
of the world about his having father and
I have to say that after my mom's
funeral
um I I kind of moved Beyond like trying
to
prove something to her prove something
on behalf of her and it's just I just so
I noticed her absence but it's not in
some ways it's there's there's less
anxiety than it was before if that makes
that makes sense
yeah
sorry we got heavy with this third step
another thing that's right I mean I know
I know I hope people feel seen in what
you said but also I really do hope that
people feel empowered to love what they
love and let it let it help them reflect
on
at you know anything that going on in
their lives because
if you love you know I all these
wonderful texts that people put in the
chat earlier right Lord of the Rings
Legally Blonde
like it really can speak to you through
moments of grief
um
yeah if you sit with it in this kind of
dealer way right that's why we use these
yeah yeah okay step four of lectio uh
because we're running out of the hunt uh
the step four left deal is to
um is to to say what this calls you to
do in the world so this is sort of like
you've already reflect upon where it is
in your own life now now you're thinking
prospectively what does that mean I
ought to do for the future what does
that mean I ought to do tomorrow uh what
does that mean I have to do going
forward so uh the line again is every
it's like every time you go up there no
every time you go up there it's like
you're flying with a ghost
Vanessa does this call you to do
anything
my ghost
because I don't think I'm gonna stop
flying with ghosts
but I can I can choose what parts of
them and I think that there's often this
feeling at least in religion something
that I was told as a kid I so I grew up
in a pretty secular reform oh we were
whatever I grew up in a pretty secular
Jewish family but all of my family
around us was Orthodox and someone said
to me once well you can't choose from
Buddhist from Buddhism you can't choose
from Judaism like it's a buffet like if
you're gonna do it you have to do all of
it
um and I disagree I think you can choose
for most things like it's a buffet and
that doesn't mean that the thing at the
buffet isn't there like you have to walk
past it you have to acknowledge it but
like you can choose what lessons to
learn from your grandparents and want
lessons not to lose and what lessons to
learn from your grandparents and what
not to and
so yeah just you know he can go up there
and remember his dad every time or like
he doesn't have to let go of his dad but
he doesn't have to let go of this this
version of it
um what about you Matt what does it make
you feel called to
yeah just to fill out like your your
thing I mean the other thing that
happens in this movie is that he is
trying to prove this thing about his dad
that's why he flies recklessly and he's
flying recklessly contributes to the
death of goose eventually his his flying
partner they get caught in a they get
caught in a flat spin and they eject it
as they inject because it hits the
canopy and of the cockpit and he's
killed by the impact and so they're best
friends it's a very traumatic thing and
at the end of the movie he kind of has
to let go of goose to fly again right
like still holding his clothes with us
like go
um yeah when we when we read when I said
the line again I got the line flying
with a ghost and and it just like we
think of ghosts as like scary and
haunting and I think they can be that
but if you think about like they're also
like Casper the Friendly Ghost like fly
with a ghost could also just be like
super free like super like you know what
I mean like I wonder if there's a way
and you can interpret that lion not as
like compensating for something or
fearful or running away from something
but also it's just like yeah this is
part of my past this is part of my
history it is always going to be there I
can't get rid of it but but I can go
with it maybe to some places you mean
like allow it to lead me and if I choose
as you save and that's if I choose the
parts that are going to influence me and
and frame me and frame the things I do
in a certain way it can actually open me
up into new things and allow me to soar
and to fly I'm sure that's what my mom
would have wanted for me and she said
that to me before she died right now go
off and go do your thing you know just
go
um and I don't think when she said that
she meant like forget about me and never
remembered me again she's just like you
just tear me with you as you go it's
fine right and like that kind that idea
of flying the flying really stuck out
with me when I read the line this time
so
Divina
that's luck to your Divina with Top Gun
everyone just what you thought you were
gonna do this morning
um
project awesome we are donating and
support and voting for the national
Center for transgender equality with
project for awesome we love
um
um um p4a is gonna do a featured video
for the national Center of Transit
quality because it is what we um asked
for them to do they asked us to pick a
video and that's what we picked
um we are gonna train we have a couple
of minutes left sorry I'm just trying to
figure out how to transition we're going
to transition to the next host so
the video
do we do we say goodbye now I don't want
to leave it with that air so let's just
wait
but everybody we had so much fun thank
you so much for
um for doing this with us and choose
your choose your ghosts is now something
um to out to vote for sorry yeah you can
say goodbye because Taylor's next host
is ready amazing
thank you everyone so much this is a lot
of fun uh don't forget to be awesome
great
yeah DFT today
bye
five or nothing
all right oh we are on hello hi
everybody oh my goodness
um
wow we are live and we have a very very
hyped dog very happy hi folks um my name
is Taylor this is Miriam uh this is
Darcy we all use she her pronouns and uh
we are very excited to be here with you
um today on the second half of the
project for awesome which is officially
Just Begun my favorite I mean I love all
of the project for awesome but is this
my favorite part uh the second half is
half of the stream because uh now we in
the first half we were raising money for
Partners in Health and save the children
too amazing uh organizations that
nerdfighteria has worked with for a
really long time but now we are raising
money for organizations that you will
choose
with your votes
um for videos made by Nerdfighters that
you can watch at product for awesome.com
we just watched one I think for the uh
National Center for Trans equality
awesome organization so you know if you
if you want to go on project for
awesome.com you can watch a bunch of
videos learn about new uh Charities that
you've never heard of before you might
look up ones that you know that you love
and vote for those
um you can also sort it by like issues
so if you wanted to look up you know
lgbtq plus uh organizations or
um environmental Charities
um you could do that and you could go
and vote for
um videos under those so definitely make
sure that you are taking time in the
second half to go watch videos and vote
for videos
what else are we doing oh new
um new pool of matching funds so now if
you
um claim a perk you you're is it one
one-to-one match is it one to one match
I don't know I know they're matching for
the second half I don't know the numbers
hopefully someone will tell us but yeah
but there is matching again so your uh
your donation goes even farther
um there are new physical perks so there
were some uh perks in the first half
that sold out there are new ones so I
think there's like new hanklerfish art
and uh stuff like that
um I also have a part that is going live
or just uh went live so lots of really
exciting stuff
um someone in the chat said I'm going to
believe that Darcy supports trans rights
um you better believe she does oh heck
yeah
and also uh Darcy is here to get some
carrots every time that I we we get
another five thousand dollars
um in the tiltify I know folks are
really excited for the crunch the Darcy
crunch she is like literally crawling
over the table because the carrots are
right here and she knows that so what
are we out of the tiltify right now so
we know when our winners he gets her
first crunch good call oh man it's going
up fast okay oh okay let's let's say it
was at seven six zero and we're gonna
give her her first garage at 765. okay
does that sound good yeah okay so every
five thousand dollars Darcy gets a
little carrot we cut them up into
smaller pieces this year because last
year usually maybe you could hold it up
without her losing well she'll lose her
she's gonna lose her little mind yeah do
you see this
don't you want her want her carrots and
the only way that she's gonna get them
is if you go to project for awesome.com
donate get yourself a digital download
bundle get yourself which is live now my
perk is live now uh for now three four
years I've been making bat art I make a
linoleum prints so here's my little
print block and I take ink and I roll it
over here and then I put uh press your
press your paper down on there and we
get some bats flying over the moon and
they're
um you know what I'm not a professional
artist but I think that these are fun
um there's some blue ones there's some
silver ones there's some blue and silver
ones so you can get those at product for
awesome.com
for the low low price of fifty dollars
um you can get what else we we got all
of our past years before a perks here um
hangler fish all right this is a past
tangler fish art that uh Miriam has
um they look different this year but
they're no less special and there's new
ones live at project for awesome.com
and give the baby her carrots Taylor bat
art is spectacular and I highly
recommend getting it thank you Jen
um I'm a big fan of it
um
about a talk about years ago you can
also get a project for awesome coins
Miriam has been collecting these coins
since when when 2017 I think is my
earliest continuous this is a 2013. well
okay so I was not as good of a donator
when I was younger yeah I mean now
you're an adult with money
um see
they're really fun
um I like to play with them when I am in
my zoom therapy
say if they make a really nice little
fidget toy
um
is tiltified down for anyone else I hope
not yes the second half is started we
are in the second half of the project
for awesome
um my bat art is live you can get many
many physical perks you can also get
digital Parts I'm gonna get this so
close digital download bundle myself I
love getting all the exclusive uh
episodes of of uh dear Catherine and
Sarah
um like letters excellent podcasts uh in
the digital download bundle and then
also stuff that I'm not expecting
um movie commentaries nerdfighter art
all sorts of wonderful things it's so
close to crunch time and she's like
salivating do you see this
we're so close we're 500 away to Darcy
getting a crunch who's gonna put us over
the edge where's the info of perched on
p4a website if you go to
projectfroston.com donate you find the
tiltify then you have to click the
button that says rewards and it'll drop
down and you'll see all of the things
that you can uh perks you can get I
think you if you you have to get each
perk individually so you can't just
donate once and claim all the perks you
have to go through each time so uh
that'll keep you busy as you go get all
your uh excellent perks at project for
awesome.com slash donate it is uh it is
dangerously close to the first crunch
time so um
for for new folks that one digital
download bundle one digital download
button that needs to be bought and then
auctioneers
um for folks who have oh
ah it's crunch time so we gotta explain
the crunchler for new folks
um Darcy our wonderful dog of an unknown
age she's just licking my empty hand
um loves carrots more than anything in
the world and um
we know that not everybody can donate
there are many people watching who
contribute in other ways like by making
videos by watching them by voting
Darcy's way that she contributes to the
project for awesome is she eats Carrots
um to give you just an extra motivation
to donate and she does it so well and so
now it's time for Darcy's very first
crunch
here she goes oh yeah
that's a good crunch right there
oh sounds ASMR
I think I'm gonna move these because I'm
Gonna Knock you're gonna play with them
too much and they're gonna be loud yeah
so
how's everybody doing in the chat I feel
like we just did our um
I feel like I was an Auctioneer
okay every dollar is matched until you
reach
828 until to five and 46 cents and 46
sorry
um so we've got quite a bit of matching
to go
um we're also only 11
000 from our goal of uh our 25 goal of
777.77
everybody's saying Darcy is so cute
that's very that's very correct we're
also only 3 000 away from Darcy's next
crunch yeah people were expecting such a
good crunch and you know what I think
this is better than a lemon crunch
personally
um much cuter and happier what else
we've been watching this stream the
whole time so
um we've been enjoying the lemon crunch
we've been enjoying tuberculosis uh
facts my initials are TB
um so I always sort of thought that if I
like became a rapper or maybe I revived
my very short-lived graffiti career um
my like stage name would be consumption
um but I also appreciate uh the the
facts and also the um
uh that's been going on in the chat I'm
sure that there are organizations such
as Partners in Health that are working
on that that you can uh that you can
support and you can go find videos and
vote for
um Darcy crunch is my best everybody's
focused on the the most important thing
here which is the dicey crunch I
appreciate that people keep asking for
our introductions but everyone knows
Darcy's name yes so Darcy's the dog my
name is Taylor
um this is Miriam my channel is it's
radish time or goth croissant if you're
uh you're on to my new one
um Miriam is at zentoro
um we've just both been really long time
Nerdfighters we have uh
interacted with the complexly Cinematic
Universe in many ways
um and we are here for the vibes
Vibes in the crotches
I can't see him clear fish in the park
um the very excellent people who are
working on
um producing the stream and doing all
the technical stuff behind the scenes
are working on the hankler fish please
be patient with them there is so much
going on now that we've switched to the
second half of the p4a
um so it will be there can the bat art
be made into stickers are they only
prints there are only prints but that is
a good
um
that is a good call maybe I should make
some um bat stickers for next year
or this year I don't know I'm not are
you a couple yes we are a couple and we
met uh during the project for awesome
many years
um so you know uh somebody was talking
in the tuataria Discord or was it the
nerdfighteria Discord there are many
wonderful discords um where you might
meet your future partner during the
project for awesome how do we donate
um project for awesome.com donate is
where you can go to claim bat art or the
digital download bundle or hanklerfish
oh the fish are live we passed a lot of
things
we passed two Darcy questions okay what
are we okay Darcy needs a conch for one
what are we gonna do for the tiltify
goal because until they go will it
happen I know but we were we hadn't even
gotten to the point where we're like if
we reach the tiltify goal we'll blank oh
um we have a bunch of um
cursed things to eat here
um oh we have hummus we do have them we
got hummus
um
maybe we could mix it with a little uh
you can't have the power to set a new
goal we can have the power to set a new
goal what I'm seeing on my screen should
we set it a million oh that is so many
not for our time but like we gotta set
the next like bar for tensify I feel
like the next bar for tiltify should be
in there she is crushing that was a big
piece of carrot yeah that was maybe the
biggest one I mean it makes sense to get
the biggest crunch for the
777-77.77 goal
yeah I was a skincare reviewer for a
brief time in 2013. I've had a long life
on the internet
um oh no get down or wait should we do
all Eights
I'm or in all Minds
if we're doing all mines we might as
well do one million everyone wants
eights okay so we'll do eight eight
eight yeah eights repeating
and then a milestone for our segment um
well I guess if we're doing five
thousand dollars for every darcycon oh
my gosh we're we've already passed
another dirty crunch Darcy's currently
below the table crunching the crown she
dropped yeah she's but he's maybe we
should have done it more than five
thousand apart because we've already
gone past
an additional Darcy Crunch and we're
about to hit another Darcy crunch did
the handclap fish goes like does that
one fish went live oh that's what's
happening
zoomed
we'll keep it at five
I cut the carrots smaller this year so
she won't get an upset tummy
um
okay when we yeah so uh
[Laughter]
um we have too many chats and discords
open and so we're just watching all the
Darcy memes
uh roll in so our new goal is oops all
Eights oops all eights and then every
five thousand dollars we raise Darcy
gets to conch another crunch
um once we hit oops all Eights
if it is uh during our segment we will
oh some more lore for folks that don't
know in 2020
we uh
Target order yeah we did a Target like
um curbside pickup order situation
because it was 2020 and um we asked for
laundry detergent and we got two
um
Glacier freeze three pound cans of
Glacier freeze uh Gatorade so um this
one says detergent
um the other one which we've slowly
finished over the course of three years
um said peeperatorade so this is the
perforatory and um we might have to eat
it dry I thought we were gonna put we're
gonna mix it in the hummus
um you know sometimes you get like a
garlic hummus you get oh wait this is
the Garlic we're not putting it in the
garlic you want to put it in the spicy
hummus our options are garlic hummus or
spicy hummus we don't have plants that
could be a bowl okay yeah that's that's
that's gonna be a poll um can we get a
can we get a pole garlic hummus or spicy
hummus
um and we're gonna make it Gatorade
hummus and I said there's no way that's
not expired does this even have an
expert
I sort of feel like it doesn't count I
don't see any Best Buy dates I think
this stuff lasts forever I think this
stuff will outlive us all right we're
gonna have a poll garlic hummus or spicy
hummus to mix the perforatory into and
eat it with carrots Darcy won't eat it
um she'll just eat the regular carrots
um if we hit the goal of of oopsolates
what's the spice in the spicy hummus
like like chili like hot peppers yes
yes spicy not temperature hot wise
all right um while the folks the kind oh
we pesto the Darcy crunch oh Darcy you
have to tell us
chat we're looking at you oh there she
goes here she comes
oh goodness such a good crunch
somebody says it does expire check the
bottom
oh you're right it expired in December
of 21. and that's not going to stop us
all right I think we have a guest
joining us
um
we have hallease
from
police
what is police's Channel just please
channels are sleep but you have that
stumble well stumble well yes is her
production company Police makes
excellent content here here and
everywhere
um and Elise will be joining us for some
uh
hi police how are you I'm here
I don't have my audio I'm sorry oh dang
that's unfortunate sorry
hello how are y'all welcome well I'm
saying welcome and I'm the one that's
here hi welcome to you
yes
um I was watching on standby I am
genuinely terrified please do not have
that Gatorade but you know what in the
spirit of the p4a do what you need to do
it early enough that we can eat it and
that everyone can know can we pass
another five
minutes I'll start doing this at tens
yeah holy crap I didn't yeah maybe
that's another thing I was gonna say
that yes uh I think y'all have missed
like a few Darcy crunches if I've been
seeing the comments correctly oh man I'm
so sorry everyone okay well that piece
of character is eight missed crunches
all right we're changing the contrast
Crystal to ten thousand because we can't
let her get an upset stomach
yeah for real you didn't finish your
crunch so apparently the poll is live
your poll is live your poll is Live Well
that's why I'm voting for uh whether we
have to mix
Gatorade into spicy hummus or garlic
hummus and eat it
um oh my pronouns are she her if you all
I saw somebody ask that but you gave me
what a day I'm not gonna be mad about
that either honestly so
she heard
that's fine what up
um Jenna does point out that we safely
had this Gatorade last year and it was
already past a year past there that's
true we will be fine I've also been
drinking it just what I feel like
normally
I'm trying to get rid of it it takes up
a lot of space in my cabinet and I live
in New York City it's not very much
cabinet space uh shout out to Monica and
Patrick we're back in the chat Monica
and Patrick always come and get that art
um which you can get at project for
awesome.com donate right now
um police folks want to know about your
beautiful plants behind you
yeah so I pulled them all out because I
don't think I'm on the stream for very
long so I was like what can I do I tried
to bring most of the plants from my
around my apartment I'm in my second
bedroom right now
um
balance I don't know man I got a lot of
them you know what I'm saying yeah this
one they're pretty good you get some
great um like uh what is it like a
tutorials on hallease's channel if you
want to yes on my YouTube channel I
think that's my claim to fame at this
point is lecca but this one's in lekka
as you can see
alternative growing mediums this is a
hoya Crimson crown queen Lush and
healthy yes very Lush very healthy look
at her what a peach what a doll wow this
is incredible
yes yes
also Darcy is adorable like I look
forward to always being live on the
stream with y'all and seeing
a little Muppet yeah we eventually
didn't get her hair cut for maximum
fluff
I love it there are only eight
anglerfish left so uh jump on those if
you wanted a hankler fish can we name
the plants so the plants have names
already you talked too experience I do I
talk to them like this one I grabbed it
for the live and it was starting to grow
into my what are those things that are
on the walls that hold things up Shelf
it's starting to grow into my shelf
sir I call them sir
very very dignified I'm from the south
I'm from the south so this is hello but
I was like sir what are you doing sir
sir get down sir sir so anyway this
one's name is Bertolli because
it's in a Bertoli can not sponsored but
yeah
um police have you are there any
organizations
they want a shout out or that you might
be voting for at project for awesome.com
vote this year any any causes any genres
of cause
so my usual game is I do the live and
then after the live I get on and see all
the causes and decide which ones I'm
gonna donate to and then I donate so I
do like the opposite yeah
that's allowed um folks in the chat if
you want to recommend any videos that
Louise can uh watch Once when she's off
stream
um we'd love to know because this is the
second half of the project for awesome
where we're voting for The causes that
we're going to distribute all the money
that we're raised to so uh
yeah Darcy's so attentive because the
plate of carrots is right here and she
wants some okay I think we are at a
we're at another crunch we're doing it
on the fives every ten thousand on the
followers it's like 28 20. yeah okay
yeah and so the next would be 8 35. all
right she's like it's time for me to
punch now
um yeah so
yeah everyone's like can we get a
nursery yes now it's every 10 on the
fives yes okay
so good this is the most fun time of the
year for
for learning about excellent
organizations that we can support for
eating excellent carrots
um some folks are saying Camp lilac Camp
lilacs um I always vote for Camp lilac I
think they're doing great work
um people tell me about it what they do
hold up hold up uh like a very like uh
affirming safe camp for Trans kids
um to just be able to go to summer camp
and hang out and um be their whole
selves and and
um you know feel accepted and safe in a
in a loving environment and that's uh
wonderful I think
that's what's up that's cool yeah people
are saying conservation fund
um Miriam as a as a climate scientist so
we love we always love the environmental
Charities yes
I love them because I live in this world
and I see outside
[Laughter]
right now
mildly important yeah like as we know it
just a little bit just slightly dude
we're almost at 2 million just FYI I
don't know if y'all saw that oh on the
oh my goodness wow yeah it's crazy what
should we do for two million I feel like
every year at least you're here when we
do bats on the faces
yes
um we might do some face facts you got
anything that you want to put on your
face
uh otherwise I mean I I have I did bring
shout out to Fenty I did bring some
stuff if I didn't get to put something
on my face so I am ready ready if it
comes to that it doesn't have no that's
not that's not the vibe you come with P4
right it doesn't matter if it comes to
that I'm ready
we would celebrate it if it did I mean
if we raised 30 000 real quick we're at
2 million so
dude okay I'm over here personally with
the Pat McGrath eyeliner not spawn but
excellent
we're interesting black owned beauty
brands
what a beautiful ZZ you've got there
oh thank you it's in the way
oh
goodness gracious
some law students looking for Law
related Charities you got one I I mean I
did make a video about a noted
environmental law firm earthjustice if
you want if you want to go vote for that
somebody says that all eights have been
achieved so all eights have been
achieved how did that happen so fast no
my way
that seems wrong
we're at 8 28 almost 8 28. I was gonna
yeah okay we still have sixty thousand
dollars before uh we're we're a thousand
dollars away from another Darcy crap
numbers
yeah
um
slash donate and you can claim we'll
leave five left oh my goodness
yeah but well I mean everybody loves
bats uh bats are great I can make more
if we run out but we're gonna find out
if we run out first yeah
I learned to care for plants I learned
how to care for plants from the internet
from YouTube for sure
YouTube University
all the way
that's how I learned to do most things
that's really yeah everything I know I
learned from someone in their basement
that's how I learned to make linoleum
brands
I did it in high school and then I I
wanted to do it for project for awesome
and I was like how do I do this again
it's freaking bats people are saying in
the chat yes it's freaking bats I love
p4a
freaking bets I love people
trying to see where we're at we're at
1.97 project another great organization
that I always like to vote for
how about adding a few bat Prints but
the bats have faces maybe that'll be the
next thing because I'll do 50. I do 50
regular
and then 25 face baths
my only knowledge of you guys is pea
face bats would love to know more about
what you do outside of honestly that's
really all about it that there is to me
of the year and we just go back into our
cave for the rest of the 364 days I
think well Miriam has a brand hallease
you and me are both just sort of like
you get what you get you get you get
what we have what we want to offer and I
think that's cool about us I don't know
personally
[Laughter]
the niche is me there's only one knee so
there you go right there's only one
police and as uh P Sherman in the chat
says police is so cool her content is
great that is I agree with you German I
would say correct
oh
thank you
um Darcy we try really hard guys
which I really are
going again
we're not putting it directly in the
hummus container I have an auxiliary
container to mix I thought we were gonna
dip a carrot in hummus and then in beef
no we're gonna mix the hummus oh that's
somehow worse yeah I don't know
um oh yes Taylor has a crash per series
on films in front of this we put up this
wallpaper because we filmed it in 2020
um when you what I I couldn't go film it
at uh the places so we put off this
wallpaper and shoot crash course and
never took it down and we've had a great
I mean I'm not taking you down I put it
up in July in New York City it was very
hot I couldn't have any air conditioning
because it would have blown all the
stickers off so I'm never taking this
off this is staying up until crash
course Linguistics because we had to
turn up the AC and it was like 97
degrees I like I'm sitting in a chair
and below the frame is just a pile of
ice packs that I stuck my feet into to
make it tolerable
um you know so it's behind the scenes
content from movie Magic
yeah for now crunch course oh wait no
for 4 000 away from next crunch
the Press Penny sold out I don't know
there's um lizard lizaretsky is here
what did lizaretsky say that made uh
people laugh out loud lizaretsky oh has
anyone gonna give that dog Liz is Liz is
one of our best friends oh
yeah adorable
um Taylor what's your crash crash course
about someone else
that I presented I did not write it I
I much more smart people than me wrote
it but I said the words
said the words great yeah yeah 48-hour
crew who have been watching the stream
from the beginning make sure you drink
some water do a stretch eat something
have a vegetable like a carrot bathroom
break any of those things uh take care
of yourselves
um yeah
well people have been off for 48 hours
hold up
they're the 48-hour crew they're here
from the start and they don't go go till
the end
dang that's scary
folks are wondering what kind of dog is
Darcy she is I call her a gray dog which
Taylor doesn't think is a funny joke but
she is oh I shouldn't have touched that
carrot that idea
um she is uh she doesn't shed so she's
one of those uh we think she is Tibetan
terrier and
what was the what what did they say the
paperwork says she's a shih tzu but
that's not correct she likes to jump and
climb and uh run around and she can kill
rats she's a very good rat terrifying
for me so we think she's some kind of
terrier yes this very cute face uh in
New York City on trash day is a terror
wait wait so have y'all had to implement
the I saw the there was an IG post about
dogs where you have to have them in a
bag to take them on the subway and yes
and it was hilarious
well she's like this is hilarious
these are a regular like made for dog
bags
um wow okay y'all aren't doing the Ikea
bag struggle I know well unfortunately
like she's she's I I character her eyes
her as the biggest small dog because she
still fits in all the small dog bags but
she's like 20 pounds
um oh but but she does love her bag as
you can see here we'll show we'll show
you how she rides at the subway okay
she's very popular on the subway she
makes friends everything I would imagine
so because I mean look at that she's
like we didn't waste enough money for me
to be going inside a bag
she's like where are we going though
this is how she rides the subway look at
her
well we zip it it's a little bit to her
head
and then her head pokes out and it's
really cute yeah
this is this is
[Music]
this is a single person better
so cute
can we talk about it can we talk very
cute I do know about the thing where New
Yorkers with Terriers go hunting at
night for fun I've heard about it I
think Darcy would be very good at it the
problem is so we adopted her and the one
thing they were like is she doesn't like
other dogs so the problem with that is
she would treat the other dogs like she
treats the rats uh so yeah we don't get
to participate in those funds she's very
cute she's very sweet to all people she
hates every dog and will bark at them
oh your art is sold out Taylor oh uh oh
oh no well maybe will is that an oh no
though I don't think that's an oh no
congratulations Taylor good job
beautiful lovely bat prints um
maybe we'll add some more I'd die if I
saw it I see on the subway
she is uh she is travel-sized she's a
she's a good dog but she is not a team
player that's that is she's not a team
player unless you she thinks she's a
person who just doesn't like dogs yeah
oh my God someone put a very very cute
little dog we're seeing other people's
cute little dogs
yeah oh Ben that's cool there are so
many so many places to chat
an apology
Unapologetic Dr Pepper has a very cute
dog that's all I'm saying no somebody
asked if there can be a perk and it's
just Darcy crunch sounds like ASMR video
like crunch sounds I mean that would be
very easy to make I don't know that yeah
I actually want that yeah do people tell
us
what is it
what does it I want an update on devices
Forbidden Love oh she has she has an a
nemesis who lives upstairs that's true
um Thursday's Nemesis is doing great
he's very cute
um they still hate each other
like a lot
yeah it could it be on to the digital
download bundle
um probably I mean folks tell us tell us
what sort of Darcy related perk you want
in the chat and then we'll get something
up
yeah yeah and uh
we also enjoy Senior Dogs we're so sad
that we can't have puccion this year we
miss poochie so much oh yeah poochie is
running in the in the dog Sky catching
squirrels and living her best life up
there for sure
yes and she's nice and fluffy and she's
not overheating because she's not in
Texas
[Laughter]
but yeah amazing
yeah people want either Darcy bats or
Darcy stickers or Darcy ASMR what is a
Darcy bat I don't understand I mean I
don't know what a dirty bed is that is
like up to your creative juices I think
no I don't see the problem is putting
the dog in a bat suit Fighters oh she's
just went down into her cave she says
he's gonna hang out there until until uh
we get to him yeah we're only only 1200
away from the next Darcy crunch
oh nice oh I'm sorry y'all poochie was
my dog who was on the 2020 stream 2020
2021 stream
um she has since passed away she's gone
to be with the great poochies in the sky
the other poochies her name was Dakota
but I called her poochie
and she's gonna she was an Australian
Shepherd Cattle Dog next thing so yeah
calls our dog by their actual name we
don't talk to Darcy we don't we don't
call her Darcy uh that often we call her
many many things
um her main nickname is schmoo or schmoo
bear
um calendar
um
um let's see schmoo bear oh the the
garlic hummus is winning out in the poll
I don't know how it works garlic or
spicy wait yeah it's gonna be bad either
way yeah
that's fair um someone wants to know if
he had to train Darcy to like the bag
um
not a lot I thought I did and I like
shot all the tutorials for how to train
your dog to like a bag and then I just
put her in it and then she really likes
like caves and holes like she's always
like sitting under like like burying
herself under a chair or like
hiding under the bed or um
she just likes to be in a little dark
hole so the bag is perfect and she also
loves like car rides and so what scene
was like she's in in subway ride so she
Associates the bag with those things and
she's excited
excited he's like oh I'm gonna go out in
public and get attention and strangers
are gonna put me on the train she's so
cute I'm making Retreats yeah how old is
Darcy
awesome question
we adopted her in 2016 and she was
between the ages of four and seven so
that's a very big range and she's at
least
possibly than possibly 13. yeah wow what
a range of Ages probably like 10 or 11
is what I'm I'm hoping for uh in terms
of age but we don't really know yeah
nice
okay she's gonna show you a little
picture of poochie I'm not sure how what
I'm allowed to do and not do on the
stream so I don't know but I don't I
don't there's a whole video on my
channel
sometimes she's schmooby sometimes she's
schmooby Pooch Sylvia says we better
take Darcy on a field trip after getting
her hopes up by bringing the bag out you
know I mean as you can tell she really
likes it like she's calmed down her eyes
are well now they're open because
I said yeah they were closed
um you look like a muppet you're a
little Muppet
sorry I I constantly she's so soft and I
just sort of want to like rub my face in
her fur all the time
I feel like why not
it's really close to crunch time it's
one minute to Kitty time
yeah we only need 300 more dollars till
the Darcy gets another crunch
oh somebody who's up there so there's a
lore guy that somebody puts together
that's like all of the the people I lore
over the years and apparently
um so there's Kitty time and there's dog
o'clock when you show your animals and
because poochie came on during dog
o'clock there's a poochie in the lore
guide
that you can go see a picture of Dakota
in there so yeah
Parker has shared in the chat yeah
wow oh man we're so close hundred
dollars
who's gonna give Darcy her crotch it
could be you yeah 30 bucks 24 bucks
that's not even a whole digital download
yeah now I'm stuck in the lore and I'm
seeing Oh my gosh this is like blast
from the past and the Lord though sorry
I just like real yeah this whole site is
amazing it's wonderful there is so much
history I know people are like really
incredible historians it's crunch time
so I think uh at least we we're going to
say goodbye to you after this crunch
time so anything else folks should know
um about about you or causes that you
want to support during the p4a you're
going to be going and watching watching
the videos after this yeah yeah
definitely but you know y'all the point
of this is to see and realize that there
are amazing things happening in this
world even though the new cycle make you
think otherwise so thank you so much for
hanging out with me at least for a
little while and Darcy of course and I
always enjoy this time of year and being
on the live with y'all because it's like
you know what
humans are okay
let's sort of kind of restore my uh
faith in humanity
oh definitely for sure
um subscriber whatever but you know no
pressure on that always happy to be here
thank you so much I hope she's gonna
come out of the back I don't know why
well the schedule yeah the schedule's
real tight this year y'all so I'm I'm in
for a hot second and then I'm out so
hopefully next year I'll like pop in and
like stay for a minute and chill with
y'all yeah yeah
well thank you for being here we loved
seeing you we loved seeing all of your
uh Lush uh Greens in the background and
uh thanks for thanks for hanging out
we'll we'll celebrate with one more
Darcy crunch oh my goodness she's like
yes she's like give me a spirit
they're her favorite things
I love that her favorite snack is so
healthy like
I love it
she did have her breakfast she maybe
didn't eat it but it is in her Bowl all
right well thank you Elise it was so
good to hang out with you
likewise good to see y'all
bye
oh tersei is a live awake alert and
enthusiastic
she uh she really she really
oh man it's the Darcy bump yeah I we all
know who the real star is here we're
just here to be managers
um
well Darcy raises
thousands of dollars all right for
various Charities let's let's check on
the poll
um oh that's your department oh yeah I'm
I'm I'm Discord garlic Thomas is beating
up spicy hummus that's 6 419 raised to
four thousand five thousand
I shouldn't be the one in charge of
reading numbers
you just say around six and a half to
around five and a half yeah rounding is
our friend
[Music]
Okay so we've got uh just a reminder for
folks we are now in the second half of
the project for awesome where we are
raising Monies
several money more than one money for
organizations that are chosen by you the
community us the community we're part of
the community we're here
um and you can go to project for
awesome.com watch videos and vote for
them there many ways to find out which
video or which Charities that you want
to vote for you can just uh watch videos
at random you can watch the featured
videos you can uh talk about the videos
that you're voting for and watching in
the chat you can search by uh like
type of issue right yeah yeah category
of charitable category of Charity so
yeah you can go by category so you're
like I really wanna
support
um educational Arts organizations go do
that
um
environment yeah we're just like lgbtq
and environment
um
yeah and make sure that you're voting
throughout the rest of the stream
because that's how we decide where all
of this crunch money is going so yeah
you have the power to dictate the crunch
both when it happens and where it goes
it doesn't make a lot of sense but if
you think so it is a a really important
way and not everybody can donate but
even if you can donate it it's a really
important way to kind of uh participate
in this whole spectacle and
um help sort of decide what we value as
nerdfighteria and uh it's my favorite
part of the p4a so do it because I think
it's really nice
um what else wants a certified bat art
with Darcy paw prints
I don't think that that the ink that I
use for this is safe for her to be
stepping in but uh we we appreciate the
uh the desire for it okay talk to animal
wonders what they use yeah I think they
do like um what's it the kind of pain
that they give to kindergartners
um tempera oh uh but we can do all kinds
of new perks are live all kinds of new
perks all right let's uh let's let's see
what the rewards are let's see what they
are I I wanna I haven't gotten my perks
yet I want to claim some we didn't get
the blanket
um you can get a p fried blanket we have
the the
blanket which is very similar so we can
we can show it to you oh there's a
camera very cute keychain I like that oh
that is a delicious
all right we're we're just shopping now
yeah don't mind us you can get a
crabilo.us monthly subscription this is
not included in the digital download
bundle but if you want to grab in your
inbox every month or in someone else's
inbox or a friend you could get crab you
could send someone crabs send your
friend a crab every month at krabiola.us
no projectproston.com
um you can get digital zines you can get
exclusive podcasts you can get uh what
are the new perks
we can get a warehouse because we're
hummus coaster oh that's cute
where those coasters are quality
coasters I'm using rosiana's yeah
and it's excellent
um there's a beanie there's a calendar
you can get pressed pennies you can get
the Pea Frank commemorative coin
I will be getting that for sure
you can get some leftover awesome socks
from the awesome socks Club if you're
not in the club oh it's Jim's keychain
that's exciting that's a nerdfighteria
member I think
I'm excited to buy that keychain
um also I'm wondering
um stream producers could we put up 25
more bat Arts I can make 25 more four
digital media workshops with Daniel
Bainbridge that sounds so cool
[Laughter]
we're just uh the chart shows how much
money is made at each hour spikes at
Jersey cruncher I would like to
attribute it to the fact that it is the
second half and people some people are
waiting to um
doesn't hurt she's very talented and we
love her and uh every ten thousand
dollars she gets a
a carrot
yeah
um what else once we put the tiltify
goal of oops all eights we're gonna mix
some expired Gatorade powder with some
reasons
some recently purchased uh hummus of
your choosing could be spicy it could be
garlic
and vote now at project for awesome.com
donate
yeah
we'll have to eat that we will on a
carrot Darcy for clarity will not be
eating any of the hummus garlic or
otherwise she Darcy only eats Carrots
yes if we're trying not to upset her
little tummy
um
but although in our second we're going
to be hosting in the wee hours of Sunday
morning and we might be eating some um
we did get my favorite
candy yeah
what else do we have to do oh at some
point we're gonna put bats on our faces
are the bats that are faces at the same
time is the hummus or the bad summer
faces at 2 million bats on our faces at
2 million okay total we have to use
their matches we have two million with
the matching we draw bats on our faces
at oops all eights we eat a curse Gator
hummus
um it just gets worse and worse
um yeah and you can also get maybe uh 25
more bat Arts are are live so if you
missed it you can you can grab a bat
print printed by me
um assisted emotionally by Darcy if not
if not uh physically I'm gonna explain
how you do it oh yeah because that was a
while ago I think I carved the little
bats out of this little block of uh
Rubber and then I put ink on it and then
paper
um
it is linoleum block printing there are
people who are really really talented at
it I do it for fun and for charity I I
block print for
uh p4a only someone wants to know if
Darcy's on Instagram or Tick Tock she
does have an Instagram but we don't post
to it that's right we post to it mostly
so we have a repository it's called
darstagram so yeah if you want to follow
Jersey on Instagram you can um it's
mostly so that we have pictures of her
to look at
look at yeah um but also she's she's
kind of like a once a year event
for project for awesome so that's kind
of uh that's kind of why she's here is
because she this is herself loves to
help out
um yeah
um what else do we have to uh promote or
oh wait why I don't know
to Darcy all right people you need to
raise six thousand dollars because
Taylor Just
got Darcy all excited yeah
yeah I'm gonna have to go grab a Dr
Pepper for caffeine honestly you know
what you might be on something
Miriam had our very first uh
Dr Pepper this I keep wanting to say
summer but it was Christmas time yeah we
were road tripping uh oh that was loud
oh that was
crispy
gotta maintain the exclusivity she does
she really wants those carrots and the
only way she gets them is if you guys
raise another five thousand and four
hundred dollars oh folks are saying that
the Audrey Lord project website is down
so the the charity that I made a video
for Audrey Lord project
um
is probably experiencing a little bit of
high traffic both from my video and
because it is Audrey Lord the poet and
Writer's birthday
um today yeah so happy birthday Audrey
lord well she's no longer watched us
obviously but I like this video you'll
see Taylor Falls yeah maybe we'll do um
some featured videos soon but um yeah
there's probably a lot of people wanting
to celebrate her life and work
um which is cool
uh dressed again people people are
finding the doorstagram it is yeah I'm
not known for doing a great job of uh
SEO in that both my username and Darcy's
username are very hard to spell yeah but
look at how cute she is she's just a
little more of them we're we're special
treats if you can figure out how to get
there that's that's yeah that's the
vibes
um if you want to give Darcy a character
crunch you can go to project for
awesome.com donate that's true that's
how you get her carrot we only need
another shoulder I feel like there was a
spike when it was hanklerfish
um and
and now it's slowing down but we gotta
pick up the pace because this little dog
she sees all the carrots over there do
you want do you want to feature your
video now that we've been talking it up
oh um sure yeah we can do a featured
video together we can uh talk about that
we can watch the video that I was just
talking about just so that it makes
sense to both
um and also to encourage you to uh go to
project for awesome.com and watch videos
about whatever Charities you're
interested in
um so that you can vote on them and
decide how we're going to spend all this
money
um it's it's it's the most wonderful
thing about puree I think
um but I could cuddle Darcy would no
longer be mentally well I have some bad
news for me I mean I'm not saying you to
help
but I cuddle her all the time and I
remain mentally ill so
um she's not magic she's just she's
perfect
um
drink water anytime someone says hummus
hummus and you know what I should drink
some water too okay all right it looks
like the the featured video is ready to
go so if you go to project for
awesome.com featured you can all watch a
video
um together about the organization that
I chose to support this piece right
um and then we can all come back here
and hopefully get Darcy across hopefully
it'll be some crunch time all right uh
yeah great
here we go
because we're hum is because we're
humans because we're hummus we're hummus
because oh we're on we're on
you hit 2 million
hi happy 2 million everybody
I thought we were still watching the
featured video all right uh that was
that was um
that was a great way to return thank you
everybody this is so exciting two
million uh we just hit two million
dollars raised and oh there's a
beautiful we're here because we're
hummus because chorus in the chat here
because we're queer because
not yet did the matching funds for the
second half so each dollar that you
donate still counts for two
and now we're going to do some bat faces
bat faces
um probably we get a special crunch
we'll do a little carrot wait a little
carrot because she's only three thousand
away from another carrot yeah
two million dollar crunch that's what
this is some celebratory bat faces oh um
do you want should we color in the bats
um I have this is my this is my eye
shadow and I have a bat on here that is
upstairs you hold it near your face I'll
be in Focus sorry I don't I'm holding it
up to a camera that is not the camera
that we're shooting we have three
screens going on
and the camera uh very normal I have a
little bat sticker on my on my eye
shadow should we color in the bats and
what color should we color in the bats
your options are Sparkles and purple
[Laughter]
all right
we're gonna bat bat face to celebrate
all right and now we're gonna be bat
face on the street for like another hour
it's a good thing it's a good thing
this is very curious about what's
happening right now yeah
um they're also still bat there are some
additional bats uh on product for
awesome.com donate that you can claim is
a perk somebody I don't know who
um is putting together the tildify found
the description of the bats from a video
that I made about why I doodle bats and
it made me cry a little so thank you to
whoever did that um
uh so as they are they're quite
meaningful to me unfortunately when I do
a bet I just immediately ruin it by
putting glasses
Sparkles oh wait sorry okay I
do Sparkles and purple well I've got a
color for you the problem is I can no
longer read or see anything
I will just being bad okay
[Music]
um what what's going on in the chat
while I do this I don't explain to you
why that's a problem and that I can no
longer see I think
I was trying to make the blurry letters
become real letters that turned into
English words that I could read to you
but unfortunately
all right I need my glasses they're not
just for show you're good but
two million dollar crotch that's what
the chat said I'm gonna honor myself
very makeup vlogger
um
I was like oh I gotta fix my little
eyeliner but I should I should bat first
you're a p4a veteran um everyone's
really excited about passing 2 million
which yes it's very very exciting a
million dollars y'all so many dollars
and now we're raising money we're also
only a thousand dollars away from
another Darcy crunch which I know is not
as exciting as 2 million but Darcy
thinks is exciting
excited climbing up on
he's ready
um
what was it needing glasses yes I agree
um not spawn but this eyeliner is really
good
um
also please appreciate how Taylor put
the bat on me and is now putting the bat
on herself because I am incapable of
doing anything in the physical world
um
see it's funny how I I'm also one of
those people who like closes my eyes and
I can't see an apple
um
but I can I can sort of make a bat
that's that's really all I've got I mean
if you give me illustrator or like a
mouse I can do it but if I'm required to
use these useless things it just looks
it'll turn out like a little smudge
um
they're actually settling in she doesn't
realize that we're only 600 away from
her next crunch how are we doing on on
bat perks are we sold out of those yet
um do you want to show them to the
lovely people if they haven't gotten a
chance oh also we should say our names
because people might have joined since
oh yes say your names and pronouns again
I'm Taylor this is Miriam sorry you
could you can say your own name it's
okay
to cut you off Taylor Darcy Miriam there
are still bad Arts available
um they're lovely there are several bats
in the Moon made
some of them are silver some of them are
silver and blue and they all have bats
and a single Moon there's only one of
those that's true well on this planet
it's not on this planet it's in this
space
um
there are 18 bats left so if you want a
bat get honest it's time it's time
um and that rhymed and is also true
so sometimes when it Rhymes it's true
I'm putting glitter on my bed glitter
bat
just you know
for the spirit of
you for right yes Spirit of p4a because
this is fun for me we were talking about
like what what are what Shenanigans
we're gonna get up to and we came up
with the hummus thing and we're like
okay should we do something that's like
bad for us or good for us because Darcy
gets good for her she gets carrots
and this I guess is is this good or is
this bad
I mean the bats are fun it's fun I'm
enjoying it now I have to wash it off
later that's still The Annoying Thing
the bats are fun I am a little nervous
about the
what's winning garlic yeah Gatorade or
the spices oh garlic is pulling well
ahead at 11 000 versus yeah
garlic garlic Gatorade hummus what is
the what is the blue
um what is the blue what oh this is
Glacier freeze Glacier freeze garlic
hummus
it's the flavor that we're going for
um so you you could do that to us if you
raise another
forty four thousand dollars in the next
hour we're only a hundred dollars or
perhaps two bat prints away from a
doctor oh look at her wait I wish that
we could tilt down she was raised she's
resting her little chin on the table oh
well I can't do it because she's on my
lap but you can you can you can fill in
the rest with your mind unless you're
like me her nose is directly below the
frame yeah um I'm sure you can imagine
that
um thanks to Kate and almonds yes thank
you to all the mods who are
um are making this chat uh run so
smoothly yeah why does it have Gatorade
in it faith wants to know um because
here you want to hear me a bit even if
no one else remembers because we commit
to a bit it has googly eyes we've had
this can of powdered Gatorade for three
years because we ordered a Target uh
curbside pickup order for laundry
detergent and they gave us two not one
but two uh three pound cans of Gatorade
instead
um and so we've been slowly working on
it over three years it did it did expire
in December of 2021 and that's not going
to stop us from achieving greatness you
know what 16 weeks to Glory I think
16 weeks to finish a couple of Gatorade
it should be it should be a challenge
um
uh I it has not changed taste in the
three years it still tastes exactly it's
a little bit radioactive
um somebody did say while you're
watching the featured video that um Dr
Pepper tastes like a hockey rink and I
just I want that person to know that's
the most evocative sentence I've ever
read in my life I think you're also
selling a shirt because it said then
call me a slush puppy and I'm convinced
these tastes like what's a slush puppy
it's like a blended Frozen drink that
you could get at gas stations oh it's
like an icy but a different brand
um are they Dr Pepper flavor no that's
the thing about Icees is they're also
not Dr Pepper flavor but they taste like
Dr Pepper this tastes like the blue icy
you can't tell me otherwise
see to this to me this is this is like
spicy red
well I mean
who knows like you know how something
can be red flavored
yeah this is like red but prickly
it's red with a little ziz I mean that's
fair expired means that it's lost its
top Microsoft quality and that some
Gatorade QC scientists decide about
minute Foods that's a great video okay
so yes yeah it's just it's just not as
quality of Gatorade
you're talking about Gatorade when Darcy
could be crunching you had to hold it up
so she doesn't immediately on the table
there you go okay
who needs them
100 spicy red Sylvia agrees with you
yeah
the tub of Gatorade is essentially a
toddler now that's true we know
toddler's younger than the Gatorade yes
our fake nephew who might be watching
this right now well he's real
well he's not he's not our biological
nephew but he's ours he's our he's our
spiritual nephew
um in a roundabout way he's our nephew
is
yeah did somebody just say that did you
say that Dr Pepper tastes like blue
raspberry because no I agree it does not
taste like blue raspberry somebody who
I'm sorry this is your second Dr Pepper
in your life it does not do not get to
talk it does not taste like blue
raspberry because the blue icy does not
taste like blue raspberry
I'm a candy connoisseur and I want to go
to the death of this this is the hill I
am willing to die on
I'm glad that everybody understands what
our what a fake real nephew means
um donations are still being matched
correct everyone's in love with this dog
she gets a carrot every ten thousand
dollars that we raise and once we hit
oopsolates because I'm not going to say
numbers repeating
um we're gonna eat Gatorade
mixed with hummus mixed with hummus dry
Gatorade not like Gatorade powder we're
not even turning it to do an actual
beverage excuse me I'm sorry I got a
little easy thank you
see this is what I think is is troubling
about Dr Pepper is because it has so
many flavors and we don't know what they
are you can't do like Cherry Coke or
vanilla Coke or apparently there's a
Darcy page of the lore guide
[Laughter]
I see feels like Dr Pepper see I can get
behind that
um
but somebody said earlier in the chat
that they're making a strawberry Dr
Pepper and I was like is strawberry not
one of the 23 flavors
you you can't tell me that it's not
weird we don't know for sure unless you
release the list you can't continue to
be that strawberry is additional
they're just this sounds like fraud
they're just gonna put different labels
on the same can and you're just gonna be
like sounds about right
you can donate to get the public racks
video yeah yeah that's true they're
gonna go do a roast beef place a roast
beef restaurant couldn't even eat
beef
[Laughter]
this is an impossible hassle this is not
gonna say this is a carrot and Gatorade
only yeah yeah that's what we
said it was too 23 flavors but more
strawberry
that makes sense
um
title cards would be helpful I'm Miriam
this is nope try that again
yeah we need Title cards I don't know
I don't know Taylor this is Miriam this
is Darcy she loves carrots and she gets
one every ten thousand dollars that we
raise
um yeah I also want to know what
strawberry Dr Pepper is we ordered a lot
of snacks specifically for our next
segment of hosting and we didn't think
about strawberry Dr Pepper well it
wasn't part of the theme and we just
like bits I think one of the 23 flavors
is aspartame
yeah
um
she smells like a Frito chip we are in
the second half she's so so cute I'm
sorry I just want to eat your face
I'm sitting very good she's staring
directly at the carrots which are just
slightly off screen oh
that didn't happen just oh did that
happen now and at the same time on the
live stream that's delayed or was she
just yawning right now we're just
looking at ourselves on the live stream
we don't know we don't know where we are
in timer space but we do know that it's
the second half of the project for
awesome
so there are many things that you can do
to participate you can donate project
for awesome.com donate there are
um new perks like keychains and bat art
and uh the digital download bundle which
is not new but it's the best value for
your dollar in a blanket there's a
blanket there are other coins and
they're very fun to fidget with and I
don't know where we put ours
um we put them away so you wouldn't make
so much noise yes
um it's dog o'clock it's dog o'clock we
got a dog that's a way you can
participate if you uh can't donate right
now you could share your dogs on the
internet with dog o'clock yeah there are
many ways that hashtag or in discords
that don't include donating yeah uh you
can you can go to projectprossip.com and
watch videos made by Nerdfighters about
organizations that they care about and
you can vote for the ones that you want
to receive some of the money that we're
raising right now uh yes this is
completely off topic but uh pixel pie in
the nerdman hair Discord asks are
croissants carbonated bread
carbonated yeah
well but
that's you do you think they aren't you
say no why would that be carbon it's
butter It's Not Butter it's air but the
butter makes the air poof
I consider myself a croissant
connoisseur
oh man I wish I had a croissant right
sourdough is the other Contender that's
my other uh YouTube channel is goth
croissant because I wear all black and I
like to eat bread
um there we all you know yeah I don't
it's
is chat is all bread is carbonated
actually yeah
you know
sourdough's carbonated bread I agree
oh and also there is such a thing of
soda bread which is pointed out
I don't know how I feel about this
carbonated bread
no no croissant
they're just better little butter
holders yeah but then the butter melts
and really steam which is trapped in the
bread is air velvet's Rose says oh we've
still got the Gatorade three years going
strong yeah there's still a lot left in
there too
can't believe it's not here wait did we
pass another Crunch and I missed no or
that was the old crunch we're two
thousand dollars away no the conscious
happened on the fives
no they have been on
the no we we did it we just did a crunch
yeah so we're not we're not two thousand
dollars I'm a liar we're we're six
thousand dollars six thousand
dollars away from another Grudge
seven
and
six and three quarters of a thousand
you're right seven
I actually looks so sad she does need a
carrot if you go to project for
awesome.com donate you can help bring a
carrot into this little dog's mouth
otherwise she's gonna fall asleep when
she's clearly happening yeah she's just
using her eyes are completely closed oh
you should swipe it up a little bit
sorry Daisy you gotta entertain the
people yeah Darcy's kind of she's over
it a little bit and when we hit oops all
eights which we are forty thousand
dollars away from
simply four crunches away from we were
four crunches from cursed Gator hummus
Humper homicide sorry excuse me it is
um Glacier freeze garlic hummus or spicy
hummus depending on what you vote for
but it seems like garlic is pulling well
ahead spicy can make a comeback
yeah you know the spicy is actually
quite spicy is it I haven't had that one
yet it's delicious it's my favorite one
this I don't think it would be great
with the beefer hummus Aid as a jet
marker has I worry
what
you think it smells bad no I'm just
saying like we can do that
yeah I worry about what we have to do
at least it's a better see I'm not a
Gatorade connoisseur so I don't know
which
um which flavor's the best but the chat
should let me know
um oh to be a small dog being fed
carrots I sort of no thoughts had empty
belly full of carrots is the way that
I'd like to be living my life
think out I live my life I just didn't
loving to eat yeah naps for nursery
2023. she'll take a nap wherever she
wants to yeah Darcy is currently
um her rear legs are on my lap her front
paws are kind of dangling and her one of
her front puzzles on my leg oh one of
her friend pauses on your legs
also on the table so she's
yeah the the physics of what she's doing
right now doesn't don't make sense to me
blue anything is the best flavor what
even is Glacier freeze that's not what
food is supposed to be called
yeah I mean I I am pretty confident that
no actual glaciers were harmed well does
anybody know where I could find a
picture of the bat art right here oh no
try again hold on focused here or I
could or you could walk up and put it
like properly in front of the camera to
focus if you want this is the bad art
it's so beautiful it's okay
it's great and I never get one because
you always get them all away
okay so you need to uh focus on it
yeah
is it is it focused it is focusing it
looks good I will take it away look at
that depth of field
um so you you could have a bad art of
your very own that I never get because
someone gives them all away well it's
for charity it's for charity I know
um although we've over the years
collected Lots we do have all of the bat
sticky notes still
um they're in my desk
I thought we mailed something anyway
um cinematic back all right we mailed
some of that they bought the next year I
just realized I've been just slowly
wiping away the battle because I keep
forgetting that I have it yeah don't do
that I'm not used to having stuff on my
face although it's holding up pretty
well how's it doing near my bangs that I
keep moving out of my eyes because I
just desperately need a haircut all
right Pat McGrath all right Allison in
the chat says according to the company
that produces Gatorade gluten-free is
Glacier freeze Frost Glacier freeze
sounds like
tastes like sweet juicy Citrus slash
orange and candied strawberry okay so
I'm we're going for citrus orange and
strawberry candied
don't breathe too deep it'll go right in
your nose
that's what happened to me
also just new new to the tildify is a
personalized soundscape from flu laborg
so if you want some sweet sweet Tunes or
soundscapes personalized soundscape that
could be yours think about studying to a
personalized soundscape how productive
we would be how motivate your own
earworm
doing chores and the soundscape
is personalized
I feel like it would elevate your daily
life oh I agree entirely yeah
I'm not getting I would say notes of
juicy Citrus and candied strawberry
I'm sort of getting like a Are you a
a Gatorade sommelier no I'm getting sort
of a
citric acid I mean I'm confident that's
like the third ingredient
getting a little
Darcy means
the Darcy
me yeah monopotassium phosphate knew
that was there I opened the uh to ataria
Discord there's a two million dollar
Darcy movie poster uh made by Tiffany
and I sorry I missed that earlier but oh
my gosh
oh my God there's so much left yeah
we're um
we're I would say oh no it's
solidified it's not well it always is
because it gets there
[Laughter]
oh my gosh there's so many good Darcy
memes in the two ataria Discord yo
you're amazing I missed so many I miss
so many memes should Darcy donate
premiums again Darcy can donate for
memes again how much did Darcy does
anyone remember how much Darcy donated
for memes last year yeah somebody tell
us in the chat and maybe
sorry we made they're like oh no I feel
like we lifted up the rock and all of
the bugs are scrambling like oh no like
hello I forgot to call you back well the
bugs are cool
um you guys yeah I'll I'll um how many
how many ten dollars per me okay yeah
we'll do that again we'll
Darcy has her own money that she's
earned by being a hard-working cruncher
and she will donate ten dollars for
every single nurse you need you can do
the game oh no why are you doing this
close it
[Laughter]
um yeah ten dollars for any Darcy memes
or Arts if you make those Darcy will do
some
we'll use our little paws to operate the
tiltify I believe in her she's very
talented yeah
um Bob I'm sorry you missed the shout
out but we we can do it again
[Laughter]
um I love you guys you keep me young ten
dollars for me and get meaning yes
correct oh man they could see the cloud
of theater and that came across on
camera oh no oh no yes Darcy does
participate in the economy cuteness is
is it directly transferable to US
Dollars I don't know if you were aware
she sort of photosynthesizes it um how
do you submit memes um the easiest way I
mean I am a little internet Gremlin and
I will look through the discard and
count but if you want to tweet at me or
tag me on the Discord I'm zentoro
everywhere
[Music]
um
z-e-n-t-o-u-r-o Darcy you could tag her
but she doesn't like to use social media
during the day so yeah she has good
boundaries she has boundaries on like us
so if you tag either me or Taylor it's
Raj times on nope you're Taylor Binky
underscore on Twitter but I know I have
too many different usernames right now
just
we'll find them you'll find them
a little easier you can tag us but
otherwise it's fine yeah
um
he'll be scrolling yeah put them at
project for awesome.com art there's an
official meme suggestion we'll just look
through there we have we don't have
I guess we can ask we'll figure it out
idea I'm a hard-working cruncher on a
t-shirt with Darcy's cute little face
so I'm just using an otter for uh for
for Darcy which is not it actually is
like quite long
um and has tiny little legs so
she doesn't super love water but she'll
tolerate it when is the deadline for
Darcy meaning like end of end of end of
our time
today no like end of the live stream
because like that's the there's lots of
eyes open for a while okay and it's yeah
but I wanted I wanna I wanna
you want to collect it I wanna no no I
want to get the number up while we're on
the street you want Darcy to be actively
donating while we're on the stream when
she is already asleep
that's fine
yeah no I say by the end of the live
stream
um yeah okay cool but also like uh make
sure that you don't do that at the
expense of going to project for
awesome.com and watching videos of
Excellence yes uh uh organizations that
we can support in voting on those
because this is the second half of the
project for awesome and uh the the way
that we decide how we're Distributing
the money that we're raising right now
is by your votes so you can donate you
can uh get perks you can make art you
can go vote for videos you can talk in
the chat about the videos that you're
watching and voting for and that you're
excited about there's so many ways that
you can participate uh both with your
dollars and your attention and I think
that that is really cool and it makes me
so happy and it sort of makes my heart
feel soft and warm you're saying really
lovely wonderful things but Peyton
thinks Darcy should unionize
Darcy's the real Breadwinner in this
house it's true
um who are we watching now my name is
Taylor this is Miriam this is Darcy and
we are all just sort of around we are
all long time Nerdfighters and uh we
always love being here with you and
eating cursed things
foreign
I know it's not as fun for you when
we're just looking at memes and laughing
yeah let's not just look at the Discord
uh let's look at the chat where
everybody is so that we can
introduceaurus Rex Darcy Saurus Rex oh I
wish we had her dinosaur costume that's
true well you know what we do have
what oh
I can't she's a solidar city forever
incredible solidarity
foreign
X if the Rex is a dragon
and she doesn't want it to happen 3C let
me eating carrots is a hard job
she put her head through the armhole oh
no
Darcy
can you put your arms through uh we are
only
2500 away from Darcy getting another
carrot
yeah and and you're gonna say you're not
gonna let this dragon have a carrot this
darcyosaurus rex have a carrot I'm
worried that we are not going to get to
um Glacier what is it Glacier freeze
you're holding it
[Music]
it's not that bad
Glacier freeze garlic hummus a clock
we're here until 2 pm Eastern so 40 more
minutes of Darcy crotches to raise her
arm is through the wrong hole oh no is
that true
that's all through the big hole
wait no it's both it's
oh
and then through the right hole and then
she weaved it back in
do we have a goal for total vote votes
how many votes are we at should we set a
vote
project.com currently there's 31 000
boats I'd like to see a hundred thousand
votes by the end of the stream yeah but
that's a long time from now maybe 50 000
votes by the end of our time oh Darcy's
fully entered your flop era
don't say that she's slayed no she's
fluffy I know
um
Darcy's darcyosaurus Rex and you didn't
even have to do anything for that
um
we'd love to get to what 40 000 votes by
the end of our time together that'd be
cool man there's well there's there's
two there's three thousand people here
so if everyone voted three times we'd
get to work yeah you could pick three
videos for causes that you care about
care about will you still do the hummus
and Gatorade if we don't hit the all
Eights on tiltify should we keep the
pole oh right there's a poll there is a
poll
yeah I guess we can still do it
yeah we'll still do it that doesn't mean
you shouldn't donate but we'll do it
faster if you hit all oops all eights
yeah oops all iterate we will eat some
Glacier freeze garlic hummus
and Darcy will just eat carrots can we
see it can Darcy see with the Hood
um probably not what have I done I just
careful of your oh yeah
let me um and let me see are there still
any bat Arts while I'm on that I need to
be promoting yes there are still some
bad Arts left so you can
go to project for awesome.com donate
and you can click oh there's one left do
you want the very last
tailor bat art because I don't have any
more paper I can't make I can't keep
adding more after that there's not a
single piece of paper in the whole world
no I mean I did buy out the art supply
store of all of the paper of the size
that they had that is suitable for print
um so you can get the last bag
um you can donate for this little dog to
eat a little carrot in front of your
eyes Crunch and then make us eat
Glacier freeze Glacier freeze hummus or
spicy hummus if you if you choose yeah
and you can vote at project problem
accomplish donate what hummus flavor we
consume
yeah
um Darcy does have social media it's
project for awesome.com Jenny yes
um that's where you can go and she only
responds to likes in the forms of
carrots that she gets every ten thousand
dollars
oh
my Darcy's are extract I did not know
that was a fate of the hummus we we have
a separate container we're gonna We're
not gonna put the Gatorade in the film
before hummus became even a p for a lore
um we were like you know because we sit
and we watch the stream for as much of
the 48 Hours as we can and a lot of
times we like order takeout and eat a
lot of candy but we're like this year
vegetables hummus fresh fruit we're
going to be healthy water and not feel
like little bags of salt and now uh
instead we're gonna mix it
we're gonna mix it
with some Glacier free skating but only
a small amount because the rest of this
we do want to eat like in fact want to
eat this hummus like a regular food
um
what size and brand of paper I don't
know what brand of paper I use and I
also don't know what
size this is by looking at it I go to
the store and I know that it's got the
green cover
and I know that it's the size
um I am one of those I I am not a person
who can um who has has has spatial
awareness
um
I'm so happy you're alive
somebody's puppy locked them out on the
balcony oops
to the Lord where can I find the P for a
lord there's an excellent uh I can't
type I don't know I'm trying to type
one-handed I'm sorry I see host I'll be
afraid the thing that I've come to
realize over the many years years of p4a
participation that I've done is that
everybody's really here to just see this
little face yes and I think that that's
Grand
it's correct I mean she's perfect and
how could you not want to see her and uh
project for awesome.com donate so she
eats Carrots because it's her favorite
thing in the entire world and you're the
only thing standing in her way of eating
them yeah so if you wanted 700 a boat
crunch
you deserve better than that in fact I
think you deserve that yes we don't for
being such generous uh contributors to
product for awesome.com Jenny don't
worry top not Darcy's next time
she has an entire plate
but we're we're dispensing them slowly
because we don't want her to get an
offset tummy yes last year she got maybe
too many cares yes and this year it's
every ten thousand dollars yeah
yeah
there's enough love in my heart or taste
buds for us
um
excellent
thank you to the mods
when the hood is down she looks like
she's dressed as a carrot you know
you're not wrong
carrot with eyes and teeth Lane Marie
says just donated Darcy made me do it
she's really an effective fundraiser and
we're so proud of her
um we are about oh we're so close less
than 400 100 away 380.
379 and
11 cents
um
mom was talking motivating me to get up
get up I actually would love to eat a
little hummus how did you figure out she
likes carrots well she makes her her
intentions very clear like if you're
cutting a vegetable she likes sort of
crunchy things in general she
um when I started cutting up these
carrots for the stream and you can just
probably like look at her lays like
shooting lasers at the carrot right now
um she started sort of just like running
and doing circles around the living room
because she was like yes yes carrot
carrot carrot so if you start
cutting something crunchy she starts
like jumping around and being like yes I
love crunch
um so that's how we found out she can
she can hear it yeah and she's ready
she's like
Darcy is getting sleepy but the way you
wake her up is by donating less than a
hundred dollars to get to 855. yeah
several zeros on the Tilt what other
vegetables does Darcy like cucumbers the
Cucumber Sean really likes lettuce she
likes to eat a kale stem that's true
foreign
dog I'm assuming you are a dog and
you're just jealous of the carrots yeah
um
that was a really good crunch Darcy good
job yeah that's good ASMR for the is
Darcy part goat actually she really
loves to climb on to like if you're
walking her and there's like a ledge
like a short wall she has to jump up and
walk um along the wall she likes to
climb rocks so she is like a little bit
yeah a little goat
someone wants a dirty cam in the corner
for the rest of the Stream oh man she's
gonna take a big long nap after this
she's gonna be so excited uh as as John
and Jarvis were talking about earlier in
the Stream about like when you take off
when you turn off the camera and you
kind of just go like that's gonna be
Darcy after after she's done crunching
for all of you and and your wonderful
generous donations at project for
awesome.com donate
that was a good one
I'm so impressed Darcy is so polite and
waiting for you to hand her carrots
instead of lunging for the plate
honestly she was lunging for them but
she's had a lot of carrots at this point
in the beginning when she didn't have a
belly full of carrots she was like get
at me right now people are asking what
is on the wallpaper nothing it's just
it's just like abstract shapes and lines
um that kind of look like hot dogs that
were used this was used as um
as a background for crash course
Linguistics and it is still up
um did we turn determine what the
wallpaper in the background is it's just
um you can get a better look at it
actually that's not true because it's
all blurry in the background it's just
lines it's just yeah it goes in shapes
someone needs to give Taylor a fidget
toy
um I have one right there I'll sit on my
hands is it because I keep opening and
closing the gator I'm gonna take this
away so we don't accidentally fumigate
ourselves again with the fidget toy
where are the uh commemorative coins
because
um Miriam has a stack of those that
she's collected they look like we're
dancing
projects for awesome over the years and
I do use them as a fidget toy when I'm
on video calls so there you found them
yeah they're just I'm sure they're very
loud that metal what if you held one at
a time instead of doing that oh sorry
um I can see the microphone let me
here's the 2021 coin
sorry if our audience
I apologize yeah 33k to hummus
monthly pictures of Jesse's crabillo.d
Darcy crabillo dot Darcy
um
yeah
um it's like primary architectural
conversations or just pictures of Darcy
from whatever room the other one isn't
in
big yawn yeah she's a good daughter yeah
she's a very
excellent little carrot eater and
fundraiser I see Tacos on the wallpaper
this is kind of like a cloud cloud
gazing that is beautiful you know people
are making beautiful art she wants to
Crunch again yeah somebody was like yeah
I can't believe she's being so polite
and now now she's not she's like she's
like wear carrot wear carrot she knows
exactly where the carrots are she just
um can we we gotta donate so she can
crunchy oh wait no not 95 okay
85 nope 865
000. well maybe we should start doing it
every five thousand so we can get to the
hummus school every five thousand we're
lying lowering the bar for crunches but
we've got to get
um
we've gotta we've got to get to to
garlic garlic Glacier Frost hummus time
um or spicy spicy could come back
I would subscribe to Darcy pick
subscription
um
I mean it is she she's I feel so called
out that everyone's like get tailored at
the time I'm sorry yeah unfortunately
all the fidget toys you have in this
house are very loud I'm trying to be
normal I'm trying to be normal on the
camera well it helps for me that I can
just pet Darcy you could just pet Darcy
yeah I guess she could stand out against
my sweater now that she's in the orange
but that's true would you like to have
her on your lap I'll take Dyson okay all
right
I have a Darcy a Darcy Tiffany
with the Darcy do we have um oh no
that's the same message we saw
oh my someone made a Darcy Saurus Rex
uh Symphony and p4a major oh chef's kiss
incredible yeah thirsty is Darcy is uh
donating ten dollars from her own bank
account from her own Darcy bank account
the bank of Darcy directly into the p4a
for this Thursday yeah Tyrannosaurus rex
or tuberculosaurus Rex
um yes tuberculosaurus
um I say as a as a TB as a Taylor Banky
it's a tuberculosaurus Rex yeah let's
put as many different words as we
possibly can into that sentence
um
yes yeah
um good job comforting Jesse she is a
very excellent little oh what oh what
she's going down she's she wants oh she
saw her bag and she's like I want to get
in there get in my bag and I have no
idea who these people are but I'm glad
to see you guys eat this year Josie
every year yeah I you know what I
understand I understand that's also how
I sort of feel about I mean I'm glad to
see her every day looking at her face
did I See's age is unsure we have an
Adrian she's pretty ready yet she's
she's between
9 and 13 14.
the absolute youngest you could probably
be is like six and a half or seven but
that would be if she was like a puppy
well like she was like one when I got
her yeah you got her one six years ago
yeah
yeah so and they said she was between
four and seven yeah uh which is a lot of
range yeah
and she's still very spry
she's very spry and also clearly the
best grunter known to all of us yes
um so you yes so as a monster money you
can submit Darcy crunch memes at
projector awesome.com art and for every
piece of Darcy art
Darcy herself will donate 10 to the
project for awesome
um
using her paws and no thumbs she will
operate the tiltify website
true facts that's talent she's very
talented
yep
um
um definitely take some time to to drink
some water eat a snack hummus is a
suggested snack I don't suggest mixing
it with eggs
[Laughter]
we don't know
there make dicey lemon crunch uh
absolutely not little lemons are for me
um I want to see how many of your are
they any of your bags the bats are sold
out are they gone oh my gosh well thank
you for buying back thank you all for
buying all the bad art that was very
sweet of you and I'm really excited to
make uh them for you
and if we need a connection between
Tracy and the season of success
the best Contour of the p4a Darcy or
Hank maybe that's um maybe that's a poll
that we could do Hank Crunch versus
Darcy crunch we'll we'll declare garlic
hummus the winner yeah if Darcy crunches
a window I will be so mad at every
single one of you
you know what you gotta this is what a
democracy is you've got to let the
people decide Hank crunch or Darcy
crunch who is a better conjure nope
she's like I heard she's like I want you
to all know that I'm the best cruncher
and it's not even close
ooh they're setting up the poll okay
setting up the pole we've declared
garlic is the winner which is good which
means I don't have to go find the spicy
hummus and or
denigrate it with the yeah
we don't have to um
yeah yeah Darcy yeah I agree blue space
cat or is he better she's gonna win and
she better win
I you know what challenge Hank to eat a
carrot kind of like this
just sort of mouth wide open I think
that that would be a great look for
everybody
yeah Paul is live so a little slime you
can you can vote Hank crunch or Darcy
crunch she's here to defend her title
and you can also donate to feed her at
project for awesome.com donate to uh get
get another carrot in this dog's mouth
it's Kitty time Kitty time we also love
cats the problem is I'm allergic to cats
but I think they're so cute and I wish I
could have one but I
um
it wouldn't do do I wouldn't do well
with it and also it Darcy would Darcy
would not be friendly
she's uh she's the only animal in our
hearts
No Hands carrot crunching roasted
carrots and zucchini with hummus
surprisingly delicious that does sound
really nice that sounds much better than
Glacier freeze mixed into garlic hummus
yes
I agree Hank is in the chat
hanky got a crunch of carrot later I
think the people want to see the people
who have to do it a la Darcy yes you
have to do it in the style of a Darcy
crunch
add that to a balloon that's my that's
my gentle suggestion
first oh man I think there's he could
even crunch it with
it does Darcy have a carrot dog toy she
does not but she has a variety of
she has a variety of dumplings she has
a little flower
yellow rose it's very cute because she
holds up on a dragon she's got a plant
she's got a little plant in a pot and
you can separate the two and put a
little tree on there so you know can
stimulate them mentally what are you
doing he's trying to get comfortable she
wants to go on your lap okay so that she
can face the carrots well now she's
facing the right I'll let her see all
right there is a poll on Project
fossil.com donate you can vote Hank
Contra Darcy Crouch wow Darcy is
trouncing Hank oh you just Screech and
nurse you said what Darcy should do an
ASMR ASMR our
um submission may come is on the stream
uh do a Darcy crunch you have to do a
good job I think that that's got to be
the that's got to be the uh
the balloon suggestion
Jesse you're off camera all right uh we
are how far away are we from another
country because we've we've lowered it
the bar to five thousand oh then we
certainly passed one did we no we're
we're do we miss the 85 000 words that
we're twelve hundred dollars a lot I am
don't listen to me I don't know I have
1200 away from 1200 away from a crunch
okay and you can you can deliver that
crunch to that dog you can buy the
project for awesome.com
donate while you're there you can vote
Darcy Contra hand crunch maybe we're
gonna make Hank do a do a Darcy crunch
he has to do a good job
past another 5K we really made honest
the meme of the stream yes every every
P3 has a mascot sometimes it's a it's uh
Glenn and Dale sometimes it's but fart
man sometimes it's just beans hummus
sometimes it's just hummus
I got the T-shirt so Darcy could crotch
well I think that that's a really
generous thing for you to do Christine
so just for just for this dog for no
other reason yeah
with carrot with Gatorade powder fill
I'm disappointed myself for considering
this fortunately and we do not have one
of those horrible Contraptions I'll tell
you one thing that that thing of
Gatorade will probably still be around
next year
[Laughter]
yeah they see they see crunches and she
always does a good job
there are so many new perks yes you can
claim new perks we're in the second half
of the product for Awesome by the way if
you weren't aware
um
you can get new perks there's a keychain
that I'm gonna buy immediately a spider
since I'm done with that stream Darcy
just jumped on the floor she doesn't
believe you're gonna donate the next 800
so she gets another crunch yeah she
doesn't believe in you and so what does
that say about you
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
but I believe in you how are we doing on
project for awesome votes oh yeah we're
at 32 000 votes I think you should also
um regardless of whether or not you can
donate because we know that not
everybody can
um and we want you to be responsible
with your uh individual financial
situation you can participate in a
project Crossing by going to project for
awesome.com watching videos about
Charities uh that that we as a community
have all made including us we both made
one yes many of you have made one and
I'm glad to see that you're shouting
them out in the in the chat the videos
that you've made or the videos that
you're voting for watch those learn
about some organizations that are doing
some really cool work and vote for them
because that's how we decide how we're
splitting up all this money that we're
raising right now and uh how we decide
kind of what we as a community value and
what sorts of changes we want to make in
the world and
um yeah it's really lovely and it makes
me feel emotional every time I talk
about it it is so nice yeah this is this
is the best time of the year it makes me
feel warm and happy and sad
um
Scott Fab says she may not believe in us
but we believe in her I believe in
Darcy's ability to come she just needs a
carrot and we're only 500 away from
getting her that carrot
yeah we're almost because
oh man
um two million already yes that is super
exciting Hank is coming back up in the
better cruncher poll oh man Hank could
make a comeback he could but I
might be wrong yeah
um
I'm sure it makes me feel Mormon no
thirsty not the carrot no she's just
over on the ground uh chilling she's
just sleeping she's waiting she's
waiting for you to raise
only 400 more dollars and then skip the
carrot and then you'll see her face
again and I think that we all want to
see her face
yeah I miss her my lap's a little cold
now
should we feature another video about
your video should we feature your video
sure
cool we'll feature that while you're
busy uh
uh uh donating these last 400 and then
maybe we'll come back with a crotch
yeah okay cool we're about to feature
another video on project for awesome.com
featured
where you can go uh learn about another
uh charity that a nerdfighter has talked
about in this case Miriam
um and then we'll all meet back here
hopefully if I heard Darcy Crunch and
time for a Darcy crunch but I'm just
sort of vamping because they're uh
they're getting that ready for for all
of us to watch okay so
um in a moment you can go to product oh
yeah it's gone okay I have to go to the
bathroom
[Music]
it's time for a crunch crunch time
crunch time all right yeah let's get
that crunch going right away oh yeah
there she goes good job raising another
five thousand dollars oh we're almost
we're three thousand dollars away from
yet another crunch
um Darcy is Far and Away beating out
Hank is best cruncher in the poll on on
the tiltify right now at
projectprossum.com
I saw some questions about voting for
charities in the chat so we'll we'll
talk about that while Darcy crunches
this care or maybe after so that
everyone can enjoy the ASMR and those
sweet sweet sounds
wait somebody made a pizza down of Darcy
that just says carrots
I love it good job frogsville
okay Thirsty's basically are we hummus
or are we dancer
um yeah that was an excellent video
about earthjustice good job
um so on product for awesome.com right
now here in the second half of the p4a
we are raising money for the Charities
that are selected by the community of
nerdfighteria and how you choose what
charities we're gonna split this money
amongst
um is by voting for videos so you can go
to projectfestival.com watch videos you
can uh search for organizations that you
already know that you care about you can
learn about new ones you can search by
category so that if you know if you
really care about the environment like
Miriam here and me also
um you can uh find you can choose that
category if you choose lgbtq or you can
choose art so you can choose uh
Healthcare I think there are many
categories so you can spend some time
watching videos
you know spend some time mute the stream
um we're not that exciting go watch
videos and vote on them you can vote for
as many videos as you'd like
um so there's no limit you don't have to
just choose one or just choose a few you
can vote for as many as you think um you
want to support
and uh I think you can only vote once
per video but you can vote for as many
videos as you'd like and that ends the
time the stream ends so the tiltify
stays open voting ends so you've got to
during the live stream in the next less
than 24 hours less than 24 hours 22
hours and nine minutes
is that right go watch videos and vote
on them at projectforawesome.com
um Darcy just conch to Crunch
um and she's we're three thousand from
her 2500 away from the next car
we promised you
that we would make a curse Thomas now we
haven't hit the tiltify goal of eights
all the way down
oops all eights oops always I mean
they're out there in Hollow pies but I'm
gonna mix it up because you did vote on
the poll and some of you donated to
choose the garlic hummus over the spicy
hummus so we're gonna mix up can can
folks see on the stream what I'm doing
right now you might want to can you
Scope oh Darcy no no no no no no scoot
the Darcy maybe Darcy goes down for a
little bit here will we make the curse
time it's just protect her from all
we've got the garlic hummus okay
don't put that spoon in here
we're using the scoop obvious
we've got the glacier freeze
perforatorade
how much do I put more that was a lot I
could smell it
I think that's enough
juicy Citrus and candied strawberry
and we're gonna give that a little mixy
mix
and we're gonna eat that with carrots
we're gonna wait we're gonna we're gonna
wait until we hit some number maybe it's
yeah yeah and then yeah we can get 8 000
more dollars in the next seven minutes I
believe in you and we'll see what
happens yeah I was gonna say that might
be that might be ambitious but we'll eat
it before we we turn over the stream to
Hank who's coming next I think
apparently we've raised over a hundred
thousand dollars I don't know you say is
less less of a carnival Darcy's the
better cruncher I firmly believe that
um and it's kind of a green color oh no
that's horrifying
but you should it's like a a mint beige
I almost licked my finger to clean it
three month green on camera
I think it needs honestly I tasted a
little bit it needs more Gatorade it's
not giving what it needs to give oh no
we need more powder we need more powder
we've gotta we gotta go in the focus we
gotta give people their money's worth
here we're just gonna be a blurry blur
my job
is it the same Gatorade from last year
it's not only the same Gatorade from
last year uh it's the same Gatorade from
three years ago
so this is this is its third peep array
probably will make it to a fourth beef
right
that that
Gatorade hummus I think that that's the
payoff that that the people need
it's the texture is changing in an
unsettling way is it like a multiplying
yeah like look at that it's kind of like
um syrupy oh I see that you should go
show the camera I don't know if people
want to know
that's kind of the texture that we're
working with here it's definitely green
all right
um someone's wondering if the sweet and
salty can work here um I'm not
optimistic well do you like candied
strawberries roasted garlic do you only
get one spoon no we're gonna dip Oh I
thought we were gonna dip we're gonna
dip carrots oh you told me we were just
gonna eat it Street no finally aged
Gatorade how many years will the
Gatorade make an appearance yeah that is
Shrek that's sort of a slime texture
slime YouTube is Big right that's like
an ASMR
situation I'm not fond of it myself but
oh God I'm sorry I'm just terrifying
people I need to stop yeah this is
Nickelodeon slime is what I've got here
it's completely change texture you're
not wrong I didn't it just the problem
is it's like it's like when you take it
really fascinating when you take
something out of the oven and it kind of
keeps cooking like the texture keeps
getting slimier and maybe it's like the
sugars are hydrating that's what's
happening it's like mixing into water oh
no oh no what have I done everyone's
like just stop with the spoon I've been
I went from Mean Girls down to being
deeply fascinated yeah that's what
happened to me too I was like ooh and
everyone's like stop showing this to us
oh it smells so weird
all right I don't know how to like
categorize that all right let me let me
do my little we have four minutes left
no we don't do it yet I know but I need
to oh you gotta you gotta smell it you
gotta hopefully we'll get another good
doctor I mean it's like overwhelmingly
garlic
but with like a back end of sugar
forbidden pesto you're correct
P for a slime tutorial I mean yeah this
would actually make a great slime and
it's like a little pastel which makes it
kind of cuter than a normal slime
yeah if you think about it as pastel and
cute that makes it better
oh man delicious guacamole
uh those will be we're gonna just use
the Darcy carrots the Darcy hasn't eaten
I think or we have cucumbers but I think
yeah we're two thousand dollars away
from a dicey Crunch and when we get
there we're also gonna do a little bit
of crunching ourselves
before we turn the stream over so 2000
where where uh two thousand or one
thousand one hundred dollars away from
the next crunch we'll get a crunch Darcy
look at a crunch and then we'll turn
over the stream it's been lovely hanging
out with you here at the second half of
the project for awesome where we are
raising money for organizations that you
get to vote on and select project for
awesome.com by watching videos and
clicking the vote button on the ones
that you think that we should uh
distribute the money that we're raising
amongst most amongst or Distributors I
think you can just end with the word
distribute yeah yeah
um so people are asking where why the
hummus started and Hank is about to come
on and explain uh to uh
where that where that came from but in
the meantime uh people are donating
we're 800 away from a Darcy crunch
she'll get one last little carrot one
last little carrot we're so oh well
we're really feeling melee need to raise
500 people are people are motivated by
the carrot people really want to yeah we
got a cruise truck
yeah Darcy only gets a joy we get I mean
I don't know this could be fun
oh it's solid now
oh last year when we did it like fun dip
and we dipped the carrots into dry
Gatorade powder and ate that it was
actually
fairly okay yeah because Sugar's
delicious
yeah
we also did what was it
Gator alcohol things
yes uh the lower page has all the
information on the hummus all right
um people are saying thank you we gotta
do a dressy crunch we're we're 200 away
we'll do our crisp Crunch and then
hopefully we'll have hit a jersey crotch
all right I have oh oh goodness
it looks like it's kind of different it
looks like cake frosting to me now at
this point it's so green I'm going very
too hard on the cheers cheers
it's a mistake
oh no
it tastes like kind of like a a sauce
you get at a fast food restaurant
because they're so full of sugar
here's the thing it's like um
that's really not that bad I think I
like Gatorade more than you do though if
you you know the picture where it's like
you can look at it one way and it's a
bunny
's deck or like the dress right
that's what this hummus is doing to me
I'm like is it hummus is it Gatorade and
if you focus on one you can taste it and
then if you focus on the other you can
taste it okay let's give Darcy a crunch
though because we passed the Darcy
crunch
y
no man all right
I I need some water and you guys can use
a crunch
good crunching good girl wait we gotta
hold her up so that people go yes so you
can see the crunch
just holding it for later
he wants to save the crunch there we go
there's
all right one more problem for the
people Darcy
well we try well thank you everyone for
feeding carrots to that dog she says I'm
done crunching
I don't know if they can hear but she's
silently crunching oh hello I'm in here
oh what a fun hat
thanks thanks did you is that how you
actually feel oh no what are these
I'm I'm choosing to focus on the hat
which I like more than the other things
on the screen
oh man oh no they move oh no oh no oh
that's
[Laughter]
we need to give people an act like a
like an actual something to go by here
so Oren can you hold this out to me and
put it in my mouth yeah we got into the
crunch comparison oh here we go
laughs
I think
um that was a great crunch I would say
very gentle yeah it was a very gentle of
course he just has more experience she
gets a little more feral
[Laughter]
I'm inexperienced everyone this is
Lauren you two can achieve the dark
foreign
you don't have to have your tongue out
buddy
yeah
I understand I understand
all right oh I forgot actually orn you
were supposed to pop the the
um the pink balloon do you see yeah
okay
you gotta you gotta hold it against
something
we'll pick up that piece of paper
all right
what did it say
it's with my handwriting so you probably
can't read it yeah
okay
yep and then what does that say
yeah yep
two
two do
you realize that it does look really
messy John a good job yeah good job
do we have a bat no
make sure Taylor notices orange back I
think those are dinosaurs yeah those are
dinosaurs which we also love we do love
dinosaurs
yes what are you just doing
before we came here
um
nothing nothing
all right well thank you all for giving
Darcy her crunches
um
she's very excited to donate with her
actual little paws for all the Darcy
memes yeah we'll see you again at 5 a.m
Eastern and we'll probably just be
watching until then
ready in my Pringles oh
where's the button oh there it is oh
yeah they'll just get rid of you yeah
yeah
um hello everyone I'm here with my son
Oren Green Oh and Dr Becky has arrived
hey hello how are you
I'm good how are you Hank surprise I
guess no no worries
this is Oren
hi Oren
he's gonna be like I love the dinosaur
PJs yeah that's fine I get that yeah
when you have dinosaur PJs on like that
you kind of you've got to be like that
right there's only one way you can be
yeah that's right you gotta you gotta
Timber like you're a big tree gotta show
everybody your foot
here come here I want to have the pickle
pick your nose
no you don't want the pickle to pick
your nose my nose
um so that's the kind of business we're
getting up to today
um everybody this is Dr Becky uh she
makes uh videos on YouTube about space
and science
um can you tell me a little bit about
what why and when you started doing that
um yes I mean so I'm an astrophysicist
by trade I guess you'd say
um
this is like usually fascinated and has
a huge amount of questions and it's so
interesting I think everyone is
naturally curious about space and
science so I basically just was like if
all these people have these questions
I'll just start sharing the answers to
them on YouTube and see if people want
to chat you know space with me and sort
of get that like Insider's look into
what it's actually like to be an
astrophysicist system what we're all
excited about you know at any given time
obviously right now
Space Telescope
um and sort of giving people insight
into what it's like to do research as
well
um and what it's like to be in the field
I wasn't talking about four years ago
probably I've been doing it for four
years now
um what uh
what are people most confused about in
space right now
uh
yeah
I mean one of the things that I see all
the time so my research is on
supermassive black holes so I'm obsessed
with black holes I like my thing and one
thing that people always ask when they
find out about that is like oh could you
you know where do black holes go could
you travel through a black hole and they
think that a black hole is literally a
hole in space when in reality it's
almost like the opposite it's more like
a mountain of matter and I think what's
get people confused about is black hole
versus wormhole
so a black hole is like where a star has
collapsed and all the math has been
crushed down into this incredibly tiny
space it's very dense whereas a wormhole
is sort of like you've taken two parts
of space and connected them
right and you have to be able to travel
in and out of a wormhole but you can't
travel out of a black hole once you're
in there it's you're just crushed with
everything else basically I can
definitely see it see how one would be
confused by those two things but but
thinking of it as a mountain of matter a
sort of mountain of like an
insurmountable not not even a mountain
like it's an infinite Peak
um yeah in a way and that's upsetting
um and so so you so for a Clarity we
don't know what happens at the at the
tippy top uh because nothing makes sense
anymore
well no nothing makes sense all those
are physics break down when you get into
like trying to describe what's happening
inside what we call the Event Horizon of
a black hole so everything breaks down
and there was a there's paper that came
out this week as well saying that black
holes could be dark energy like
responsible for
accelerating the expansion of the
universe and basically even all of us
astrophysicists are currently like my
head hurts trying to
understand all right let's see the
numbers show me the integrals Oren did
you have a question
oh yeah did you what did you have to say
about white holes
be the exit of black holes
I have I know nothing about a white hole
oh we have it like
oh no no that completely hypothetical
and I'm glad that he knows that
um but yeah so a black hole is like you
know like now nothing can escape a black
hole we like to say that essentially if
you get core you know in the pool of a
black hole's gravity like all of your
future paths end at the very center of
the black hole there's nothing you can
right whereas the white hole is opposite
where you know sort of instead of Mata
being trapped there matter is literally
being spewed out and your future paths
all lead away from a Whitehall so there
is one idea that like when black holes
like if they could die one day they
could almost turn into a white hole
instead and release all that matter back
into the universe a very very long time
in the future
um but also like if you think about
um you know there are some people that
say Well if you get to the center of a
black hole it could be a white hole and
you could have an entire whole new
universe at the center of every single
black hole in our universe
that makes your brain cry yeah this is
my favorite one and and I I somebody I
don't know where I read this but the the
idea being that um that sort of like
that new universe would have slightly
different but not entirely different
rules from ours and so universes read
universes that are more likely to create
black holes and universes that have
black holes just also happen to be good
for making planets and stars and solar
systems and maybe even projects for
awesome and uh I love that let's see
it's very nice it's pretty it's sort of
like is analogous to Natural Selection
and uh uh but it doesn't actually solve
the problem of where you the the sort of
first stuff came from
which always I think that's always I
don't know it seems like many things
ever thought that they would always be
Mysteries and then someday weren't
always Mysteries
um yeah I think it's okay for people to
be still confused about stuff because
there's the whole you know the whole lot
of stuff that I was asking yeah
right right so there's the stuff that
like people you talk to are on like
through the internet are confused about
and then there's the stuff that people
in your field are confused about which
Still Remains many many different things
so what's the most confusing thing too
after physicists right now
oh
um let's see
um so many things I think dot Matt has
got to be up there right what is that
yeah what the next all the stuff
yeah 25 of the universe is made of
matter we can't see but we can only see
its effects what is it I guess that's
the job for the party though
but right yeah that one seems to me like
a big empty space that no one's figured
out what to fill it up with there's also
the thing where I don't know what it is
but there's like two different ways of
projecting the something something and
they're like diverging
[Music]
it's gonna happen
yeah
so this is um basically there's two
different there's two main ways you
measure the rate that the universe is
expanding and one uses stuff from like
nearby us and one uses like the most
distant thing we can observe which is
the cosmic microwave background it's
sort of the echo of radiation from sort
of the formation of the universe and
those two ways of measuring the rate of
the expansion used to agree when our
ways of measuring it went very good and
we had big errors and now they've just
diverged and diverged and diverged until
they don't agree to within like you know
one in you know three billion chance
that it's not a statistical and normally
like it's not random and so people are
like ah something's really wrong either
yeah one of those ways of measuring is
really wrong or that's something we
don't know about the universe which
would be really exciting there's like
stuff close up that's there's something
about close-up stuff is different from
far away stuff
exactly yeah it could be there's like
local and Global issues going on and
we've got to figure it out and it made
me laugh so much when do you remember
when we detected the gravitational waves
for the first time back in 2017. it was
like murder of two black holes and we
like sonified the sound and it sounded
like you know like that and that was how
everyone remembers it
um like when we detected that sort of
the first time when it was a merger of
two neutron stars not black holes we got
light from that as well which meant that
you could use it as what's known as a
standard candle something that's the
same brightness wherever you are in the
universe so you could work out how far
away it was and so then you could work
out the expansion rate of the universe
and people got so excited because they
were like this is the first time we've
got a brand new method of doing this and
then it essentially the value they got
fell smack bang in the middle of the the
two estimates that we had previously
that don't agree
and it was so annoying it was like oh my
God an independent method that is right
yeah I mean that's great that's great
the Romans like that are always the
times when you know that something
interesting is about to happen like like
confused is the like like a lot of
science is sort of the okay we
understand and we're gonna fill in the
details like we've got an idea of the
the fact that atoms have mass and we're
going to figure out how like the mass of
every atom in the periodic table and
that's going to unlock a bunch of stuff
and it's but it's gonna be a lot of just
normal signs work and then you have the
moments where it's like oh but the mass
increases
sometimes by like whole number
increments like they're all whole number
ratios with each other and sometimes not
sometimes it's really weird or like have
these or like but it's never exactly and
like if you go out to enough decimal
places eventually you get something
that's not a whole number no matter how
careful you measure there's there's a
mess here and it turns out like oh
there's Isotopes there's neutrons
there's protons there's like subatomic
particles and like you have to sort of
do all of the normal science to find the
the broken part that allowed for the
discovery of like the structure of the
atom which is you know wild that we just
think that it's totally normal to be
aware of the fact that there are protons
neutrons and electrons in an atom
don't
don't talk oh okay
okay
yeah
it's funny because like what you were
describing then was basically like how I
picture science in my head as like this
big jigsaw puzzle that we like think we
have all the pieces for but we don't
have like the picture on the lid to tell
us like what we're working towards but
then people also just keep adding New
pieces all the time and you're like
I said there's no Edge pieces like
that's no there's no edges to stop from
yeah it's just like oh I guess that one
that one's not connected to any of these
ones that's a great mental image so I
guess we'll just put it over here for
now maybe we'll yeah I just see this
like big hole where we're like okay so
like you know like dot match romance is
this big hole that everyone's been
coming at from like astrophysics
follicle physics like some chemistry in
there like yeah big hole we just need
the pieces for this is the first time
he's ever blown a balloon up by himself
oh I am honored to
be witnessing this there's always
something new so something new and fun
it did just go back
um so you had a perk but it's gone what
was it it's gone yeah
oh no I'm so sorry for everyone who was
OBT on um so they were signed copies of
my book A Brief History of black holes
and why nearly everything you know about
them is probably wrong
um so it was sort of like all of this
book about challenging misconceptions
that people have about black clothes
that we were talking about before it's a
really fun book I had so much fun
writing it and they were signed copies
and it sounds like they've sold out
already so thank you to everyone who got
one and like you know donated to charity
ball and that was awesome yeah we've had
we've had just uh we've had perks flying
off the shelves
um I created 200 of these last night and
I and I think that they sold out in like
uh oh it's not one of the Finding Nemo
light fish I don't know what they're
actually called it is a little angler
fish uh but I don't think that it does
not have anything to do with Finding
Nemo as far as I know I think that I
invented that fish
um Catherine did it with me my wife
um and uh and I it was like five minutes
for 200 of them and then people were
like I didn't get one
I was checking out when it sold out but
um I'm gonna head to Michael's later and
get more little little canvases
so yeah that's cool we'll get them back
wow look at you blowing up a balloon
that one was fun
it did that's true nice we'll make a
rocket engineer of him yet yeah that's
actually he has a little rocket book and
that's one of the ways that they talk
about it nice
um
but
he was just playing hockey is what he
was doing he was at hockey practice
which is very cute because
there's no hockey happening
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
standing up and falling down again
so how was uh How is how's the life of a
content creator been for you
versus really fun yeah I mean like it's
so cool to have both a really logical
part of my job in terms of the research
and then a really creative part of the
job in terms of content creation and
having fun with you know trying to work
out okay well you know what what do I
care about as an astrophysicist one of
my colleagues care about but will other
people care about that and or at least
can I make them care about it by making
it interesting to them but also giving
them like all of the the context and the
back story and that you need from you
know being immersed in the field for 10
years and stuff but it's also just
really fun when I'm like and I can't
think of a video idea I'm like oh I'll
just explain this cool paper that we
chatted about in our like Journal Club
the other day because like that's what
we were excited about and I feel like
people follow me because they want to
hear about like you know yeah what
you're excited about at the minute yeah
yeah exactly so it's been really really
fun and I've had fun trying to like
sort of uh Reach people who wouldn't
necessarily be always think that they
could understand the master physicists
video
um by you know like reacting to like
sci-fi shows or showing what a day in
the life is like or like space meme
reactions and stuff it's like the Trojan
Horse of the science educational video
you just package it or something else
and they click on it so like reacting to
sci-fi has been it's been really fun as
well because you get to go back and
watch cool sci-fi so like I've never
seen the film contact and like my all my
colleagues were like we will disown you
if you haven't seen contact with Jody
Foster and yeah so I was like well I'm
gonna record my reaction then and uh
sort of say whether you know what's sort
of the science and what's the fiction so
right
yeah I'm I I'm a big fan
um what a what a weird uh what a weird
novel and movie
um
uh so but I assume that if you just spin
a bunch of rings around really fast you
don't make a sort of super fast light
speed portal
I don't think so I mean I don't know if
anyone's tried it but I should do it
was expensive
um
yeah I do completely agree that someone
would try to blow it up like that that's
that checks out
um 100 yeah do you find though that like
I don't know like knowing a sort of is
you have such a broad range in sort of
like the the science knowledge that you
have with doing the communication that
you do is sci-fi as ruined for you as it
is for me having really Niche knowledge
or it's funny what bugs me and what
doesn't like yeah like I also write
science fiction and so like to me if the
internal rules are working that's fine
so if you say that there's some kind of
engine that was developed that allows
you to sort of travel
um at like 9.8 meters per second per
second always so you're always pushing
at gravity and then you flip and you
always push at gravity I'm like okay
like
yeah you don't have to explain to me how
that works but like it fits in with like
how the universe works and the engine
you're not going to tell me how the
engine works because it doesn't exist
and like I understand that that's no big
deal but if it's like I mean if it's was
that movie called gravity what was it
called the one with the two people stuck
in space yeah I hate that phone because
they destroyed the Hubble Space
Telescope within the first five minutes
and then I couldn't watch it I was like
how dare you
know I was like my baby yeah I was I was
like none of these things like they're
traveling between things in orbit and
I'm like no
like that exists on in our space as our
space exists and that's not how our
space works well so that ought to be a
little bit yeah buddy this balloon
actually
it looked like it hit an invisible wall
yeah it just stopped it landed ran out
of gas
okay
this is the life of having a
six-year-old so he's learning about
thrust and Rockets the rocket engine
yeah I told you one day yeah let's make
it hit a wall as soon as it stopped
going uh but then there's the moment
where George Clooney like let's go and
there's no reason he should fall toward
Earth he just Falls toward Earth and I'm
like okay so like there's space and
we'll just fudge it so that like these
things are in similar orbits or whatever
you need to do but you can't like the
entire movie gravity's been working one
way and now it works a totally different
way just for dramatic purposes that I
was like in the moment I couldn't
believe that
so that's the stuff that like when when
the universe doesn't work the way the
universe works it yes it takes me out
and then the other thing that's very
frustrating is when I'm watching science
fiction and then they do something that
violates yeah you really did yeah it's
almost as big as I made it
um like I really hate the end of
um
Battlestar Galactica
which I've never seen it I was really
hoping you'd say interstella but
oh I mean the end of interstellar is
clearly just somebody decided that they
wanted something pretty to happen
um yeah okay go pee buddy come right
back okay when you're done because
there's nobody in there
in the house well Mom's she's in there
she's just in the shower
so just come right back
ew I'm loving this like inside York
what do you live in a barn Jesus
I love how some things are the same
wherever you are in the world
[Laughter]
my dad used to say because you were from
the north of England so like this
imagine this in like the most broad
Northern like almost like
um uh Sean Bean but like the other side
of the Pennine range in northern England
but like you just said put wouldn't so
we both in a bone
put the wood in the hole and make sure
the door
like no something's never changed yep
yeah I don't know I I I had my my
mother-in-law was I think the first
person who ever yelled were you born in
a barn at me because I didn't close the
door and I was like oh I mean
yeah
uh so yes everywhere in the world
um that's very cute uh uh I have to
check out your book I'm excited about
that I can't get one from the project
for awesome but I bet I can get it
somewhere else how was the how is that
process of uh of trying to do three
things at once
just like in my head and I just needed
to get it down on the page and like one
of the things that I love about like
when I was like a student in learning
science I loved to learn it through the
history of like who figured this out and
how they figured it out because then I
understood the thought process of okay
why did they think that rather than this
instead oh no they did think that first
but then they rolled it out for this
reason or whatever and so it helped me
better understand so I actually learned
quite a lot about like where everything
fit in chronologically in terms of our
understanding of you know black holes
and the amount of stuff that had to come
together before we even got to sort of
the idea of them theoretically properly
down on paper and like the 60s
and what what I loved sort of like when
I was writing it was I was like I
realized like
we
as a community in astronomy like didn't
even accept the idea that black holes
probably existed until like the 70s oh
wow so like we landed on the moon like
humans landed on the moon before we
recognized that black holes could exist
and before we knew that we were all
orbiting around the supermassive black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
which like wasn't even confirmed until
like the late 90s early 2000s yeah and
like that's something that like I take
for granted I'm like yeah we've always
known that right and I couldn't believe
like like I kind of knew when it was but
like having that actually written down
and like realizing what it meant like I
was you know like dancing to the Spy
skills before we like confirmed there
was a black hole in the center of the
Milky Way like I was just like it always
didn't compute you know that that was
yeah the timeline so it's weird I mean I
know that this is totally the case for
people who are in their 80s and 90s but
it's like starting like in my four
starting to get the feel of like oh I've
just like seen the things happen where
where when I was a kid there were no
exoplanets and now there's thousands of
extra points like confirmed and observed
and like we're examining their
atmospheres and uh and and like you know
it's also true in biology where like
there's a bunch of stuff about you know
epigenetics that didn't exist when I was
in school it's a big balloon boy wow
bigger than mine
maybe not we'll see
nice one landed on my landed on my head
over there on my little doll head
um
and uh yeah and and stuff about like you
know body plan genetics
because it went longer uh and so there's
just like all the stuff I didn't learn
that's now like normal stuff that kids
learn in school and I'm like oh man I
gotta keep up
it's very tricky to like be a science
communicator and people like everybody
knows that and I'm like well I don't
know what you know I haven't been I
haven't been in biology class
I don't know what they did I think I've
forgot everything in biology the only
thing I remember from biology is that
the answer is always the surface area is
increased and that's
that is a very important thing biology
yeah yeah
um but yeah it's funny that you say like
exoplanets for example as well like I
have a colleague Grant Miller who talks
about exoplanet discoveries in terms of
films released to put it into context
for people so like he's like Jurassic
Park like 93 no active on it Toy Story
95 1X
and like putting into contacts with
people like you know when those films
came out that's where we were in terms
of the science yeah I remember I
remember that first that first exoplanet
and like you know it's controversial and
like and there's wild because like this
is this is how I feel that everybody
knew there were other planets so you
couldn't talk about the fact that there
were other planets you hadn't confirmed
them this is how I feel about the
universe being maybe infinite maybe not
I'm like you all know that it's infinite
Beyond like you know what we can
actually observe in terms of how long
you know light has had to actually get
to us this is like a horizon that we
can't see past and so unless someone
thinks you're a really clever test of
like oh but if it was infinite this
would imprint on like this thing that we
can see in our own Universe if we could
do that test then great but we don't
know of any tests that we could do yet
so for me it's like yeah just like we
didn't have any way of testing whether
there were planets but people like yeah
like that'd be real weird yeah well
someone will think of a test eventually
I just think it'd be real weird if the
universe looks entirely consistent in
the bits we can see but then there's
some inconsistency somewhere else but
that's just my vibes I'm this guy with a
crab on his head
I feel like I should have some sort of
cool hat and I feel
I'm kind of well that's the first time
I've worn them this wasn't this was a
surprise for everyone it wasn't just
okay this wasn't like what I've been
wearing the whole time no one knew this
was gonna happen
I'm enjoying the chaos of like the crab
the lemon and then like pickle Rick is
that is that pickle Rick or is that no
that's a that bean pickle he's a pickle
stuffed with baked beans
oh
it's terrible
I don't like pickles so it was bad for
me
yeah we both know like pickles fun
um fair enough well I'm fat I'm
fascinated I'm sorry uh that you can't
agree with me that the universe is
infinite we just we just won't say it
yet
um I'm an observer though like I'm not a
theorist so I need evidence so that I'll
not be convinced until someone's like
here is the evidence that the universe
is infinite so
yeah I'm like I gotta see it through a
telescope you know yeah okay show me
okay let's fly to the edge and then
we'll do it we'll we'll look again
and then it'll just be another sphere of
of uh you know however many billion
Horizon we'll just keep going we gotta
go again
I don't know how to do that test uh but
that's why I'm not that's why I'm not an
astrophysicist
um thank you for uh spending a little
time here doing this
um it is the first time I've ever gotten
to speak with you and I love to chat
more
um and
uh I I've just been a fan of your work
so keep keep it up hey fan of yours too
and also a fan of your son's amazing
balloon skills yeah look at him he's
he's alive balloon animals yeah
start with a pickle yes
[Laughter]
just draw some beans on it
uh yeah beautiful
well Dr Bill yeah all the best for like
the the live stream as well and I hope
you guys I know you guys hit 2 million
before which is amazing we did yeah we
did we could work everyone watching as
well
yeah thank you so much have a lovely day
um you will probably just disappear now
magic of editing yeah
push a button
um you can find Dr Becky on all of the
places on uh I think mostly on YouTube
uh and it's you could just search for Dr
Becky I um I have some important work to
do now first of all thanking some people
for donating including Andrew and Jess
who uh paid a hundred dollars for
something I don't know what
um it was just oh the Hank thanks on my
Tick Tock uh mads says trans rights
non-binary people are non-binary happy
people and got the digital download
bundle Anonymous says don't forget to be
racksome
Mike Nikki D says crunch crunch crunch
hummus and S says hummus hummus and
Nikki says crab content and that brings
up what I would like to talk about today
um so the things so so we have not yet
it seems to me settled on a mascot for
this year's project for awesome this
year this it feels it feels like we've
been a little bit scatter shot so I
think we but we need to decide and there
are a few contenders and I'd like to
walk you through some of the contenders
now I have them all prepared here
um we're gonna start out so these two
down here are from end hero Studios uh
there's Bean pickle and there's this
terrible Lemon Lips
like no one likes them
um
I love that he'd given me a little
transparent PNG so I can have some real
fun here like unfortunately I can't move
two of them at the same time but I can
have them talk to each other I'm pickle
breed man I'm a Lemon Lips man
um
oh what is what is this I don't know
what that does
oh you can fly in oh
wow advanced
I love that
um so those are two options but there's
a bunch of others so we've got this
lemon crab which I quite like I don't
know that we're gonna settle on
Lemongrab because it's not actually
something I've seen but he's saying
hummus and so it's just sort of
encapsulating a lot of what's been going
on the project for awesome
we've got I think a a very strong front
runner Is tyrannosaurus rex you've got
ruin your pants here you've got
Tyrannosaurus Rex uh watercolor you got
Tyrannosaurus Rex you can be eaten here
which was a modification of someone
else's Tyrannosaurus Rex you've got uh
so those are so I think Tyrannosaurus
Rex is a strong Contender
um there's definitely been a lot of
Tyrannosaurus Rex uh
uh uh art done and also to me it seems
like
um
it seems it's got a name already it's
name
yeah we're gonna pop a balloon in one
second but I gotta walk through our
mascots first but we're gonna pop a
balloon right after that
well do you remember where your balloon
popper is
you find that balloon popper and we can
pop up alone we got the scissors there
though we can use those if we have to
um and then we've got hummus just the
word hummus not the actual substance
hummus
actually free the balloon yeah we free
but don't do it right now because if you
cut the oh that's weird
static electricity if you cut it now
it'll go to the ceiling and then we want
people to get it down
uh so so I think that it's important
that uh in this case the mascot would
not be the substance hummus which I
haven't seen very much of In The Stream
but just the word hummus and then we've
got lemon
yeah
what are you doing
yes no don't do that don't do that don't
do that we're gonna pop it in just a sec
okay
so we'll look at my lemon man so we've
got various Lemon Lips situations as
well so uh that I was sorry
um and this one oh that's just the lemon
okay where was it
that's Tyrannosaurus Rex again
I'm so confused where'd it go oh there's
this Lemon Lips that's nice
um
and I guess that's all the lemon stuff I
did I thought I had another lemon thing
but that's okay so I guess it's just
this this lemon down here so those are
the things and I'd like to vote so I
think that the things to vote on I don't
think that we need to do bean pickle but
I think that we could do uh
do Lemon Lips
uh Tyrannosaurus Rex
or just the word hummus
all of those are definitely weird
uh enough to be project for awesome
mascots but we haven't we haven't been
able to focus in so we're going to
create a tiltify pole
Tyrannosaurus Rex do you want to see
Tyrannosaurus Rex Orange
what do you think
he's nodding it's good yeah you like it
you want to see a different one
there's that one
you like that one
okay
um he said yeah it's that one so that's
what he thinks but we're gonna create a
tiltify pole and then we're gonna know
what the pro with the and then we're
gonna pop a balloon
um and we're gonna look
so you have to donate to be part of the
poll so uh and it's it counts by dollars
so
it's not fair
Lemon Lips man everybody's tied at zero
right now well this you got it
[Laughter]
we got a whole one out all right
that's really funny buddy that was a
good joke okay which one of these do you
want to cut that one okay
you can where you're going to cut it
right there
I don't know if that's gonna work but
try
do it go go closer to the here
yeah go deeper on the scissor
that's not working
okay
it's not working
okay go get your go where'd that pencil
go oh there it is right there
and then stab it this is
this makes too much noise oh well that's
what popping balloons is
yeah they make a noise when you pop them
do you want me to try and pop it quiet
okay you're gonna do that and I'm you
want me to do it louder or do it quiet
just cut it okay
that was loud oh I got eye twitch
this one says let's read this side
[Music]
that's a weird word
that's right
so there's a clear liquid challenge
everybody and I've got four clear
liquids here I've covered them up
um so that so that confetti doesn't fall
in them and oron I'd like you to tell me
which one of these you'd like me to
drink they're all different things
one of and uh and
uh I won't know until I drink them what
they are
which one would you which one of these
cups you want me to drink out of
um
um this close one okay
should I drink it all fast
should I go really fast
no just drink a little sip
do you want a little sip
it might be water it might be water
come try it
yeah that means
I do not like that
oh I'm sorry
you okay
you want some you want some water yeah
okay here
okay better okay sorry what is it
um it's really salty it might be salt
water okay
um
no it's vinegar
vinegar I'm sorry about that bud yeah
um
vinegar is the worst whoa liquid oh I'm
glad I didn't drink more of that
right now Tyrannosaurus Rex is winning
uh but followed by fairly closely by
just the word hummus
uh
[Music]
I'm just I can't believe I can't I made
my son do that
uh Kelsey says rex rex rex rex Catherine
says for Narnia and for T-Rex Grace and
Melodies uh get the digital download
bundle and says the biggest thanks to my
sister Melody who introduced me to this
wonderful community and was the first to
ever show me what it means to be awesome
Abel says It's gotta be the racks TC
says hummus and hummus says hummus
hummus hummus and sheza says we're
hummus because we're hummus and Ida BL
says
um this is happy for a greetings from
Denmark and Sarah says hi crank and Oren
and Terry says thank you for being you
and Ali says T-Rex T-Rex T-Rex and Aaron
says I can't wait ah and I think that's
for the trivia that I'm doing I'm doing
a trivia night do you remember my trivia
nights but I do sometimes
what or I come out and I quiz people on
trivia things
I do not like that that's what you said
I'm glad that you didn't like it so much
that it was made you sick yeah how does
your tummy feel weird because my feel a
little weird
he's down he's down
what do we need Oren what do we need to
recover from that
it was vinegar it's just white just pure
white vinegar
just acetic acid racks on racks on racks
says Lish T-Rex Supreme says T-Rex
forever and Emma says Long Live hummus
it's a battle
the homeless people are not giving up
let's see where we're at
oh the homeless people aren't giving up
but they aren't pulling ahead
they want to keep fighting for it for
their right to party but
um Oren do you want to tell people about
your poster that you made
um it's right here right
uh here it is
so let's put that in there is that gonna
work yeah
well you don't know yet oh yeah there it
is
um
so there's that poster that you made uh
I can tell people about it it says the
countries of the world by population
yeah
um what choices did we make
to get ready for the future yeah how did
we get ready for the future because as
we we put India in front of China right
because that's at some time this year
it's projected that India is going to
have more people than China
okay so that's what we did and then what
what country did you want to be last
if that's what
is last what's the uh population of
Vatican City do you know
hun oh
he does know
800 and something eight 858
I mean I it's probably not that specific
but let's look
825 in 2019. so it could be 858 by now
who knows maybe some of those people uh
some new people moved in
maybe more people got born
yeah maybe more people got born I'm
telling you what Lemon Lips is not gonna
win uh but but uh lemon lip sounds kind
of creepy yeah no it's definitely creepy
uh wouldn't be the first creepy project
for awesome mascot for example we have
not actually seen from a previous mascot
everybody to them
who's this Aaron
I forgot this uh his name is beanie
sandverbs and it was a project awesome
mascot in like 2020 or something like
that had to be 2020 or 2021 yeah it's 20
20. well yeah who knows really
oh gotta take this down if you're gonna
be doing we eat the baked bean bee it's
the baked bean bee that's right
that's what we call it
but its name is beanie sandverbs
officially
do you want to write something on beanie
Sanford's bottom do you wanna
put put something on there
what would you what would you draw your
name maybe
oh you're gonna do the stick man
mm-hmm
what's your favorite thing to draw
Stickman yeah
what does Stickman do
they're just
yeah that
nice well now beanie Sanford has a
stickman on the bottom
so we'll always remember that Oren did
that
fun
that's you
don't get your spit in your mouth please
all right uh I don't know when to call
it uh here uh definitely the vinegar was
the one that was the worst of the wands
so I'm glad that we got that one first I
guess just so I don't have to fret about
it
um we don't we're not doing another one
yet
we got there's there's three more clear
liquid challenges in these balloons here
foreign
but I don't know that we should pop
another one quite yet we got to look at
how things are going
um Maya says racks those pants and to
Phi says hummus hummus hummus this is I
mean it makes I guess it makes sense
that it was tricky for me to decide what
the mascot is when there is a fair
amount of confusion you're gonna pop a
balloon just by leaning against it
I don't think that's gonna work
you never know
wait just put it on the ground and sit
on it
okay not right there though
oh geez
that's a powerful balloon
this is very cute everybody
it's got a bunch of stuff stuck to it
you gotta squish it you got to do it
again get on there and put your Just
Bounce with your butt
maybe jump on it okay try that
yeah don't use both feet because you
could go flying
that didn't work either
go sit on it put up between your legs
and just just
pound on it oof
no you don't want to try sitting on it
there it is
whoa
yep oh clear liquid challenge
got another clear challenge everybody
you taste it this time yeah you don't
want to taste it first
bad I
water hooray
hooray
so glad so glad that it's water I might
[Music]
yeah oh we're about to hit eight oh my
gosh we're about to hit our goal Lauren
oh I drank it sorry you can drink the
rest of this if you want water
um our next goal is 888
888.88 cents
and what are we at we are at 888 000
172.89
I know let's see who's gonna get us
there
who's gonna get us there and then we're
gonna be joined by another guest soon I
believe
uh
uh yo and a little and we got another we
got another half hour so great
what buddy
what was that noise about
yeah you like popping balloons huh that
was really funny watching you sit on
that and falling
has the word egg in it oh it has the
word egg in it we can't I well I don't
have all the necessary materials for
that one right now but I can get them
pretty quick I think
um yes
uh this one
this one We're Not Gonna We're not gonna
do it we're gonna do it when we hit the
goal okay buddy okay
um
[Music]
this is very hot hat if you're wondering
but I'm doing it for I'm doing it for
the people
we've got a lot of donations uh hummus
is already in the lore guide uh that's
great that's great but is it a better
mascot than Tyrannosaurus Rex I just
don't know it's just a word it's just
the word hummus
and what about oh gosh
there's those there's those like
inflatable Tyrannosaurus suits that but
dressed up like Mr delicious would be
very good
just open in your mouth real big
yep I bet we're there Oren I bet we're
there
we are we did it we hit it okay one more
balloon
do you want to try and sit on it again
okay he's gonna try and sit on it again
there he is this is yours covered
then he fell
he fell
[Laughter]
do you see any
is there something in there oh it's
right there by the Light
yep
that was already there
okay
just popped the popped the end off so it
didn't come out
you want me to help
it's gonna be tricky to get it out
wait I got it you're gonna cut it okay
you want to do it that's okay you can do
it in the meantime I'm gonna say thank
you to kres who got the digital download
bundle and says T-Rex Mr D and Mary Pat
uh
uh got something for twenty dollars and
who knows what it is because Delta 5
sometimes doesn't tell you
oh uh antler got your countries by
population so that's awesome
and uh Mary Pat got the hangar fish
temporary tattoos which I didn't know
existed Zeta said thank you
uh nerdfighteria Hank and Johnna all
co-hosts and everybody working behind
the scenes volunteering to make project
for awesome work this brings me so much
joy even the cursed mascots and memes
and got the hanklerfish temporary
tattoos I didn't know those existed
that's new information to me that's
great I love that
um we just got some people who are
getting polls uh for T-Rex uh and
nothing else
this person got the digital download
bundle and made their vote count toward
T-Rex
he's almost got it everybody all right
there it is it's a big one
what's it say
stand up here so people can hear you can
you stand up here so people can hear you
tell us a story you can wear every
sentence
stars with the next letter of the
alphabet
where every sentence starts with the
next letter of the alphabet oh my gosh
that's gonna be tricky orange do you
want me to tell you a story where every
sentence start to the next letter of the
alphabet yeah
all right
that's gonna be my first sentence all
right
Ben the beaver wanted to go to the store
can he go to the store
dare I say he can
forever and ever he walks to the store
putting one Little Beaver foot in front
of the next
gosh what a cute little Beaver he is
he's really doing his thing
abcdefgh
I can't believe that a cute little
Beaver like Ben the beaver has to go to
the store all on his own he's such a
little baby beaver that I'd think that
he would be accompanied
joking he could totally do it by himself
no big deal
oh boy we're getting into the less
common letters now
Karen the the kangaroo interrupts been
the beaver on his way and says Ben I
know you're going to the store can you
pick up some lemon hummus for me while
you're there
look Karen says Ben the beaver who turns
out is maybe not a baby but is a little
bit of a belligerent drunk beaver look
Karen
I don't know what you're thinking but I
can't just be doing chores for random
people who stop me along the way
my goodness Karen says that's not very
neighborly of you why wouldn't you want
to help out an old lady kangaroo with
some of her chores to pick up some lemon
hummus
oh amen
no you listen here says Ben the beaver
this isn't how it works and if you want
me to be a doordasher for you you have
to doordash with me I have an account
and I'll do that and I need at least a
minimum two dollar tip
oh my gosh it says Karen the kangaroo
what is the world coming to currently
just be neighbors
um
LMNOP
says Ben the beaver period
p a mfpq oh
um quickly says uh it says Mary the
mouse run run for your lives it was
getting a little boring so we had to
have something happen there QR
really says Ben the beaver
really says
oh I guess that would be a new sentence
really says Ben the beaver what's wrong
what's going on what's the concern
um
and uh our QRS
something's coming something terrible
it's the Specter of every everything
being commodified not through
appreciation but only dollars
uh is what's coming
s t that sounds like not that big of a
deal says Ben the beaver
you
um actually says Karen the kangaroo it
sounds like a huge deal it sounds like a
complete shift in the way Humanity
imagines its relationship to itself uh
both as individuals and as societies
um you
answer to um rstuv
very good point said the mouse who is I
think name was Mary
I don't know the alphabet very well I
should have written it down ABCD V x
what now I have
t u v w x y z okay that's what we got
left
um
well where was I uh the Mary said very
good point
when will this ever end says uh says
Karen the kangaroo
um
X huh
x what word starts with xoren
what
hexagon
okay hexahine says Ben the beaver
um and then uh period and then he thinks
for a second uh and it's not part of the
story and he says you know what
I think you're right I hadn't thought of
it that way before but we need to be
more like neighbors not just like
everything is a commodified interaction
that can only be properly appreciated
through money uh and then they all said
Zoom because they had to run away from
that Specter of everything being
commodified not through appreciation and
there being no other form of
appreciation than capital
thank you very much that's the story of
Ben the beaver and marry the mouse and
Karen the kangaroo
and I hope that you liked it uh that's
what I had that's everything I had for
you
and I I honestly it could have gone away
worse
so right now we're gonna I haven't
actually uh because the world has been
oh nope
I hope I hope everybody's doing well I
gotta pop out that chat so I have a
better view of it
yeah buddy
it's not a balloon time
we'll do one more pop before when Mama
comes in okay
look at that I only have four balloons
for the entire rest of the project for
awesome
let's blow up a different one and we'll
pop that one
but no task
I need to save some
you want we're gonna have a lot of
balloons bud we're gonna have so many
balloons
um
I forgot e okay well
uh you know it it is what it is
apparently I forgot E A B C D E I just
moved straight to f
yeah you want to blow that up
get these
into these I put it when they're uh when
they're deflated and then I blow them up
with them inside
wee oh it almost hit you
um hilarious hilarious that I forgot the
letter e don't forget don't forget to
awesome
I don't know what he would have said you
know it would have been the same story
you know you don't know maybe if I had
included the E it would have gone an
entirely different direction you never
know that was in the beginning when
anything could have happened Hank and
Catherine Greene
we guys vote Lemon Lips I'm broke yeah
Amber I don't know I don't know if
you're gonna be the one in charge of
that unfortunately I'd love for you to
be
uh am I Frozen right now like super
Frozen No no I'm good I'm good
did you know that uh if you're watching
you can actually go to uh double speed
and it will catch you more up to be
where I am rather than like a little bit
behind very wild so if you shift and
then hit the like over like Arrow
bracket
you'll zoom up to like more actual
real-time of the podcast uh Hank please
check the slack great I will do that
sorry
um
okay I will save a task for when that
happens I will have one ready for that
thank you very much probably
yeah wow you really blew that up bud
good work
oh
yeah
it did it came to get me it was totally
random but it decided to come get me
oh the funniest thing in the whole
entire world
um I did do the ceiling balloon it fell
it actually fell down in the night and I
I popped it and put it in a different
balloon so it's a little bit
anticlimactic about the ceiling balloon
but
it's what happened
you guys this is totally a podcast
what's totally a podcast
[Music]
well uh I accidentally cut one of the
strings and one went all the way up and
I couldn't get it because it was too
high for me for me to reach the string
foreign
yeah I don't know why my slack isn't
making sound
um I don't think I haven't muted
no I don't
I don't know it didn't make sound it
should have
they should have said hummus is what it
should have said
um on the screen right now you will see
the countries of the world by population
a map created by me and Oren green it
was Art directed by Oren he told me that
he wanted the countries to be rainbow he
wanted the countries to be the shape of
the countries and not the flags he said
they wanted to be each the same size
even if they were different sizes which
thank goodness because that would have
been really difficult to pull off and he
said he wanted them to be ordered by
population
um we sort of uh we we went through a
couple of iterations where we changed oh
it got big on the screen it's covering
up Aura now it uh it was uh in rainbow
form
um and it took us about a full day and
we had to figure out how to get it
printed for Oren and it's on the wall of
his room now and he has that along with
um
uh another map that shows the countries
of the world by area so those are the
sort of two ways that he likes to see
things
um they're not Mercator Projection
because they uh when you when you've got
a like a Countryside thing it's not as
big of a deal like the map projection
mess up uh doesn't affect things as much
uh maybe for a country like China which
does go from sort of closer to the
Equator to predict Northern uh it might
mess things up a little bit but um but
they are not attempting to be the like
correct size in relation to each other
which they definitely aren't
um
I got it yeah whoa that's gonna pop all
in its own you want to throw it away
again see what happens
oh it's really was moving slow there I
like that
um I don't know who's coming after me uh
um
I was I I last night I got in trouble
for telling people what the schedule
looked like but I haven't actually
looked at it well oh no what is it it's
this
I have to show everyone what it looks
like
it's a lemon Furby and a pickle Furby
and the pickle Furby is full of Bean
Juice
I think this was made by I'm trying to
move it around so that I can shrink it
down oh I didn't mean to close it
elastic
yeah yeah
how do I shrink it here we go
yeah oh my gosh
it's beautiful they're long Furbies made
of pickle and Bean Juice and one made a
lemon oh my God
oh it's hummus it's lemon hummus
uh
uh I do I did want to see it it's true
and it's from Alice and it's I I want it
I don't do I want it they don't know
it's it'd be a bit much to to put this
on the wall of my home
but it's also really beautiful
I love it so much very very cursed oh I
hate it oh the horror burn it uh this is
horrifying maybe a sticker let's not do
it as a poster because that seems like a
lot but I think a sticker I think it
would work as a sticker and I like I'd
like to
foreign I'd like to be able to own this
and to apply it to my laptop
um
but I don't know if Alice would like to
would like that to happen and don't put
it on a wall
the back of a shirt that's a lot of
colors but I might not might need to be
print on demand for it to I don't know
you could screen print that maybe you
could
um please sell that it'll be in the
nerdfighter art perk which is part of
the or it'll be on the digital art perk
which is part of the digital download
bundle that's a big balloon buddy for
sure
oh Oren do you want to be around for the
magic show
yeah okay let's let's have that be a
thing what is the magic show that'll be
some magic I don't know exactly what
it'll be
yeah that's fun
[Music]
would probably be a good puzzle I don't
know if we can pull off a puzzle this
way and the projects are awesome I'm
gonna I'm gonna let people who are in
charge of perks decide what's possible
um
uh and and they'll let me know in the in
the slack whether or not we can do
something with that because it is very
good but you'll definitely get it as I
think I'm pretty sure that it will be
submitted as part of the art oh sorry I
just saw your text finally
oh man
what's this
that's from earlier today okay
you make yourself pass it open yeah
no orange been blowing it up all on his
own
I sort of like Get I like blow it up one
time and then he can blow him up
then he wasn't up and he lets it Go and
it flies around
is it Kitty time regardless of whether
it's Kitty time it's gonna be Kitty time
oh gummy bear thought that was
interesting
come here
hello look at the camera
up here
we have to do our
holiday card everybody look at the
camera
no smile face no silly face
[Laughter]
one of those will work yeah I actually
he did I saw that he did what did you
think of that well how I'm treating our
son oh I I mean no I didn't see him
drink the vinegar I saw the uh
I saw the the arrangement of three clear
liquids on the oh yeah last night and I
was like what's this about this is going
to be interesting yeah so Oren Oren had
a little bit of vinegar and he said I
did not like that and I was worried that
he might be unhappy incentive sad about
it but he recovered quickly he had some
water it helped yeah
yeah so many strings it wasn't even he
wasn't even sure what to make of it he
was like was that very salty
I want to pop balloon you want a pop
balloon
um
we can't do it we can't pop one of these
with the tasks in it right now because I
need to save some yeah that is only got
about so many of those but we can blow
up another one you can pop it
just regular one but a helium balloon if
you guys want or we can blow up a normal
one yeah and you can pop it if you want
you don't like popping it that much
either
tie it up I do not like that
it was very funny
yeah he does
inside of it for you
a task for you yeah but well how will
gummy bear feel about the popping he's
not gonna like it but he's not gonna
like it he'll he'll recover
oh he hates the garbage truck so much
Destiny the garbage truck is like boom
yeah Gummy Bear runs runs runs away
oh you get what in there
oh I just fold them up and shove them in
and I blow it up
yeah it's wet yeah yeah
you were blowing it up oh okay cool
um
Rachel says one more donation to be part
of the raxolent adventure you can still
get the uh Hank and John's rocksolent
Adventure perk where you can go or you
can you you can uh be be along for the
ride with us we're gonna make some
content that's public and some content
that's private so if you want to get all
of it you can get the Hank and John's
racksaw and Adventure perk for twenty
dollars you can get the hummus lover uh
nope that's a different thing you can
get the dftba wall hanging that's just
from hummus lovers the person who bought
that uh and I I didn't know about the
dftba wall hanging but it looks like
it's beautiful maybe I could pop that up
if I get it on the on the uh
slack I can show you that uh because I
haven't seen it yet
yeah look at your tiny camera isn't that
a cool camera you know what a funny
thing about that camera
it's actually a flash drive
it's a secret am I cool yeah I don't
know where I got that but
some of some event
Susie says this one's her for anyone who
isn't able to donate and got the
nerdfighter art second half for 55
dollars
cart EP got crab said crab crab and got
the crabilis monthly subscription where
for eight dollars uh a year at some
years 66 dollars a month you can get a
different piece of crab art in your
inbox every day for in every month not
every day that would be a lot of work
Gabe says those Furbies are nightmare
fuel and got the Dad cast with Hank and
Travis Sarah said my husband and I love
this perk it's been such a delight and
got the trivia night with Hank number
two it is really fun what are you gonna
do bud there's your balloon you gonna
pop that one okay you want me to show
you popping up
yeah that's how he was doing that
he's doing it
literally got a hop
that's so cool I love that
Ukraine green Shakespeare and it's all
wet because there's a lot of spit in
there
we won't send that one in the confetti
envelopes we'll just put that one in the
trash can you don't need this pretty one
it just fell apart yeah I did the crank
green Shakespeare last night I should
have practiced because it did not turn
out uh I don't want to give it to me
I don't want to judge it either
you want to wear the crab hat yeah yeah
good because my head is very hot
oh perfect oh it's way better on you
this is cute I might need a coat though
yeah because Halloween is cold in
Montana
perfect that was for us
oh my
God I may need a hat now
you took away my crab hat
look at me I'm just a I'm just a man now
what are you gonna do just wrap up wrap
up fart button yeah okay
that's definitely what it is
um this is cultural appropriation like a
like a Babushka situation of the
apartment oh
because you're not book parchment
why
not better
oh that wall hanging gotcha all right
we're going to now be joined by Mark
Gibson for some magic time uh I think
that he will pop in any moment now
and I'm excited to see
and I uh what what happens
and we'll see what
you're gonna put that task in there okay
um hello hey
hello how are you I'm well how about
yourself
I'm good I'm wearing a shirt on my head
it's a great place to wear it I'd say
it's very good to see you thank you so
much for joining us everybody this is
this is Mark Mark uh Delights and
entertains people all over the world uh
yes you're there and everywhere Here
There and Everywhere
um I've I've been witness to his talents
and it can be sometimes a little
overwhelming
well hopefully in a good way yeah well
you know sometimes I'm like is that
person about to staple their hand to a
piece of
food
possibly but thankfully uh no Staples
again no Staples yet no Staples yet
um good how are you doing right now
doing well doing great it's actually
been a little bit since I've seen you I
got married since last I saw you oh
that's amazing yeah
what is that is that ring do anything
magical
uh does the ring go to the uh it it
transformed me from from man to husband
so that that is the magic that is
bestowed within this ring
you have a crab over your shoulder I see
I do you guys I think we've met once
before
yeah
okay buddy
oh goodness me well I do have some magic
here uh prepared for us would you like
to see something for everybody uh yeah
I'm so curious what you what you have
prepared
yeah so I know I've kind of been uh
tilted and Shifting the camera a little
bit I just want to be sure that it's in
frame uh over here over my shoulder uh
you see a little bulldog clip uh with a
little blue there you go I see a little
blue piece of paper hanging there in the
corner you all can see that yeah yeah
yeah yeah perfect uh that would be
important in just a little bit actually
what that is uh I've I've kind of Taken
on a nightly practice really uh Hank do
you ever have like a dream journal do
you ever like write down your dreams
when you wake up in the morning yeah
yeah so I think a lot of people do that
but I'm starting to get into it uh and
as I go through and read through them I
realize how absolutely Bonkers insane my
own brightness
yeah yeah uh because they often when you
wake up you forget about them but then
when you go back and read them you're
like holy cow where the heck did that
come from uh and I wrote some down I
have like scraps of paper or things
around the apartment and I'll just
doodle on them and I'll keep them uh so
I have one right here uh that's one that
I wrote actually was last night
uh and it was just a dream that I had
honestly was a bit of a nightmare uh but
uh but I wrote it down and it's it is
Bonkers mad and uh actually Hank you and
I are going to kind of uh recreate and
reimagine uh what this nightmare was uh
so all of these decisions are gonna come
from you Hank and they can be completely
your own decision uh and equally for
everybody watching I didn't ask you I
didn't text you ahead of time going hey
Hank I need you to help me with this you
didn't even know we were gonna do this
till now nope nope perfect nope well
Hank uh my nightmare began it was a very
cold and rainy night uh and it was
somewhere in the world Hank where in the
world did this dream take place
uh absolutely anywhere
oh you got a little one of those uh it
took place it took place in um
took place in Brazil
in Brazil that's exactly right it was a
cold and rainy day in Brazil now I
wasn't alone in this dream uh I looked
to my left and there was somebody with
me was a friend of mine
what was my friend's name Hank uh was it
Barack Obama
was it Obama it was Obama That's the
amazing thing I was here in Brazil I was
walking around with Barack Obama and as
we were walking around we wanted to get
out of the rain uh so we found a diner
and we walked inside and we ordered
something what kind of food did we order
Hank
I think that it was like fries but like
uh some kind of like Regional variation
where they're very wet they got a lot of
stuff on them but very wet fried like
chili fries almost yeah I like that okay
like chili fries I like it uh and we
also had something to drink what did we
drink
oh just Cokes just two guys yeah two two
cokes Barack Obama or sat in his
Brazilian Diner uh someone bursts in the
door and robs the place
now they have a disguise because they
didn't want to just be recognized they
were dressed up like an animal
what kind of animal were they dressed up
as Hank weirdly enough it was a crab it
was a crab that's exactly right it was a
crab
this person came Waltzing in and they
were dressed up like a crab uh and they
they robbed us they walked up and they
said give me all your money but this is
this is where your heart sinks
especially in a nightmare is when you're
asked to do something and you can't do
it I reach into my pocket and I pulled
out it wasn't any money it wasn't my
wallet or anything it was a random
object Hank is there anything in the
room that you could pick up
yeah yeah a random thing anything you
want this is your decision
um
a balloon a balloon that's exactly what
it was I reached in my pocket and all I
had on me was a balloon it was deflated
it was in my pocket that all I had and I
sank this robber needed money and he
wanted an exact amount of money that was
the weird part
Hank how much money did this robber
demand from me do you know Lauren
25 cents
25 cents that's exactly right buddy yes
all we wanted was exactly 25 cents this
burglar dressed like a crab wanted 25
cents but thankfully thankfully I reach
into my back pocket and what do I feel a
very tiny metallic quarter and I had 25
cents and I handed it to him and I said
here you go and well right after that I
mean my heart sank but I woke up and I
mean wow what a nightmare that was that
was absolute bloggers yeah and you made
all those decisions like we were in
Brazil you're exactly right with Barack
Obama we went into a diner we had some
chili fries and cokes a crab man came in
and robbed us I had a balloon but
thankfully I had exactly the 25 cents
that that person was offering uh now
that's been in full view since we
started right that's right having a near
it my hands have been in full view the
entire time uh I'm gonna reach over here
and come back and see what happens he's
grabbed the grabbed the clip got a
little piece of paper and we're gonna
read out what it says here on live okay
I'm gonna hold it up right here so you
all can see it and we're gonna read it
off
together I'm gonna wait for my computer
to kind of catch up here I hope that's
gonna be the right way around yeah it
says two uh 2 17 23 drink dribble this
is exactly what it was uh let's see what
it says I'm very cold it's rainy in
Brazil
yeah it's very rainy in Brazil uh I'm
walking down the road Obama is with me
and we enter into a diner
I don't know how you're doing this Hank
but this is absolutely wonderful let's
see what the next section says we order
two chili fries with a Cola bottle to
drink
absolutely we had two notes just two
dudes sharing a Coke and some chili
fries and I told you the scariest part
of this nightmare is when somebody broke
in and started to rob the place uh
before we pay a person dressed as a crab
walks into the diner and robs it they
approach us and they demand for our
wallets
sadly uh all I had on me was a deflated
balloon that's all I had on me at the
time
you did it and then uh they asked for a
certain amount of money for a particular
kind of money but thankfully in my back
pocket I had exactly 25 cents what a
nightmare that was
how do you do that how'd he do that
well done
[Music]
yeah the story
yeah the story that we told with him
wow well
[Music]
I'll hold that up if anyone wants a
screenshot that there you go yeah what
um well done Hank well done
makes no sense I do not understand
perfect
that's that's the way it should be
that's that's the fun part that's the
fun part
um so right now if you so I don't know
how aware you are of our situation but
this is the project for awesome it's a
48-hour live stream where we have a
bunch of perks that are available uh at
project for awesome bye buddy thank you
for helping helping me out uh at
projector awesome.com donate there's a
live stream it goes for a very long time
I have not slept the normal amount and
uh and it's only and there's a little
clock behind me that shows me that we've
got 20 hours and 37 minutes left so
there's uh there's there's miles to go
before we sleep
um and uh right now on tiltify uh We've
we just hit 900 000 total dollars raised
from people getting uh perks on on
tiltify and we are trying to select our
mascot for the project for awesome which
looks like it's somewhat likely to be uh
Tyrannosaurus racks so a a dinosaur
that has some connection to the 90s fast
food chain racks
oh okay yeah do you remember did you
ever go to Iraq's you're you're right I
have not been to Iraq's but I hear you
and John talk about it on the podcast
often
yeah exactly it's just this fictitious
magical place that you built of hyped up
so much
yeah so we're gonna go to Rax that's one
of the things that the product for
Austin has determined is is we had
enough people buy the Hank and John's
raxlund Adventure perk that we we have
to in the next year at some point
somehow it the racks so that's awesome
yeah I'm excited to to eat the whole
menu
absolutely is Rax like a is it a burger
joint is it what do they make
yeah it's roast beefy oh okay okay I can
dig it
yeah
um Tyrannosaurus Rex
that was uh that was wild
um
I don't know I don't know what I missed
uh but or maybe like look dreams are
weird they are weird right and we all
some people think dreams are Universal
we all just have the same dreams that we
just share them that's right could very
well be something like that or you
influenced me somehow to send me to
Brazil with Barack Obama yep you know as
everyone chooses
[Laughter]
goodness me but the the live has been
been treating you well in the room here
at the home stretch now Hank you're
almost there I guess
um don't think about it don't don't go
hour by hour then it then
is that the key you just kind of like
you're running a marathon you're like
don't count the miles just keep running
yeah it's exactly as difficult as
running a marathon I'm sure
likewise I have no I'm jumping off point
for that yeah I've not I have no
experience nor do I expect to have
experience with running many miles in a
day
how was uh
how his life is a uh as a Entertainer
and content creator been uh and and in
the last couple of years
it's been lovely uh it's been very very
nice uh starting to Branch out and do
more colleges which is very very fun uh
so I've been all over the country now
uh for just College demographic seems to
just really Drive well with me they
really like the migrating stuff uh so
been all over all over the US was in
Southwest New Hampshire I'm sorry it was
in Southern New Hampshire University a
couple of months ago I was in uh Texas
uh really going all over the place it's
been really really fun
um one thing I did know I have never
been to Texas before uh I was walking
around on campus and I walked past a
tree and the tree just starts making
this horrible hissing sound and I turned
to somebody and I'm like so do the trees
just hate me
because I never encounter a tree just
making this horrible sound like no those
are cicadas and me being the Southern
California boy I go what's a cicada and
then my eye was thoroughly horrified the
rest of the time I was in Texas
just the sort of the existence of
cicadas it's horrifying I understood the
existence of a cicada I just didn't
realize habitat and why and where and
what kind of sounding they're very loud
they are extremely loud I was it was
impressive you can make questions yeah
so you have a uh you have a perk that
you have made available for us what is
it that is right so uh for those of you
that are here uh a perk of mine is that
I will do a virtual show I was part of
the project for awesome last year and it
was super fun uh and we did a virtual
show for folks so uh that was one of the
perks that folks could uh be a part of
uh and it was wonderful so they see a
bit for my live show that I can do the
wonderful thing about what's called
mentalism this kind of magic that I do
involves mind reading kind of thing as
All You Need is Another mind so that way
it works beautifully with people all
over the world uh through video so it
can still work virtually just like I've
done with Hank here a little taste of
what you could see during the show uh
but yeah it's a full show that I do and
it's super fun and it all happens and
you don't even you don't even need to
put on pants but please put on pants
you have no you you don't know you won't
ever know uh it's true I may not be
wearing pants no one would not
uh and unless there's some portion of
the show that really does involve uh
sort of a full body experience that kind
of a hammered down situation but yeah
you also do like like um
handwork like juggling and such I'm not
making myself yeah
yeah no no that's that's exactly it a
lot of the things that I do especially
on Tick Tock uh involve like jungling
and like hand shadows and things like
that uh which is really nice Tick Tock
has been fantastic in the the things
that I do on stage can translate a bit
on Tick Tock but also some of these
other random things with kazoos and
whatnot it's just a wonderful place to
go and uh exemplify that so uh yeah a
lot of people may have seen a lot of
like the the tennis ball juggling stuff
that I do I have some tennis balls if
you want me to
I mean sure I've always been very
impressed
um uh but but my like my main question
here is yeah it seems as if oh the show
is on March 10th at seven o'clock
Pacific time
um and also Mark knows a lot about 18th
century uh pirate eye patch technology
our two things yeah read in the chat
um uh but it seems like well also that
third thing as well uh they don't have a
hotel to do with each other so
um you know like like doing them like
very weird surprising tennis ball
juggling and being able to remind and no
it's not about pirate eye patch
technology they seem very disparate
um is this sort of like once you start
to develop some skills you want to
develop more skills or are you just kind
of the person the kind of person who
always has to be learning something new
I I am a a project and talent junkie I
think is the best way I could describe
it um it's just a a Fascination and
general curiosity that cannot be
satiated uh and just when I when I start
to work at something or figure something
it just kind of spirals out of control
and goes from there uh I think you see a
lot of that especially of Egyptians uh
because magic is a very repetitive
habitual there needs to be a lot of
practice involved doing very minute
things that no one is ever going to see
so it takes a lot of effort in order to
to get to that point and juggling is
very much the same actually that tennis
ball juggling uh thing that I do which
I'm probably just there uh came I was
bored when I was in high school I was a
freshman and we were just we're all
playing tennis and we're not doing PE
class and I already knew how to juggle
like just three balls and then I grabbed
the canister and I could like throw it
in and out of the canister a bit and
catch it and I was just bored that's all
that it was and so it was never intended
to be put on stage or really to show
anybody it was just something that I
just kind of figured out and it wasn't
so years years later I was actually at
the Magic Castle in Hollywood and they
were just putting together a stage show
and they went we have enough bird people
making Birds up here we have enough
people doing this we need something just
to break
to break up all the magic it's just it's
too much all in one show we need
something just to kind of be a palette
cleanser and I just had him with me and
I said I can do this and just did that
and they wouldn't keep it
so that happened and then I put a video
on Tick Tock and then everyone thought
that was that was fun and quirky so yeah
and I just love being as entertaining as
possible with as little amount of things
as possible yeah one of the things I've
noticed about uh being an Entertainer is
it's always great to have another trick
in the pocket where it's like you've
been impressed by this but and then like
some some tick tocker who like mostly
does comedy will hit you with like you
know like a self-harmonizing thing where
they like have a beautiful voice and
you're like yeah that's not fair exactly
I can't you can't be funny and talented
yeah
one so it's always good to be like you
thought I was just a mind reader and
Mentalist but watch what I can do with a
tennis ball but also right totally
separate uh ability the most fun thing
about all of that is congruity in a show
like I I think I I once threw that in
because just the talent Booker's like
hey the next acts didn't show up can you
add an extra five or ten minutes to your
show I was like yeah sure so it was all
mind reading all that it was and it's
fun and interactive and upbeat and
everything but at one point I just went
and now and just grabbed them and just
did like four minutes of juggling put it
away when you're thinking about a
playing card it just went right back
into it so the whole audience was a bit
confused of like I think that's great
okay that's this is how the the minds of
the youth work now we nobody can focus
on anything for a full 55 minutes
um so
um now we've been talking about it so
much I feel like I need to I we need to
see some juggling absolutely we've been
we've been talking about it far too long
so let me let me adjust give myself a
little bit more space here all right
that is false sounds false actually a
lot of people have asked me about this
this is just a normal tennis ball
canister uh where these Stripes come
from and why the stripes are there I
took the label off just so people can
see the balls in there a bit more
clearly uh and as you'll see in a minute
this actually helps uh just for me to be
able to see uh let's jump into the
impressive stuff back this up just a
little bit just so you can see a little
more now we're going to do the angle
down thing angle down business you can
see my dirty desk behind me possibly I
will see that you're wearing pants and
all of that absolutely
all right
that's wild
so the fun thing about all that is uh
you start with three and you can work
your way up and down
it works just the same with two
but again this all just came about I was
just horrendously bored as a teenager
and just kind of taught myself uh I had
to do all this so
yes
ta-da just one one ball and a and a two
but it's still uh my mind is broken I
don't even know what's happening
it happens very fast that's one of the
things that people comment on the videos
a lot is that you're you're going so
fast it's like I have to watch it five
times just to like pick up what's
happening yeah and it does go rather
quick but
yeah
the uh on the canister here I took off
the labels so people can can actually
see them but I put these two strips on
here so that way when I toss the
canister and it rotates in the air uh I
can actually see its orientation because
since it's clear when it rotates I can't
always tell
where it is because it's spinning too
fast or in harsh stage lights so uh a
lot of people ask why you put serps on
them or where you get these ones that
have the strips on them it's just a
piece of tape and it just helps when you
better
through the air like that so where it is
all the time
a final question for the for a project
Junkie
okay has there been any part of magic
where you just sort of or you know sort
of stage performance where you you like
I want to figure this out but you hit a
wall and you kind of gave in you're like
this is like I actually
like the the things that people do to
get to the level of skill where it would
be a useful skill would just be it's
just kind of insurmountable for me
yes uh Quick Change
so there's uh of the multiple different
styles of magic
um and I've kind of dabbled in all of
them over the years I close that magic
sleight of hand magic uh even stage like
producing parasols and like stuff like
that uh there's a very Niche genre
called Quick Change artists uh and
they're the people you may have seen
videos of them on like America's Got
Talent or whatnot but they're the folks
that are like in a in a big long red
dress and then they uh grab a curtain
and they just really fast and now the
dress is blue and now it's green and now
it's yellow and they they constantly are
rapidly and magically changing their
outfits again and again and again and
again
very when done very well it is
awe-inspiring it is really really great
I dabbled in that for a little bit and
once you just kind of get to the tip of
the iceberg and realize hey this is
probably why there aren't that many
Quick Change artists in the world
because it is amazingly difficult I mean
the skill not only to execute it but
also to construct these garments to do
it to do it well to do it seamlessly was
just absolutely blew my mind so yeah
that was one of like I can make my shirt
change and that's that's all I need to
do
[Laughter]
interesting that's really cool I would
not have guessed uh because that's not
one that I think about very often but
now I want to watch some Quick Change
magic
oh very much so maybe just a quick
YouTube search and you'll find you'll
find there's not that many in the world
and I think that's why it is remarkably
impressive when can be done well but
holy cow right right so there's like
there's like the work of understanding
how to actually construct the Garment
and then there's the sort of intricacies
of doing it so perfectly because that's
what a lot of magic is it's like you
don't have any like and I don't know
this I've just sort of uh talked to
people who do it is is it the difference
of doing it very well and doing it well
is so big
it's just so many hours
yeah yeah and one of those the same
trick being like oh yeah that was
interesting versus being like what the
there's just a wide Gulf of time
very much so
the uh Irene Larson who is one of the
founders of the Magic Castle
um came to me and said any anyone can
learn how to do a trick but very few
people can do magic
I thought that was a very intriguing
distinction between the two it's one
thing to present a puzzle and another
thing to him it presents an impossible
thing and and where that interplay is I
think is where the art lives that's
awesome that's really cool so tell me
one thing about 18th century pirate eye
patch technology holy moly I'm so glad
you asked I
my wife Vanessa told me this fact and I
have been thinking about it at least
three times a day said she told me uh I
had no idea why Pirates would wear eye
patches my natural inclination was your
eye was injured in some capacity yeah
exactly there's a lot of projectiles and
things so but she said no do you want to
know why pirates wear eye patches I said
wise is because if you go down below in
the hull of the ship to get supplies
it's very dark down there and they don't
want to light lanterns or things because
there's gunpowder and stuff so it's all
in complete darkness so they wear an eye
patch so one eye acclimates to the dark
like naturally adjusts to being in
darkness so when they go down below they
can just switch eyes and now their eye
that can see is already acclimatized to
the darkness
white like that that absolutely
shattered all of that doubled my IQ in
one sentence
[Laughter]
that's oh my God
yeah and you're up there and you're like
I don't need I don't need depth
perception it's uh it's just a ship I
know where everything is exactly
swinging things and people with firearms
come on it's fine
so as a uh as a professional magician is
there a magician or magicians who you
think are uh sort of top of the form
that
um too
absolutely yeah I mean uh the the first
answer I think for me and for many
performers out there is David
Copperfield uh and and for very good
reason I mean the man's still playing
the MGM selling out houses uh and it's
just considered this just most revered
Magician of all time I think with most
people were to say name a magician it
would be Harry Houdini or David
Copperfield so in terms of the
mainstream uh magician or Mentalist
people may not uh know very much about
as a gentleman in the UK his name is
Darren Brown uh phenomenal performer and
he specializes in the kind of magic I do
called mentalism uh wonderful wonderful
shows deeply mysterious and just a
genuinely kind and lovely person
um I've seen his shows on YouTube uh
there's also some shows that he put out
on Netflix so if you're interested in
the name uh Darren Brown it is uh and
it's remarkably great um in fact he did
a special where he convinced someone
that uh it was the end of the world
so a lot of the things that he does is
very like influence and psychological
manipulation and ideas like that so he
said how far can I take this so he
staged it to where he was convincing a
singular person that it was the end of
the world zombies existed and it was
called Darren Brown's apocalypse it it
is phenomenal so if that's the kind of
stuff that you're interested in the
stuff that I do Darren Brown is
definitely cream of the crop nowadays
awesome
I uh I appreciate that now I have stuff
to watch absolutely
um so the magic show that the the
virtual magic show that you could be a
part of it's going to be March 10th at
seven o'clock uh Pacific time
uh and you can you can see you saw a
little bit of of what Mark has to offer
but you could see a lot more if you get
that perk uh and it's available now and
until the product for awesome ends I
don't know if it has a capped attendance
or not uh anyone and everybody if you'd
like to be a part of I would love to
have you
great
um mark thank you so much for coming by
for the project for awesome again it's
really good to see you absolutely
congratulations to see you again on
being transformed into a married person
look at that
um a little bit of magic uh happening
legally and culturally there
um
and I hope that you have a lovely rest
your day you as well Hank uh I wish it
was Speedy 20 hours you could do it I
believe in you uh thank you and John and
all of your team at complexity for all
the wonderful things that you do and for
putting this on uh and for just the
wonderful joy that you spread to so many
people it's an honor to be a part of it
in any capacity
and thank you again for all that you do
thanks so much Mark
neat
uh so what do we have wow I always love
looking at the at the tiltify page after
after I've been looking at something for
a while uh I'd like to say thank you to
a few people to to leadify for getting
uh the digital download bundle and also
voting for T-Rex I think probably at
this point we can probably call it in
terms of who the winner of who the
official project for us from 2023 mascot
is
uh sorry we're getting uh you know bots
in the chat but it is what it is and the
mods are on it uh and with twenty
thousand dollars donated beating out
hummus and lemon man is T-Rex lemon man
Lemon Lips man never really never really
got was a contender but hummus was
working on it there and uh has raised a
total of eight thousand five hundred and
thirty two dollars so that's not bad so
is it tuberculosis racks is it T-Rex is
it is it Tyrannosaurus Rex it's whatever
you think but it's definitely a racks
related to uh Pteranodon and uh and it
is
uh lemon lemon mayonnaise that sounds
delicious
um and it is the product for awesome
2023's mascot everybody uh we
uh great wall art is has has come in and
I can show you what that looks like now
it looks like this uh it's to be hung on
your wall it uh and it's a it's a I
think that it's very much like this one
over here which is actually falling down
I don't know when that happened but it's
been a mess over here
I've got this resting on two nails so
it's not actually nailed into the wall
because it's art you don't want a nail
art
um R.I.P hummus I know that it was it
was hard fought for the people who
wanted the project for awesome 2023's
mascot to be a word
um and I don't know why my slack isn't
making noise but um
uh I'll try and fix that
um
okay
huh
um and I'd like to to say thank you to
uh this person who just marked himself
as best weekend of the year and said
thank you for the best event of the year
and uh got the digital download bundle
I'd also like to say thank you to Eric
who got the crabulous monthly
subscription Hannah who said watching
the project for awesome while working
equals laughing until you cry and having
concerned co-workers thanks for another
great year and got the digital download
bundle and voted for hummus I gotta say
apology the weirdest thing would be to
have the project for Awesome's mascot
just be
a a word
um
uh
but but it's a harder thing to actually
draw is the is the project for awesome
uh sometimes just a podcast where you
can't really there's not really much of
a video component to it sure but as long
as you can hear it that's all that's all
that matters anyway
humble hummus is simply non-negotiable
we still love you they say mythical
T-Rex can solely survive on hummus I
like this let's let's work out the
that's one thing you need always
is that you need
um
hummus is not just a word this is an
insult look it is just a word though in
the way that we were using it nobody was
talking about hummus the substance
they were talking about hummus the word
I have to eat a little bit of food I'm
very hungry
I'm hungry how much is a state of being
what did I call a podcast I don't know
what I call a podcast
could have been something
Tyrannosaurus Rex can't be named hummus
because he's named Tyrannosaurus Rex
but he can definitely only eat hummus
that's a that's completely on the table
T-Rex is did I save t-rex with the
Pteranodon that was a mistake
that's that's different what are they
called sauropod he's a sauropod geez
um hummus is My Philosophy he's TB racks
this is all fine he could be
Tyrannosaurus Rex and tuberculosis racks
it's a little much to name him
tuberculosis Rex in my opinion feels
heavy
Brennan was on last night uh sorry Percy
we had a great time uh it will be
available you can watch it after the
part theropod theropod not a sauropod
geez
I've lost all dinosaur cred
um Dustin is hosting later today
um I'm not sure how much later I it's
it's at least a couple hours from now
if you listen to the Gregory Brothers
song well from last night they talked
about how Tyrannosaurus Rex only eats
hummus I remember that
so if if anybody has any other
Tyrannosaurus Rex lore to suggest ob-e
beans as well you can also drink Dr
Pepper and eat beans and eat Dr Pepper
baked beans
foreign
he lives in a Lemon Grove
okay
Destin was not already on he'll be on
later today Brenda Lee Mulligan and
Samurai were on last night
um
did it was I cursing I don't remember I
cursed last night when it was late
that's for sure
um but thank you for reminding me that
there are lots of kids watching
um and you haven't missed the Taskmaster
contestant that is also tonight much
later tonight during my shift in the
evening time
my last my last big shift
um Rhett and Link will not be on this
year
John says I'm going to eat a lemon
tonight I'm on Lemon Duty that's great
news
oh Rhett and Link hosted last night
that's that's news to me I did not
realize that I should I've been trying
to send thank yous to people
John's eating lemons tonight it's it's
in the chat it's it's official
uh he Roars hummus
I mean I I feel like John's saying that
so so does that the noise that he makes
or does hummus come out like it's fire
in a dragon
where he goes Roar he's like
I think it's that second one right
because just saying he didn't put
quotation marks he said he Roars hummus
it was with quotations it would be he
Roars
hummus and that's the roar but if he
Roars hummus no quotation marks yeah the
Carl brother is not Rhett and Link
um if he Roars hummus uh with no
quotation marks that's just he's like
shooting hummus like it's fire he's a
fire breathing dragon where it's just
like
it's a little strange because they don't
have hummused racks definitely not seems
very very much like not a a Hummus Place
um but one thing about racks and one
thing that did kind of lead to its
downfall is that it couldn't like pick
it couldn't figure out what it was and
so so it makes sense that like
Tyrannosaurus Rex would be like maybe
we're a Hummus Place now we're gonna do
Greek food it'll be it won't be roast
beef it'll be we have the meats and by
the meats we mean kebab
um
and
it's it's all it's euros you know the
word Euro uh is related to gyroscope
so it's g-y-r-o because it spins that's
why it's called a Euro this is
from the ah it's cool
um
Hank if you want to be uh if you want to
be legit you just have to smash an egg
on your head like Siri and Sam just
saying I do have eggs but I I don't
think that that's but I'll put that in
my next I'll put that in a task balloon
I'm gonna write it out now won't happen
now but it'll happen when it happens
smash an egg on your head
and then in parentheses you have to do a
good job
great
I'll put that in a balloon later
and hopefully I won't get it because
that seems like it would be hard to
clean up
uh have you ever played the waffle game
I have played the waffle game like the
Wordle clone thing yeah it's fun it's
fun I'm not very good at it an egg in
this economy I don't want to mention
this to anybody but like we never had
that problem in Montana like eggs got
more expensive but they like what I was
seeing on social media was like 18
cartons of eggs
but like the eggs are made nearby here
and I guess we just didn't have whatever
that was
um
caused by
um so
John came on earlier today you know
he'll be on later today too
ah
don't need that
I'm trying to figure out the rest of the
schedule
um
so for I'm I'm willing to say
because repeal I don't want people to
miss it Dustin will be on at seven
o'clock
um Montana time
so from seven to nine and then I take
the shift after that and I'll be up
until
probably
midnight or one o'clock doing stuff
um and then we come back for the last
bit
um in the in the morning until noon
o'clock Eastern time when it's all over
John says I want a host like Hank where
I just like eat food
Jill but I'm very hungry right now I
also want chicken
maybe I should like make like get some
I could like make some food
we'll go
not enough
there's enough chips because that was
sort of a lot of Chip eating
um
I would like to add a perk
um right now so last night I agreed to
make 200 of these
they are two inch by two inch
uh
what's it called canvas board
anglerfishes
I made a bunch of them I've been using
them to cover up things so that like uh
confetti doesn't get into
um
my my drinks and my beans
I did I did finish my the beans last
night so uh I have to open up another
can of beans if I want more beans but
they look like this you know they look
like this basically and
um and I got
uh I I put up 200 of them last night and
they sold out in about five minutes so
I'd like to do another hundred of those
and if they sell out in five minutes
they sell out in five minutes uh but
they're gonna be fifty dollars each and
um and then you'll have a little thing I
I the the the the main hangker fish art
that I made uh that's down there right
now and on the wall That's all gone uh
so those sold out immediately
um they're I can't make any more because
the paper doesn't exist anymore uh but I
you know I could probably do something
like that on different paper
um someday I'll have to like I am
legitimately like I do not know what I'm
gonna do for Hank or fish art next year
so
you know that there's like there's
competing interests right it has to like
look good but it can't be something
that's gonna take like
many hours per thing because I have to
make a bunch of them and I can't like
can't be like you know this one is two
thousand dollars
um
uh so it has to be cool it has to be
relatively easy to create but so I don't
know I don't know what I'm gonna make
next year but we'll figure that out
we'll cross that road when we come to it
crunch the carrot it says you got it
love a carrot
laser cut oh no I want to do it myself
so I'm gonna be like a laser cut part
and then like I add to it maybe
anchor fish magnets that's a good idea
anchor fish art has no reason to be
happy
but it has no freaking idea what else to
be okay don't worry what's happening
a whole can of beans before bed poor
Catherine yeah well
that was all basically the same thing
you have not had a vegetable in the past
24 hours I have two maybe
I don't know I had a sandwich it had
lettuce and tomato on it
potato stamps that's a good idea stamps
are fun
surprisingly they do not last as long as
you would think that they they would
um so like like there's lots of good
ideas for like um you know magnets
puzzle stickers but I like this is like
something I want to create myself
um
so we'll see oh the mini ones are out
they're out and they're flying off the
shelves uh people are not taking any
time to to say anything they're just
buying them uh and uh I mean they're
gonna be gone instantaneously
Sarah got one Jay got one apis got one
Sam purple blueberry got one Sam the
snail got one Miranda and murphsko and
Jeremy's who maybe was supposed to be
Jeremy but or germis I don't know it
seems like two things there's a capital
letter and Chloe and skytail and
Anonymous and Anonymous and Ben uh got a
hangovers woo Paola uh got one word he
got one uh Natasha pixie got one Dills
42 got one oh my God this is wild you
guys just will buy some that they just
disappear
blow art stencil Heckler fish that's an
interesting idea I'll put that one on
the list
that's a good idea I like that
no potato stamps somebody said I don't
know why make a giant one and then make
prints of it it's an interesting idea
um I also have and I don't actually know
I should ask before I say this
and it looks like it's done
it looks like it's sold out you guys
but then
well that's strange a bunch of people
then got T-Rex coasters
like all in a row which makes me worried
that they accidentally got T-Rex
coasters when they were trying to get
mini hankler fish
um but they're gone everybody
they're gone that's how I mean
how many small black canvases can I get
from michaels.com
ah how many small black canvases can I
get from michaels.com
um
so they are called it's called canvas
board
black
and then small let's say mini mini
nope yeah there it is that's four by
four two by two
eight pack
Wade
okay two by two eight pack let's do that
and they've got 10 in stock at the store
so I could just go that I know they're
already still sold out I'm looking to
see if I can get others yeah there's
other art stores but that's the one in
my town
uh
uh yeah this is what I want this is the
product I want uh shipped to me and I'll
just push this button
see how high it can go
so there's eight per pack can I get to a
hundred can I do 800 of these
I'm still clicking the button
it's letting me buy it
uh uh
it's gonna be a six hundred dollars but
that's worth it right
so if so I've done 300 so far
there's got to be a point at which we
sell like we can't sell anymore
um
800 seems doable to me in terms of the
work
and can you do it that's a good question
so there's how many Michaels can do and
there's how many I can do
800 I feel like I could do 800.
yeah I could do 800.
definitely
just because you can buy 800 doesn't
mean you should make 800.
I think I can make 800.
yeah I watched RuPaul's Drag Race
uh and and uh rehab addict I can which
is a questionable name for a show now
that I'm thinking about it and I like I
gotta I could Property Brothers
yeah
400 but I already sold 300
Hank you can't do 800. I can't are you
sure Catherine's in here did she think
that I can do 800
she's brought me Curry
love that for me she's like how about
some food that's food
can you do 800
are they gonna be all over the house
how all over the house are they going to
be guys
are you gonna it's a good question uh
let's work out the logistics right
[Music]
what does it take to make them
just a Sharpie it's just a yeah silver
Sharpie in the canvas okay
they don't have to be Catherine has had
some experiences with hankler fish art
you've got some experience with them
taking over the house
what was the worst mom the worst one was
the first Crash Course coin which we did
in the house
and uh and I was packing every single
one of them yeah and there were all
those little pieces there were so many
pieces
they were ever and there were like
staticky so they'd stick to stuff
uh-huh
various ways
because that's his favorite just to find
a find a thing and spread it around you
gotta have family meetings when you're
deciding whether or not you're gonna buy
uh mini canvas boards yeah I mean like I
could make something but I I don't have
like
they don't have a fish
you could have a fish you've invented
the anglerfish
did I
like half of that
yeah I love those
I also love
Curry what's my brand
Pelicans
being over it
[Laughter]
Pelicans
it's a good one you you stole Pelicans
though that's true I don't
I don't have pelicans anymore
we can both have pelicans
uh what's our son doing he's watching
YouTube okay
he's fine YouTube is watching him
um he's eating lunch and watching you
YouTube
okay
so
so this is this is the the price for 800
of them
wait so but you already committed to 300
yeah so I have to buy at least 300. okay
oh I
thought yeah you haven't
no seven but like three of them yeah I
made I made like eight yeah
um
so you're committing to 500 more than
you already have done yep
about 500 total
500 total I might have to charge more
fifty dollars
that's better than so good Pringles
that's true negotiation going on here
you guys she sits back in the chair
folds her arms this is my power stance
yeah this is and then like you just
don't say anything for a while and you
see what they come back with
laughs
everybody's saying coupon I don't know
what that means can I get a Michael's
coupon you guys find me a Michael's
coupon I'll use it
I mean it's not like Michael's is
expensive you guys
like these are very inexpensive thingies
uh coward do 800 there it is there's my
inner voice
that's that's the only one I can hear
it's not going to make any difference to
your life
where's the Michael's coupon what are
you talking about
me anybody's saying coupons but they're
not telling me what the coupon is like I
said there's a promo code thing right
here where is it
daily 23 U.S is a coupon for okay
are you serious if this works
no that saved me 120 bucks
you guys you guys are great
foreign
just reading some okay Catherine draw a
wet
draw a lift
[Laughter]
your wet orange and dry how about I buy
I'll buy 800 yeah yeah and then I'll
save some for and and then like we'll
only sells 500.
yeah maybe you can do the yeah yeah
um unfortunately I did there are some at
the Michaels here if we want to go get
something you can sort of test out see
what you want to make maybe yeah
we can do that during during my break
okay
500 is not a bit much that's 500 500 is
totally doable yeah
I've turned so many anglerfish you guys
I've signed I've signed like tens of
thousands of pages of my book and John's
book yeah
wet or dry draw that hairless cat with
the denim jeans uh I got a Coke in there
I am a wizard uh spelling to drink I got
a Coke right there
besides a Coke no I'm good just Coke no
Ah that's the coke is the energy
yeah not that kind of Coke
what this book I know I pulled that out
this is the this is the the book that
has the giraffe sex picture in it yeah
yeah that that launched our careers
whatever you know where I got that
that's right
oh you could just write those frogs were
doing oh yeah look at them all
night long
get him away from me wink
wink
on coke is the format don't at me but in
typography so you just write don't at me
Catherine
yes there it is
there it is the center screenshot that's
what you used to call thumbnails the
center screenshot that launched
thumbnails
yeah because because he yeah
because that's what it was it just took
the center screenshot and put it as the
lighting is not flattering too yeah
woof it's not better
it's kind of kind of hot right now for
sure
um
it is a beautiful book
and she just found some a photo a photo
album
of what is it our College friendship
yeah
you put it in the house
uh
uh okay well I'm gonna do a Michael's
run and then if you can figure out
something that you feel comfortable
doing a couple hundred of suggest things
yeah one thing I know about Catherine
though is that I'm perfectly comfortable
being like well that was not like the
best one I've ever made
uh and just moving on with it oh
okay
I also want you to I want you to be like
thinking I have to make perfect
everything every time and and then it
becomes worried about it a weight around
your shoulders because you have to
struggle through
okay good for this effort
great
it's
um I haven't figured out how to do a
quick Pelican yet yeah but I I've
actually been thinking about it um but I
have not gotten figure something out I
mean it took me forever to get the quick
hanger fish so what which one roast beef
Furby yeah
sideways on the Shelf
feel it
just looking at it she'll move on Hank
she's over it
I mean like you draw a cat that's cat's
easy Pelican's a little hard but I feel
like there's some there's something
there
but you have to work through it a bunch
maybe figure out the fast Pelican maybe
it's a power cat oh see now you're
thinking too hard
I want to go to Rex
eat your Curry
[Laughter]
you're too hungry yeah you have to bring
this Furby with you though oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah we gotta bring the Furby to
Rex not sure that's your trip mascot we
gotta put them down next to the roast
beef sandwich the biggest roast beef
sandwich they have just everyone where
you go I'd be like oh you know what I
want I want the biggest roast beef
sandwich you have and then be like reach
into my backpack like this big
I don't want it to have eyes but I want
it to be like this big well I know you
show them that but the other side
I wanted to be like this bit and then
[Laughter]
they just leave uh-huh
I'm not this is not
all right
oh
I did something where is it music
I don't have that many times open right
now we have that many tabs open why is
John's what he's reading it from his
book I I heard him say that there he is
found him Jesus great great great great
how many workers do you have open do you
need that many no it's a mess it's
project for awesome I don't need that
many it's very
um you have this whole side over here I
know I haven't been using it I just have
this to show that that but this and like
knowing that
very instructive or feels like yeah it's
like yeah that's what it's like all the
time it really is too many tabs I love
it I need so many tabs uh I have like I
have a guest coming shortly I believe
okay
it wasn't
prumbles
okay thank you
goodbye yeah figure out how to do that
the situation yeah I'm just gonna buy
these and then we're gonna put up
another hundred and we'll see what
happens then we'll I'll have committed
to 400. okay
I mean I want the people to bump the
number up all the time all the time all
the time it's always good to do it
um
okay we're adding our in our uh our next
guest
there is you can shake those to the
fridge please
hello Jessica
Hi
how are you doing
I like that I'm very good thank you
you've been having fun
we have been having a lot of fun
um uh we we were my I my wife was
watching the project for awesome in in
the house I'm in like the backyard
studio and she uh
uh she heard me committing to do a bunch
of work and she said that she came out
and she was like first of all stop
eating so many potato chips here's some
actual food
and then uh and then she uh and then she
was like we need to have a conversation
before you sign up to have my house
covered absolutely covered in craft
supplies for the next six months so it's
good it's good to have a communicating
family
okay it I'm very pleased well I have
gone to quiz you on some queer history
oh I love that I yeah so what's the
what's the hashtag qh 101 is that it
indeed it is
we're gonna find out what you know oh
I I know what you've taught me and
that's all
you're like
it'll be impressive if I know anything
people are so excited to see you I'm
watching the chat just explode so oh hi
everyone hello hi please do play along
uh this is very exciting uh we'll see
who does better shall we okay me or or a
thousand people okay
um yeah
Yeah
question okay ready question one which
queer person famously said be yourself
everyone else is already taken
no well not recall just insane
uh that's yeah if you if you don't love
yourself how in the hell are you gonna
love somebody else uh as RuPaul
um
uh
I do not know the answer to this
question
it's definitely
what
does the chat know the answer
um well I've I my first thought was
uh it has to be after Oscar Wilde but my
first thought was Oscar Wilde
it is Oscar Wilde what that seems so
much more modern than Oscar Wilde to me
but I guess so
yeah that's lovely
yeah it's nice it's good there you go
that is a point for you though that is a
point
okay even though I thought I was wrong
okay the next one might be surprising
okay
which American TV show screened the
first ever
lesbian wedding on TV
and you say it's surprising so it's not
like the Ellen Degeneres Show and it's
not like Will and Grace
yeah let's say friends
yes
because because of Ross's wife
or ex-wife oh my goodness me what is
going on here yeah can you see your name
what do you think
there we go well you gave me a hit the
hint was helpful
I love the idea though that like queer
history this is a really integral part
right we're going to agree friend yeah
friends the the traditionally very
Progressive and not at all homophobic
show
come on thank God
we enjoyed that really
yeah
leaves it for its time but it does not
does not yeah it's got some issues yeah
uh a slightly more serious one
around how many would you say how many
children are being raised by same-sex
couples in the USA
that's a great question I don't know
I'll go with
I'll go with a million
just a big old round number
what I'm blown away that is it like what
is it
a million
you're shockingly good at this
I didn't do any math or anything
uh okay
um we're gonna have to hit me with a
harder one okay
okay uh how many stripes are on the
original rainbow flag
oh well there's one right there
like right there so I have to not look
at it
because that would be cheating
I didn't know this
um
is it six or is it seven
it's I'm gonna say six
okay good he got one wrong it's eight
oh it's eight no oh that's yeah mine has
six though so that wasn't the original
the original
um the original gay pride flag had eight
it was pink red orange yellow green aqua
blue and purple
oh my God I missed the first three or
four I just got aqua blue and purple we
had a we had a drop
oh okay
originally had eight that was pink red
orange yellow green aqua blue and purple
oh my God that's a lot of colors I want
to see it
there's a lot of colors there's a lot of
colors all right follow-up question
what does the color red stand for in the
flag is it number one the Sun
2. life or three the soul
oh they have meanings
yes they've all got meanings
um I guess let's check what's going with
life
I got it I I can't I cannot believe this
what's going on he's a he's a secret
historian oh my goodness yeah
okay it's life the red stands for life
now I want to know about all
absolutely pretty shocked okay
okay let's see hmm
true or false the term girl used to be
gender neutral
well it wouldn't be very interesting if
it was
false
so it's Gotta Be True
it's fair enough yeah it wouldn't be
very interesting if it was false so
until the late 15th century girl
actually just meant child of any gender
um and the the word for a boy was Maiden
child
made in China definitely sounds like the
opposite of a boy
well the the opposite was it was gay
girl
the what was the a woman of a female
child was a gay girl
freaking
okay
hey boy yeah I've heard I've heard
people speak thus
um the this is great I love that we do
have good gender-neutral names for kids
uh we still got we still have those uh
they come in very handy
um in uh in a place where people are a
little bit caught up on gender sometimes
for children uh but you don't know ever
I can't tell uh so it's just kids and
kiddos and children and babies and it's
great
niblings
yeah nibblings is the is the gap that we
have right now where we have we've had
to invent a word or you could say my my
brother's kid was the uh getting around
saying niblings it's the these things
it's the it's if if you if you're
experiencing the gap
yeah I agree that's like and you've also
got a
I don't know that you there there is one
for aunt and uncle either
um but I had somebody recently was like
my my
um my my nephew or my my
son's kid is non-binary and I don't know
what to call them in conversation and uh
and somebody people were like nibblings
and they were like I don't want to do
that like it's just like not like
accepted in the spaces I exist in right
now and and I was like you've already
solved the problem it's your brother's
kid
so I felt like I gave good advice that
day
yes well done
my brother's child yeah
all right
can you give me the year in which don't
ask don't tell was repealed officially
in the United States
I was yeah maybe
I'm gonna say 1998
so the year in which don't ask don't
tell was officially repealed
throughout the United States
are you sure of your answer would you
like to give
the second one
no well I've obviously it's wrong but I
don't I feel like I'm missing something
obvious and I don't know what it is
2011.
oh no
jeez
that that is not that is not what my
brain said that's embarrassing
oh no I thought that that happened much
earlier
pretty much all of queer history for you
yeah
yeah yeah pretty much just like oh oh
good decade or maybe two or even three
earlier God yeah I thought it was I
thought it was like a Clinton thing
yeah
the actual um
well I have to get something
embarrassingly wrong
um
although should we give you we'll give a
good one
um when was the first legal same-sex
marriage
carried out in Massachusetts
oh gosh you'd think I'd
now and see now now I'm getting the eye
twitch because I feel bad about I feel
bad if the extent to which I get this
wrong but it must have been
um
but I don't know
when was it
all of the years I'll just say 2016.
understand
oh
okay so wave okay I see there was that
there was like the times when it was
just state by state for a long time
gotcha yeah because it went back and
forth and yeah
which is actually uh earlier in the UK
well that's the that's the advantage of
having states where we get to be weird
and uh do things piecemeal slowly and
then mess up and have a bunch of
different sets of laws that I'll
disagree with each other
foreign
it's very weird no it's like not common
anywhere there's not a lot of places
where there's like it's like everybody
has two sets of laws
well I must say they've done very
familiaries I I feel like it's okay
I feel like that okay I feel like bad
that I didn't know the stuff about like
more recent history very well but
no I've I've been amazed I think you
have done
you've done very well
um how has uh the oh do you have more
for me or are we did I are we through
would you like would you like a bonus
one oh sure
okay
um
would you like an easy one or a slightly
tougher one
I just lost just do both
unless they have unless there's just
like stiff rewardings of the same one
okay
um easy one which state has the most gay
couples
well it's got to be California just
because it has the most people and also
it seems like a pretty gay place
you'd have the most
uh 138
that's actually less than I would have
thought
yeah it's like 180 000 people so there's
that at any one time right you know no
someone broken up yesterday they might
be getting back together tomorrow they
just went to gather time census was
taken
yeah it's very difficult uh uh uh
accounting with uh with with couples in
general
um maybe complicated at that moment in
time and they just didn't want to write
it down right
like I mean yeah we're a couple but not
like you know like we're gonna say yes
on a Government Census kind of way
more like uh
okay
but which state or territory I'm so
sorry I'm not entirely sure how you
define
all of your places okay
um has the highest number of gay couples
per people
okay
the fact that you said territory makes
me a little confused because I'm like is
it Puerto Rico uh but I'm gonna say uh
uh Vermont
not right
uh it is Washington DC
oh yeah that's that would make sense
that you said territory I forgot about
DC
foreign
which has a 1.9 percent
of all of its capitals
I missed it one point what
1.9 of all of its couples are same-sex
couples
that seems low come on
there's two percent of all couples I'm
not doing this accounting I don't know
who is
wrong I just think that I think that
that's just that uh that's that
I think I think we all need to step up
our game people
get exclusive
start yeah start writing down your
coupledom yeah when the government when
the government asks right up on the form
all of this
yeah
DC that makes sense it's interesting
yeah because I went with Vermont because
it's like uh like a pretty upper class
but small population place which is also
true of DC
yeah the smaller the population I
suppose the much
easier it is
yeah
well apparently the state with the
smallest uh the least gay couples is
North Dakota
does that that makes sense it's also
very small and homogeneous but in the
other direction in terms of how probably
how
much they've moved forward
well they apparently only have 703
gay couples which I feel like
again what if four of them broke
yeah
just checking you're still together uh
Bob and Ted Like right
I feel like I feel like just the chat in
this live stream could double the number
of gay couples in North Dakota
uh if you all if you it could be all of
that number
they could we could have every single
gay North dakotan here today right now
maybe you've got 703 couples
right now
you're very important all of you do you
matter
greatly to this number don't let it dip
under 700. yeah yeah yeah that's when it
really starts to feel weighty uh when
you when you are one of the one of the
703 gay couples in North Dakota
for okay step one be queer step two
don't be single step three move to North
Dakota
this is never break up yeah
no divorce for you yeah yeah so there's
several ways to participate in the
project for awesome you can vote on
videos at projectforawesome.com you can
donate a project for awesome.com donate
you can you can be queer and get married
and move to North Dakota at project for
awesome.com qh101
okay
um
uh so so what what I know that you're
working on the queer history series I've
been pleased to see it come up on my uh
my my shorts feed or wherever it's
coming up
um what else what what are you working
on right now
well we've actually just come back from
Malaysia
uh we spent a month in Malaysia
um so we did a little Vlog series while
we were out there which you can see on
my YouTube channel and we shot a whole
lot of extra content while we're out
there but it was
it was kind of a lot and traveling
um with a toddler as well and we we went
out to kind of introduce them to his
grandmother's culture and to meet the
members of his family that he hasn't had
a chance to meet yet since you know he's
a pandemic baby
and for my wife to get to see her family
and it was just a really wonderful time
we got to celebrate Chinese New Year
while we were out there that was really
lovely so I've got lots of some little
shorts coming out
um just really exciting little things
yeah and of course lots more queer
history 101 to teach fun facts
yeah I loved your your quite quick video
on
um sort of uh homosexuality in the
ancient
uh like ancient Greece times what you
hear about you hear it like you hear
sort of like vaguely oh it's fine to be
gay back in ancient Greece
um but like it was not what we imagined
first of all it's only okay for guys
second more okay if
uh and you know and and third like not
it's not actually like it wasn't
approved of as
you know a marriage and a couple who
would be sort of like running a
household and living the life together
was very much frowned upon for it to be
uh something that was about love and
connection
um so it's like it's so interesting
to to drive a little bit into details
and uh
uh you know
I think really like help people
understand that um
you know human societies are very
complicated and we have been struggling
with these taboos forever
um and like different you know and
different different cultures have had
different taboos and uh and and
that
you know I think that I think that you
know queer people have been kind of uh
it's there aren't that many cultures in
which queer people have been uh sort of
treated with the same like exactly the
same as anybody else so
it's so important that we talk about
our history and it's not just for people
who identify as being lgbtq plus but
also for you know everyone else like
that because not only is it the stuff
that's you know missed in history class
I didn't learn about any of this sitting
in my history class in school
um it's so important that we know also
just how recent many things are and how
that impacts still in our day-to-day
lives like we can't
um expect
to be able to have conversations with
our elders in the way that we can with
younger people when in our community
lived in a world in which they were
illegal
and then we today still through the
Wonders and powers of the internet
communicate with young people who live
in countries where it is still illegal
to be themselves
and it's so important that we're aware
of this and aware of how that is in a
day-to-day experience
yeah
yeah uh and
and just like in being part of and in
the middle of History you know like it's
not as if history was a thing that has
that has ended like we get to sort of
see it how it has progressed and we get
to choose how like the role that we play
in it which is a wild reality
um
how has
how is life as a content creator been
treating you
[Laughter]
good good I think it's
it works very well for me as a disabled
person to be able to create my own
content on my own schedule that which is
something that's great for me because I
do have an amazing audience I talk a lot
about my disabilities and therefore when
I I'm like guys I'm so sorry I've had
terrible jet lag this week or I'm really
struggling because I've been hit with
this lung infection which oh my God got
me before Christmas three months of a
lung infection and
the the power of having built a
community that's based around people who
share a very similar experiences
and I like you know what yeah feel that
I feel like that it's so lovely to be
able to sit in bed
and be like I'm filming today from my
bed
and have all the comments be like well
I'm watching you from bed Jessica so
this is what a coincidence
laughs
so please we're all together
um it's just the absolute the absolute
dreams perfect career for me
that's awesome I'm so happy
um I you know I I struggle on and off
with ulcerative colitis and uh also have
feel the same thing where when it is a
time when I can't do like sort of like
you know do the schedule of a normal
person I'm just so grateful to have this
instead and it seems like both of us
have uh and a lot there's a lot of
overlap but both of us have uh just
really supportive great communities
and uh I don't want to I it feels like
bragging a little bit because to some
extent you get what you put out
um but uh that is the that is the thing
man when you've got a good good group of
people
um so where can we find you all over the
internet
which is admittedly hard to spell so you
can also type in Disco out of the closet
and you can find me on Instagram Tick
Tock and Facebook if you're on Facebook
by also typing Jessica out of the closet
okay if you're not failure you got to
say that about Facebook because who is
anymore
um okay no my my aunts watch that's
right on Facebook
yeah you do yeah you do got to create
for all the places man you you don't
want to miss when you're trying to do
the when trying to do the Lord's work
you don't want to miss people
um uh so our uh clearly I I'm from what
I'm watching our uh our thing is having
a hard time handling both of us but also
uh it's time for me to do a little bit
of a solo shift and get some work done
um so I'm so grateful to you for joining
uh and quizzing me and I'm glad that I
didn't just flunk
that was great
you did amazingly I'm very proud of you
thank you thank you welcome back uh and
congrats on all the cool stuff
I think usually yep that's that's always
very fun when I'm like I'm pretty sure
you'll just disappear and then it just
disappears I don't know the the the sort
of vagaries of the app that we're using
for this where it decides to go to one
frame a second sometimes no idea but it
does seem to help when we mix it up
maybe there if there was some other way
to to maybe if we just like click a
button and change the I don't know
but the moment you change from one to
another it's not in any particular
direction it goes back to normal anyway
uh Jessica is super fantastic and I'm so
happy to count her among my friends and
I'm so glad that she makes the stuff
that she makes for the internet
um in the world
the uh people are asking what's
happening next I have to close that I
don't need that anymore and I have to
oh it's gonna look but I don't know
where I put it
so
um yeah also thinking of Jessica's
interpreter I don't know if anybody
could tell but uh Jessica uh
had a sign language interpreter going
that that whole time which is remarkable
um no
um so that was uh went very smoothly and
very easily
um with with the help
I'm trying
nope also not what I'm looking for I'm
trying to find the schedule but I can't
I I lost it somehow
um will there be more hankler fish yes
so that's what we were talking about
thank you for reminding me uh that's one
of the things that we have to do right
now
um we are I got I did go to Michael's
and I got
800 of them
uh but I'm not gonna do 800. I've
already sold 300 I'm pretty sure correct
me if I'm wrong uh and if I so if I've
done 300 then I you have just missed
Jessica I'm sorry trig
um then I want to do 200 more and I'm
just going to do them now because you're
the ones who are around now and the ones
who feel bad that you haven't gotten
them so Buzz is adding 200 more right
now uh oh yes Jessica has a BSL
interpreter uh for because because
British is different than American
um
and yeah still fifty dollars we're gonna
keep it flat and I'm gonna I'm gonna
make 500 of these things you guys and I
ordered more and maybe Catherine will do
something as well
uh uh and I'm gonna check out I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna check out I'm gonna
pay uh 479 for this I could get next day
shipping on this for only 364 dollars
or I could get standard shipping for
free so I think that might be what I do
and I'm gonna do it now so I don't
forget
and don't read my credit card number in
my glasses or something
in my place order it's done and it's
going to get shipped here
amazing
the people at Michael's are going to be
like what is this man doing don't worry
cool stuff
uh
I have another idea
uh I'm gonna run to Michael's after this
and I'm gonna see if this is gonna work
and I won't tell you about it
but there's gonna be more than fifty
dollars whatever I do is gonna be more
than so this will be the cheapest thing
you can do
um but I'm going to run to Michael's
after this I'm gonna see what I can do
oh I do want one of those felt letter
letter boards I love those those are so
dope I don't know what I'm gonna do with
them but that's that's separate uh the
thing that I'm making available uh and
just made available are these small you
can see how big they are I put them
right against my face they're these
small
um canvas board
Anchor Fish uh that are gonna be fifty
dollars a piece and
we had them we we've done we've we last
night I put 200 on sale and they sold
out like five minutes I just put another
100 on sale and they they sold out in
like five minutes and
so maybe this next 200 will sell it in
five minutes and then I will have sign
up to make 500 of them
but um
and I'm gonna do them to the project for
awesome team who's like why in the world
are you adding things I'm pretty sure
that I can do them fairly quickly and I
will do them as quickly as I can
um everybody is thanking someone named
ruthanne which is awesome if you go to
project for awesome.com right now uh
they're gone they were there for a
second there was a little pickle man and
a little lemon man doing a dance the the
the fact that the project for awesome
has the ability to put like little
dancing things
uh is so good what's 500 not gonna be
enough for what
not going
is five 500 individuals I'm not sure
[Music]
uh
oh goodness gracious me
okay people are getting them I'm gonna
go to see who's getting them
they're flying off the shelves everybody
we sold uh We've sold how many oh my
gosh in the last minute
oh my God they're just they're all
they're all gonna be gone
instantaneously
you can sell them you can buy them so
much faster than I can make them thank
you to BK Bedford and JC and Katie and
Patsy and John and Kelly and Julia and
uh Geo and two anonymouses Emily and
me
caffeinate me ah I was like did you just
make me say something nasty naughty uh
uh Kitty and Lindsay and Ashley and Emma
and Kate and Georgiana and or and and
lisand and nasabri and Dr
No d d Richards is what that says not Dr
Richards
Abel Arun Indie Kanan many
jwl rbj Emily I mean they have to be
gone by now they're going so fast
Grant the Great
I mean Wild
just take my money Hank there's 30 left
there's 30 left but they're not going to
be oh my God
they go so quickly
oh my God they go so quickly
nine sold out
how many people are even in the chat
right now like there's not that many
people on in the live stream I don't
understand how there's enough people
there's there's only 4 000 of you
watching every single one of you wants
one
it goes so quickly
I mean I love that we got we just got to
940 000 raised
so that happened really quick
gone
oh man
I feel I feel like I should do more I'm
not gonna do more of those because I've
agreed to Catherine that I won't
um what's 4 000 Hank
4 000 people is actually a lot no I know
it's a lot but like
200 so so in this shift I've sold 300 of
those and there's 4 000 of you that's
almost 10 percent of the people in the
live stream right now that's what it's
that's why it's not a lot it's
definitely a lot of people but it's not
a lot for being able to sell 350 perks I
love it these are great well I'm
definitely doing those again next year
um because
and people love them
um but I'm going to go to Michael's and
I'm going to see if I can do something
else I'm not sure if I can
um and they'll probably be 100 or 150
dollars
good thing that we do later
anglerfish are so popular
how many of us are there you can look
right below the video on on youtube.com
project for awesome
.com
none of that looks right at project for
awesome.com live it's a very dedicated
audience
uh it is a very good it is a very good
sign so thank you everybody so much for
for donating and being a part of what we
do here
uh I'm sorry I sneezed everybody it's
never normal I'm choosing a realistic
number of Hangover fishing we need to
respect that it's the cut it's the
agreement that we I made with my wife
uh what am I going to now I wanted to go
to something
oh yeah I wanted to go and see how much
longer my shift is it's almost over so I
just did a my three hour shift is almost
over and someone will be coming in to uh
to replace me I think I know who it is
but I'm not gonna say until we find out
because I don't wanna
uh
I don't want to say oh but I would like
to to wish cater a happy 17th birthday
she's throwing a project for awesome
birthday party right now happy birthday
cater and I will be I was right I will
be being uh usurped my position will be
being usurped by project by
um not project my God my brain is not
great right now so we'll see what I what
I get up to after this maybe I could do
some kind of recharge
um uh but yeah let's let's end on a
balloon
might send on a balloon everybody
where's my scissors I I they were they
were
they weren't was in here he kept being
close to them and I kept moving them
around
so that he wouldn't
stab himself
but now now where did I put them
I don't know
is the pencil around I need some way to
get into a balloon that's not sitting on
it with my butt like my son was doing
um
thank you all so much for this extremely
good shift of the project for awesome I
had a great time
and I'm gonna go three two one
no I'm not no I made a tiny hole
where did it go
did anybody see where it went
oh no
where did it go
uh
I don't see it
it's not this one if you did that one
already
um
that one just vanished I really didn't
see did anybody see where it went
it's in my hand
it's animal wonders is coming up next
why are you saying it's in my hand
it wasn't in the balloon I squished the
balloon around
it's not this one I did this one already
it's not this one I did that one already
did it go be like fall under the trash
can
digging through the trash can now that's
where that's where we're at
I'm a trash man
throw trash all over the rig
this is this is terrible
I'll never know what it was
all right we're doing another one I
guess
we're doing it for two we're doing it
for 2.2 million okay let's get there we
just hit it now I'm gonna pop a balloon
this one definitely has something in it
and
oh well I saw that one it flew way in
the freaking air it did eventually come
down though
and it says karaoke is what it says
karaoke from hagai uh who's who
I appreciate your suggestion uh and I
don't have a lot of time to find a
karaoke song so if you can make some
quick karaoke song suggestions we're
gonna we're gonna do some karaoke
foreign
it went up people are like it went up
yeah I'll find it we'll do that one
later
that'll be fine uh we're not doing
All-Star
Taylor Swift something Rick Astley
um as it was jump in the line Mr
Brightside
I don't think I know Mr Brightside well
enough
foreign
All-Star guys I did All-Star yesterday
Wagon Wheel that's cute
oh rock me mama like a wagon wheel
do I know do I I can't you can't do
b52's by yourself
Dolly Parton Don't Stop Believing no
gotta do something that's at least a
little bit in my range
Mamma Mia that's fun let's do Mamma Mia
that's fun
um
uh karaoke and I have to set this
so that it's not doing the thing where
it uh
yeah
yeah I gotta set it so it's not doing
this
the thing where it makes it The Sound go
away all right Mamma Mia bye Abba
karaoke version
is that making noise
yeah it certainly is making noise that's
a little loud actually thank you
I've been cheated by you since I don't
know when
so I made up my mind it must come to an
end
give me now will I ever learn I don't
know how but I suddenly lose control
there's a fire within my soul
Just One Look and I can hear a bell ring
one more look and I forget everything
whoa Mamma Mia
here I go again my mind how can I resist
you Mamma Mia
does it show again my mind just how much
I missed you yes I did brokenhearted new
I know it's just on one side I don't
know why it does that it just does that
did I ever let you go Mamma Mia
now I really know my mind I could never
let you go
I've been angry and sad about things
that you do
I can't count all the times that I've
told you we're through
and when you go when you slam the door I
think you know that you won't be way too
long
you know that I'm not that strong
just one looking I can hear a bell ring
I forget everything
[Music]
mama how can I resist you Mamma Mia
does it show again
[Music]
yes I've been
brokenhearted new since the day we
parted why why did I ever let you go
Mamma Mia
even if I say bye bye leave me now or
never Mamma Mia
it's a game replay
bye bye dogs in me forever
Here I Go Again
well I was trying to fade out
but I can't
really doesn't want me to it just it's
very loud is why I Can't Fade Out
[Music]
all right great great great great great
good job good job I'll go back to the
audio where you can hear me in both your
ears and uh that'll be great I don't
know why it does that
yeah uh well let's we'll let them know
about the bug it sounds like it's just a
bug to me when are you doing concerts
again Hank
no a good old
time all right how about this as a as a
thing to do we could go to Project
frost.com featured if there's a new
video go watch that video and then I'll
come back and it'll be animal wonders
so project for awesome.com
um I spelled it wrong so that's why that
didn't work
uh it's a video from the print from the
Trevor Project do you all want to watch
the video from the Trevor Project I
think that we should do that thank you
uh to everybody behind the scenes and
all the months for
helping I miss the singing sorry Sarah
everybody's always missing something
great though yeah that's just that's the
way that it works
um
we're here
Oh yay hello hi Jesse
Oh Nicole you're cute
yes I can hear you it's everything's
great
wonderful we're joined by sunny here
hi sunny
welcome to hour 30 of the project for
awesome live stream I think that that's
true maybe I made that up but I'm pretty
sure this is hour 30. uh of the Stream
30 hours this well this is hour 30 right
it's like so anyway uh I'm Nicole
Sweeney I uh work at complexly and this
is Jesse from animal wonders who what
are we doing here today Jesse what are
you gonna what are you gonna show us
oh man I'm I'm very excited if you've
joined us on previous years you might
know what to expect if you have not
um it's really fun I get to I I'm Jesse
from animal Winters
um don't know what animal wonders is uh
we're a non-profit organization that
takes in
displaced wildlife and exotic animals a
lot of times pets
um that maybe shouldn't have been pets
like Sunny the toraco
um come to us
um and then they spend the rest of their
life with us and we do educational
programs so I'll be sharing a lot some
some of the animals that we have um on
the stream but I have Perks and I'm here
to to get everyone excited to raise
money for our segment here and I I don't
know Nicole I'm hoping that you can help
me and admits if you could help me like
set a goal and then let's try and get to
it
um
but the perks I have them down in the
corner right now what we're going to do
is some animal paintings and I'm not
gonna paint the animals are going to
paint
and then those paintings are going it's
gonna be fun to watch it's cute
um the animal has fun I think it's lots
of treats and then those become the
perks so
um hopefully those will go up
um
people can start feeding them
um and then I I I'm up for challenges
I'm up for polls I'm up for for anything
um charity this is the second half of
the project for awesome we're raising
funds for really really important
cause it
um that make the world a better place so
I hope you watched the video before
um Trevor Project very important to give
them our support and uh oh there's just
so many good things in the world many
good things
it's so exciting to be here celebrating
all the good things
I'm sorry you need to stop eating my
fingers so who who is Sonny tell me
about Sunny what what is sunny I guess
is who and what is honey
she is a Red Crested Toronto
um that's her apple is a bird that you
would find in Africa there's lots of
different species about 20 I think maybe
a little bit more
um and they live in different regions
all over the country of Africa and the
red crest of Toronto is one of the most
prolific there
um they're pretty horny birds and so
they're really pretty too and some
people some people decided that hey
let's try and Market them as as pets and
then they're breeding them and selling
those pets people find a pretty bird of
a pet and um and they don't realize how
challenging it is to have one of these
guys living in your home
um somebody bought her as a pet I loved
her very much and then
they're
they became allergic to her but allergic
is like a not a strong enough word
um they they were going on like an
oxygen like
oxygen tank and wow the dander and their
feathers inside a hole it's just
it's just
we could take them in and
um she was from Texas she drove them up
from Texas and
dropped him off I never wonders they've
been with us for two years now and they
can live 15 to 20 years uh oh wow
she's about three years old three four
years old so she got her for quite a
while um and she's very very friendly
this is not a typical Toronto normally
they are just very very exciting like
nervous but she just she if I put her
close my face she'll like try and eat
um my nose and like
I like that your face is telling us
exactly what you think of that
um
it's very transparent uh so exciting
though
she's a fun girl she's in blueberries
right now and uh they're mostly for
readers and then they they poop and um
it's not like our poop it's very wet and
you can imagine what color it's going to
be if she's just eating a whole bunch of
blueberries it's all blueberries the
blueberry
wonderful
what a sight to behold
we have so I I want to make time do we
have I just want to confirm do we have a
full hour or do we only have 30 minutes
we have a full hour okay okay
good because I want to make sure we have
time and if I'm lying someone will yell
at me on slack but I'm I'm quite certain
we have a full hour so
great so this this is the canvas that
we're going to be doing the animal
paintings on for the perk
um and I don't have to finish these for
the live stream we could just start them
and get going
um because it does take a little bit of
time but I was hoping that we could get
input on what colors to use this time
since they are the perks
um yeah
I don't know uh how how how quickly do
we want to decide make the decision
about what colors to use oh like 15-20
minutes maybe
um we could do we could do a poll uh
yeah that's 15 20 minutes is enough time
to make that a poll
yeah let's do that and I'll and um
should we care I'll show you what a task
I'm not supposed to be lifting things
these are the choices of colors
um okay we Brooke says that we need five
choices to add to the poll we need five
choices so I feel like I feel like you
gotta pick you gotta pick the combos I
feel like because we have five choices
so you pick like a couple color combos
and we go from there you know because
you have a lot of choices there for
colors all right let's do neon is for a
choice
okay I love it
nice blue green there's another one blue
green is another Choice I'm typing this
is it Kitty time
yeah she's our co-host it was the the
mods in the chat have informed everybody
that our hosts are Jesse human Sonny
toroko and Nicole human uh so yeah she's
decided she's just making sure she's
fulfilling her duties as our third
co-host I love it here I'm gonna look
down don't we're sliding oh there we go
okay
great
um okay so neon we've got blue green
okay
um let's do
um purple and silver
oh wait no I don't have enough silver
sorry purple
and pink
one pink yeah
otherwise we're just gonna end up with
one of them okay yeah yeah you don't
want it to be there we have no control
over where the animals are gonna take
the paint so you gotta be uh
they have to be things that that play
colors that play nicely together yeah uh
nobody wants an animal painting that
looks vaguely reminiscent of poop you
know it's like not really a Vibe so
um okay and then so we need more um
let's do yellow and green
yellow and green
purple and blue is that enough purple
that's yep that's five choices the birth
is listening to this I don't know why I
feel the need to type it at her but I
have done it so the options are for neon
blue green purple and pink yellow green
and purple and blue those are the five
choices we're gonna put a poll up uh on
tiltify so if you go to project for
awesome.com donate uh you can help
decide what colors we're going to be
using for the animal paintings um and
then
you can buy them you can buy the animal
paintings so well then I guess then you
can watch the paintings getting made
um who who are who are the artists Who's
the artist today
um all right so I have one prepared
um
but we could possibly add in a second if
we hit a goal
um
Inky the opossum is going to be our main
star
and then possibly guy in the armadillo
could join in and and do some like
fun playing I have some little like some
flourishes over the top of it love a
good collab
yes so yeah the the blank adding the
uh the paintings are already sold out
actually I'm so I um
how many did we put up is a great
question 25.
okay I found two more canvases and I
also have I also have a whole stash I
don't know if this will work I have a
whole stash of paper plates
oh okay I feel like first of all if
we're adding if we're sneaking two
extras in like the two bonus ones should
be more if they already sold out before
we even started the the next two these
are you missed you missed the special
discounted 25 I actually have no idea
because they sold out uh I don't know
what they sold for but they sold out
before we even started working on them
which is incredible
um chat quickly if you could tell us
whether or not you'd be interested in
buying some paper plate animal art I
feel like they would I feel like that's
a thing people would be interested in
I saw them and I was like why why aren't
we using paper plates to begin with
today the the original 25 or 75 but uh
we're thinking maybe we double it for
the bonus the two extra ones so okay
these are the highly coveted to bonus
canvases uh
this is over it's like harder right now
the chat is the chat is down for paper
play art there's a lot of enthusiasm for
for paper plate very surprising very
exciting we'll we'll do the canvases and
then we will figure out what the the
paper plate situation
uh is we can take stock and figure out
how many paper plates to put up
I mean I I guess it's like how many
how much room do I have and is Inky
still into it
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that
is the more whether or not the artist
still wishes to create
a very serious limiting factor that we
have to contend with here so
artistic engagement is important
um I'm gonna go grab
that feels weird go grab
um I'm gonna go see if Gaia would like
to come and join us this guy is an
armadillo and we can talk about how
weird and cool armadillos are okay
all right yeah go get her
uh the chat is saying that somebody
donated five thousand dollars earlier
today for a dry erase board so they'll
buy anything
um a few years ago uh I sold a cardboard
cutout of one of my co-workers that I
had made
um I had a car I had made a cardboard
cut out of matte like years years
earlier and we still have it
well and truly
um uh yeah they'll buy anything I
actually don't know who ended up with
the Matthew gaydos cardboard cutout but
shout out to that person uh
anyway
oh man all right here's Gaia
ah
hello wait other way other way yep yeah
yeah yeah
she had a really good look at her little
back those are her back feet
yeah just poking out there
detail
um and then so she was she was put
herself back and she was sleeping um so
now she's like oh my God she grabbed me
all right and she moved into defensive
mode for a little moment and then she
usually comes out but look at her little
porn tail
just too much it's too cute it's too
adorable
I love her she has
um she's right tailed so armadillos are
really interesting because
um because they can be left tailed or
right-tailed and
um that depends on you know that
their tail tailoredness
um determines if their tail goes to the
left or the right of their head when
they curl up
so she is right-tailed so it goes to the
right every single time you go to the
right
um and so I just think that's really
fascinating oh she's grabbed my hands
they can give a very strong
oh
it's so cute and it's so cute I mean I'm
sure it probably feels less cute but it
looks very cute
um it's a job with risks okay if I put
my hand in just the wrong spot she'll
grab a hold of it and be like yes and
she just loves she loves dig and pulls
like that's what they do in the wild and
so if she can if she can do it oh it's
at night when I go in there and hang out
with him at night because they're
nocturnal she likes to grab onto the
side of my shoe and try and like rip my
shoe up
it's not ready uh she can't do it I
could easily like he's like they usually
just like lift my foot up but sure you
know she she does the attempt
um
with armadillos because if they grab you
they can actually pull you into their
level the three Bionics
um can pull you into the show and then
close on you and you're stuck there oh
no oh no but um well what an adorable
way to go
it's such a neat
um defense mechanism I love it and she's
kicking over feet right now she's saying
put me down
um I'm gonna let her run around
a little bit but I want to show her off
so we could possibly ferocious so
adorable
and immediately sold out I was going to
tell you that they sold out or I was
gonna I was going to say that the
paintings are the two additional
paintings are live uh but before I could
say it they were sold out so
you know thank you so much thank you so
much everyone for
um you know donating and supporting the
the project for awesome it's such a fun
time I I love saving up and just
splurging it's kind of like second
Christmas for me so it's really fun
right now it looks like blue and green
are winning for the painting colors so
we have a couple more minutes if you
guys want to go and go head over to
projectforawesome.com donate you can
still uh vote and contribute to the the
big decision about what those paintings
are going to be which even though you
can't buy anymore you can watch them get
painted so that's pretty fun uh that's
all an exciting reason to head over to
Project roslyn.com donate uh and get
yourself a digital download bundle or
some hankler fish tattoos or uh uh uh
crabilis or something else
um we also have a featured video which
we can we can go watch a featured video
real quick before do you want to do that
while I set up all the paintings that
sounds like a great idea so a project
for awesome.com uh featured and we can
all go watch featured video together
let's I will I will do it as well so I
can say what it is that we're about to
watch here because I for awesome.com
wait uh yeah okay yes it's the it is the
animal wonders uh project for awesome
video yes that makes sense that's the
one so we all head over to project for
awesome.com and watch this animal
wonders video while Jesse gets the art
setup okay
cool let's do it thanks Nicole
foreign hello we're back from watching
the animal wonders project for awesome
video uh which you can and should vote
for as well
um that's now that we're in the second
half of the project for awesome live
stream uh all all proceeds that we're
raising now are being donated to
Charities that you are voting on and one
of those Charities that you can vote for
is animal wonders and uh donate to their
water project and the visitor center and
all of the really cool and exciting work
that they're doing right now Jesse is
getting the paintings set up so that
um Inky and Gaia can make some beautiful
art uh it looks like Jesse though we've
had a a late upset and purple blue has
one has is is currently in the lead it's
narrow it's tight we got it's 6.99 green
to 769 for blue for purple and blue so
uh
yeah I mean if you are if you had it
then you had and that would just be that
but uh it looks like
purple and blue one out
oh blue green making a surge oh no oh no
it's what's what's gonna oh it's purple
moon winning now it's still winning uh
five dollar spread we got like
I mean at a certain point we just have
to decide that it's done
um um
it takes you already counts now
okay uh I just told Brooke to close it
so whatever it is the
chat is saying purple blue green
um
let everybody win all right artists have
you ever mixed green and purple
yeah art artsy folks in the chat I don't
I don't I I'm not that's not my brand of
artsy I'm I'm not con I don't know I
don't know what would happen if we mix
purple and green I think it's gonna turn
into Brown I I'm not optimistic about
adding about purple and green going
together I also feel like the chance of
it becoming Brown yeah the chat agrees
Brown
um yeah yeah green and purple will make
mud uh
so yeah uh no don't yeah it looks like
purple and blue one narrowly uh an 11th
Hour Surge from purple and blue uh all
right takes it so
pointed out in the chat that it was blue
and green last year so we're you know
we're doing a new year new colors so
I like it I like it and I saw
congratulations to
um
oh I don't have to say your name sorry
congratulations to the people that got I
I said not very good at pronouncing
people's names uh congratulations on
everyone that got a painting this year
and I'm sorry for those that tried and
didn't get one
um
I will I will do my best to try and
schedule in some more paintings
obviously it's very very exciting um
too but
um yeah let's get let's do this I mean
hey Nicole while I'm doing this
yeah do you want to uh take any flesh I
mean you you're welcome if you have
something that you'd like to talk about
but while I do this but let's yeah yes I
will keep an eye on the chat while Jesse
is painting and we can answer a question
so if you guys have any questions for
Jesse uh I will relay those questions
that's that's mainly why I am here
because Jesse cannot be looking at a
computer while also looking at the
animals uh so
um while she's getting all of this set
up right that would be very entertaining
not for me
yes
uh so okay cool okay how many Teresa
wants to know how many animals currently
live at animal wonders
um it changes you know week to week
depending on if we get a new animal
Works away
um we currently have 98 animals if I
don't count
like all of the chickens and pigeons and
cockroaches and rats that we have
uh wow
so
um
okay
for these pants these are this is a
terrible terrible choice
oh uh what the chat wants to know what
brand of paint you're using for the
animal paintings yeah this is
um and so it's edible I mean don't go
around like eating it
um but it's okay if they have to eat a
little bit of it and then it's really
easy to wash off of them and then
um to make the paintings nice and not
just you know Fades I feel it after
they're all dry I put uh spray a layer
of
um well
to make sure they haven't stayed
cool very very cool
um multiple people are asking about this
it's a it's it's just like space random
space stuff it's fabric I made it myself
it's fabric from Joann's
um you too can go buy some cheap fabric
of Joann's uh and have I don't know
space miscellaneous space stuff on your
clothing uh chat is oh Chad is having a
hard time hearing you basically what she
said is that she's using it is like
non-toxic paint that so that that's safe
for the animals uh but then coding she's
coding it after after it is done and dry
she's coating it in polyurethane to make
sure that it stays and sets so
um we are all random space stuff so true
so true uh what any other questions hold
on let me screw oh uh somebody earlier
asked who the new I believe this
question was answered in your video but
I'll we'll repeat it just in case people
missed it who is the newest animal in
your or staying with you at animal
wonders
um so the news actually I'm going to
move this down oh my gosh it grabbed me
um can you hear me all right but I don't
know
it's a little quiet I can hear you but
I'm not sure that the chat can there's
maybe like a levels issue and I don't
know how to solve that so uh
um okay so the
foreign
actually
we don't have a name for him yet he has
one eye and
we were taught if he was somebody's pet
and we were told another Hedgehog poked
his eye
out and
um he's about two years old now so he's
well healed but he was displaced and he
needs a place to live for the rest of
his life so
um he came to live with us and
we needed like a kid-friendly name so
like yeah
so like really and and figure out
um
and I was kind of thinking like Popeye
but that might be a little too on the
nose a little too on the nose do you
want do we want to do a poll to name the
Hedgehog do a tiltify pole we've got a
couple name suggestions winky is coming
from the chat that's adorable
um
winky let's see
name the headshot name the hedgy perk is
also an option Popeye people are people
there are some people who are down for
Popeye
um let's see
pick a name of a cyclops from the Percy
Jackson books uh I you're gonna need to
follow that up with a with an actual
name it's been too long since I've read
them
um what are what are the options there
um Odin people are saying Odin oh I love
that
Winky and Odin are both great both great
suggestions uh also about you being
heard I think it's mostly only a problem
when you turn around so like whenever
you're talking just make sure that
you're facing the the camera
um
Nick Fury yeah now people are yes sure
name naming fictional characters
with one eye uh a lot of great
suggestions oh my gosh hi hanky good
morning
good morning buddy
he's a virginial possum and they are
nocturnal so he was taking a you know
he's in he's in deep sleep mode he's
also really old for an opossum they
lived two to three years
um and he is about two years old now and
so
he's old and had to slow and he just
like sleeping and eating
um which is wonderful and I love it
but sometimes he takes a little bit to
get going some encouragement got some
delicious treats here
snacks that's the best way to be woken
up you know it's just a nice little
trail of snacks
they're gonna wake me up from my nap
um if you notice Inky is missing his
tail he should have like a two foot long
tail here
um but he
um lost his tail he was actually being
rehabbed he was orphaned and him and his
brother were kept too long together in
captivity they should have been released
sooner there was a miscommunication at
the rehabilitation center
um and they got in a fight and he lost
his tail and yeah
um so so yeah he needed a permanent home
and so he came he came to lay down and
wonders and just
half the most spoiled life ever and just
sleep on soft sense and get delicious
food all day
what a good life what a good life
I love that for him
uh there are people are saying that Inky
is so much bigger than they thought that
opossums get
um how does he how does Inky compare to
other opossums size wise
um well often they won't get this old in
the wild and he's also a male so those
are the two factors that try to play
into his eyes he okay hooks big awesome
because he's just got a very poofy area
so um
fat
right behind their eyes and so if
they're overfed they get these big fat
deposits here and it makes them look
over large and he's got this really
skinny little waist
um
it was not on the best diet and he was
very quite overweight when we got him so
he still has a little bit of that
um retains a little bit even though he
is he is a good way now
being more properly fed
um people are asking if he is as soft as
he looks
he looks very soft
no
it's inquiry
um
he's making great Footprints off the
side of the pink
[Laughter]
Focus uh you know it's relatable he's
like no I don't want to go where you
want me to be I want to go just around
the edges of where you want me to be he
said no art today
I know you
I can take my camera
I put a little barrier here
um I don't my camera does not get great
when I move
um but yeah we have this little barrier
set up and uh
I can tell that you don't want me to be
here and that's exactly where I want to
be that's exactly I'm headed directly
for the place that you've tried to Bar
me from being there's literally nothing
there's nothing over there oh listen we
just hear all the treats are here oh he
discovered more treats here we go here
you go but what what
you refused it
sir
foreign
[Music]
join the camera crew uh he's sick of
being with Talent he wants to be behind
the scenes
all right I am going to get some more
desirable treats for him apparently
apparently these little
you know I'll find something okay it's
Jesse so Jesse's going to find for
anybody who couldn't hear Jesse is going
to find some more desirable treats uh to
see if we can induce Inky to get on the
on the canvas to get with the kid with
the program uh Jesse the chat is all
saying though that um this confirms that
Inky is in fact a cat
um uh we love an old man uh definitely a
cat
um yeah you know he's just like
everybody's cats
um you know he's just like me too I also
feel this way I also feel like if you're
telling me to be somewhere I don't want
to be there I don't you want me to be
there no I want to go be somewhere else
that you haven't told me to be uh you're
not the boss of me
so I get it I understand dinky you and
me both
the talent needs better treats that's
correct that's the talent has said these
treats are inadequate they're
insufficient
um
he's demanded
he's demanded better treats
uh the the inspiration cannot be forced
also
um so you know
well I'm learning and you know to say he
has never worked in with Children of
animals all right
and I I laughed everything you laughed
in the face
[Laughter]
yep
yes they're all saying that you have to
pay the artist if uh what he's worth uh
collective bargaining uh
he's demanded a better wage
how about the new wage how's he feeling
about it okay okay
so I got some
doggie treats some like meaty doggy
treats
what was what were the old treats what
what are the two the two different
things
um I mean like this is there's some
peanut butter in it it's a it's a pocket
still think someone donated like
Greenies you just want to be able to put
medicine in these and then time your dog
just eat it oh okay
and so I just cut them into chunks and
he he liked it earlier this morning
you
but
maybe maybe just like the grapes maybe
that's the deal here I also grabbed a
nail work because I do know he likes
nail worms
we're
finding out what his his craft Services
demands are uh
I did see a question
um that said could we talk about some of
the
like
um parasites which is always a fun thing
to talk about
um so parasites that the animals you
know could have
um and I think they're so when when an
animal can spread a disease to humans we
call themselves
um and there are a couple of like
armadillos and birds they can have some
diseases that uh can't pass cubic and
opossums can have some diseases that can
spread to other animals as well I'm
gonna I'm gonna put a pivot
okay unless he's gonna go cult to
recollect
um Inky while we
uh yes there he is there he is back in
business you know he's just gonna have
to watch the artist closely today right
right she's only into the grapes and if
he doesn't get a grapes he's like I I
know I'm done
[Laughter]
it's no substitutes will be accepted
that is fine I'm okay with that um
so
um when we take an animal in we have to
screen them for parasites or diseases
that they have and we have to do
something called quarantine which if you
put them in a space where they
they can't get it spread their anything
that they have any crud that they might
have to other animals
I'll just stay there while their tests
are run and then for a period of time
um
[Laughter]
uh yes the audience the audience says
they're familiar with with quarantine
the yeah the the our ability to
understand these Concepts has has
shifted a little bit so
yes yeah
that was something that I have spent a
lot of time
um trying to educate people about before
but um that is something because of that
has come from from the pandemic is that
people are more aware of these things
um so I think you went through
your course came
if so did our own demos
20 that can carry less with me and
humans
spread leprosy if you think human spread
leprosy to the nine banded armadillo
first
and now they're then it's spread among
them and now they're carriers of it and
it's called cancer disease
so so update on the on the treat
situation I have mealworms living in
dried oatmeal
and Inky has decided that he wants to
eat the dried oatmeal
oh okay okay a plot twist
up
maybe it's like the thing where where
there's like a flavor of something you
know where it's like you you know like
jalapenos like you you don't want the
actual jalapenos you just want something
that jalapeno was on you pick it off
that's what it is he wants like
lingering lingering mealworm flavor
essence
essence of meal horror
uh
all right so
not all armadillos can carry hands to
this disease which is leprosy
um I mean not I mean yeah not all
species can only the nine Bandits and
the way that you would get leprosy from
again armadillos if you age them
um and they were infected so
and if you got infected
99 of humans are actually immune to him
and
um if you do get your book from one
percent that gets it
um then 99 of people can be here
so it's not one celebrity was a scary
thing um but it's not so scary anymore
we've done a lot of research and we've
been able to figure out how to
not make it so scary
um and then Birds they can uh opossums
actually here they can actually carry
diseases that can
um harm birds so in their food if we
if we let um if we just took in an
opossum from the wild
um they they could spread diseases to
dogs
um or our birds and so we have parents
like that and then Birds they can spread
they can spread diseases around too and
then we have to be careful
um
that's what I'm about right now we're
all pretty aware of that
um happening so there's a lot of
different ones today
um there's a lot of different things
that we have to take into consideration
which is why we work with a veterinarian
that knows
what's up and it helps us make sure that
we are testing for these diseases
treating parasites that they find
um funny notes we rescue the beaver and
she had Giardia and so we were treating
her for giardia but she had also she had
such
bad disruption of her gut flora and she
needed to swim three times a day and she
was in the water and she was
splash
and uh I I got some
somehow in my mouth
and I don't know yet
um which not not fun I don't recommend
you drink river water or lake water
especially you know beavers are there uh
Jared is not a fun one luckily you can
treat it
um but still just avoid avoidance
Giardia review just dropped zero out of
ten would not recommend
no yeah
all right
Nicole how are we doing on
goals
oh we didn't set a goal we got we blew
right past the idea of setting a goal
um we were so focused on getting our our
poll going for the um the
the the the paint colors we do only have
about 10 minutes left so
um
yeah this is this is where the paintings
are at oh beautiful what a beautiful
work of art
what an incredible incredible artist
Inky is absolutely stunning absolutely
breathtaking
uh so congratulations to the 27 people
who were able to get this wonderful
wonderful artwork
um do we want to do a poll to name the
Hedgehog we also talked about that yes
or no or we only have about 10 minutes
left so I don't know if we have enough
time so many things to do
um
to uh
find some we don't have enough time to
finish right now but um I will find some
better snacks for him and I'll get him
taking the rest of them
uh uh told me the Hedgehog uh yeah I
mean I really like Winky Winky is a
great one
I'm so glad that I asked
yeah it's a really good suggestion uh
people are also asking if paper plates
are happening
I mean
paper play art is we really want to and
I know I I know how fast the animal
paintings can go
um and so
if do you want it at home do you expect
do you want to I I think if you're if
you are down to to babysit the artists
uh I think
I think that we can um I think yeah I
think it's a good idea I think we should
go ahead and do paper plates how many
paper plates we got
uh
oh I'm present oh no there you are
you're bad you're back okay
okay
um I I mean I have a lot so so
I I do not I mean I don't have a hundred
here
how many do I have one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
Inky's drinking the armadillos water
which is okay up here
um
20 here
okay
well we can do 20 paper plates you're
not gonna get to see them made uh but
it's it's more or less the same process
uh as you've witnessed already
and uh yeah so thank you thank you for
people saying nice things to me in the
chat
um so 20 paper plates I don't know do we
want to put them for the same we put
them up for the same as the canvases I
mean I feel like I realize the canvases
are better but also they went so fast
the canvases went so fast that uh
there's more there's more that weren't
in a package uh I mean I want to raise
as much as we possibly can so
I mean I can I can get more what what
what should we put up how much should we
put up 50
50 plates for 50 bucks
and I'm going to paint on the back side
of them I think oh yeah yeah
yeah
for 50 bucks okay all right
they said 20 will go in as many seconds
50 they're yeah they're everyone's
they're going to sell out so quickly uh
you can put a paper plate in a frame
people that's true exactly that's the
thing like the whole the whole deal is
that an animal painted this art for you
you can figure out how to display it but
it's very cool
art made by yeah we don't we don't have
these available this is just you know
this happened on on project for awesome
2023 and the combo we don't ever have
this combo available so it's just it's
special just just for now and for you
that are joining us so
um yeah if you really wanted to get one
and you've missed out the last couple
years now's your chance
please guide it again this is yes sky is
back it's got the the ephemeral quality
that uh everyone loves in good p4a merch
uh so now is the time now is the time to
get to get your hands on some beautiful
um animal art
paper you know paper plate is unique too
anybody can have art that's on a canvas
um but you
can be one of the 50 lucky people that
get art on a unique and original canvas
and
there will be essence of mealworm
YouTube
can have a paper plate featuring
gorgeous animal art and most importantly
the highly coveted essence of mealworm
act now people project for awesome.com
donate
they're gonna go fast
all right I'm I'm gonna get sunny again
she's been begging for some more of
these um blueberries
those that have been watching me where
did I put my blueberries
oh
chat did anyone see where Jesse left the
blueberries I surely didn't um the chats
are thinking the mods which yes thank
you very much
oh thank you
tiltify is pretty close to oops all
nines so let's go uh we've got three
minutes until our next guest joins us
um so
last call last call to
to help us raise a little bit more money
here in hour 30 of the project for
awesome live stream
ing
here she's back
um go vote for videos we you know but
you can vote as many times as you want
for I guess for as many videos as you
want
um
watch watch there's so many Charities
that
um are so deserving and our hat is in
the range
um if you would like to help us out
we're going to try and build a visitor
center so we can share the animals in
more ways on Frozen again
no you're not you're good oh okay okay
um
and uh
sorry share them in more ways and do
more education and show appreciation for
the animals and then also just
give more of these displays they're all
the they're all the Misfits like I love
it I love every unlock I walk in and
every one of them is a misfit and
um I love it so much uh so if you would
you can vote for any wonders but then
check out all the other chairs and books
in as well donate have fun we have
another day of this
um I'm out of blueberries we're out of
time we're out of time we're out of
blueberries we're out of time that's it
that's you know the old saying we're out
of blueberries the
classic classic way I'm still telling
people you gotta go uh I'm not a
blueberries yourself
uh thank you guys for hanging out with
us
sorry
oh my god wow
that happens
you're watching opossum and then all of
a sudden I'm on screen yeah just a chill
bird being fed the blueberries should be
and now these three weirdos are here
hello
ourselves for those that might not know
who we are
we are uh drafty we're a YouTube channel
where we can take your dumb ideas and
make even dumb
that's what we do oh there's an animal
see we got we got some animal content
for you still good okay here's a
transition away from cool animals my cat
doesn't know how to do art like that
possum did unfortunately but she does
know how to get in the way of me when
I'm doing art
naturally so that has to be worth
something we we literally were like down
to the wire Tech
problems I'm so amazed that we're all
here it also wasn't working
I had to like leave and like restart and
like in like the last 30 seconds it's
what we bring to the table anyway anyway
we're excited to be here add a little
extra suspense to it you know got it
yeah
it's really good to be here we're glad
we can help support a little bit of
Charities yes yeah thanks so much so
much and take look at all this look at
all this money you've already raised
holy smokes many so many money
we did say that our goal coming in was
to double the amount raised yeah easy so
I think if we could just get another 2.2
mil yeah a cool 2.2 mil in the next hour
that would actually look really good
yeah we would look really incredible if
yeah you were able to do that yeah so
you know that's sort of the most
important
uh thing to focus on here
making us look good is the most
important thing yeah yeah
um do we do should we do some drawings
that would be awesome we're we're here
in fact to draw your suggestions for the
next hour uh whatever you want us to
draw and chat you can let us know we're
gonna draw we're gonna talk I'll be
looking because for some reason I'm not
drawing
just
just separate from that I'm just glad
you're here I'm glad I'm here too yeah
I'm sorry the setup's weird but you know
what it'll be fun
uh Nathan do you want to try sharing
your screen and and starting us off
yeah I I I'm gonna I'm gonna figure out
how to do that there's a little button
at the bottom looks like two monitors
kissing you click that one
and then you should be able to do it
through there
I need to hold on it might it might kick
me out of the call when I do this oh no
what what are you talking about what are
you doing I have to change the security
settings to allow Chrome to access my
screen
I'll be right back no it'll work I just
have to we bring a lot to the table and
he's an amazing
here I go see you in a sec
we can't do anything we can't do
anything without just being full silly
we're actually uh potentially trash
yeah
should I should I draw you should draw
why don't I just like start us off so
that
something is happening and we don't look
like fools but we that's what we do
okay so I should be able to do this
I don't know what what they're seeing
hopefully they're seeing the right thing
and they're seeing your screen and then
me at equal size as it should be
oh there we go there we go hey oh
Nathan's back I'm back
um okay chat what should I draw let's
get us started on a good I'm just going
Nathan real quick we need a mug are we
gonna get a quickie mug
oh yeah we should get like a like a
droppy mug we we draw a mug at the
beginning of every stream to get us in
the in the right mood it's kind of um so
I'm gonna do a mug that's this will be a
mug making the face of of one who has
donated to charity oh yeah
you know that feeling when you just
donated to charity
and you should all know in the chat
hopefully a lot of you
would like to see it represented
visually in the form of a mug please
when you donate
um
double the amount that's already there
yeah when this is the face you'll make
when we raise 2.2 million dollars yeah
in one hour
did you know that we have some posters
up for this event signed by us oh yeah I
actually forgot about that
I didn't tell them more Karina yeah
they're at
projectawesome.com donate
the posters that we signed you should
get one yeah signed by our own hand with
real Sharpie we touched those posters
yeah
all of us
you could have something that we all
touched
the greatest gift of all
maybe you can extract some drawing power
from them no guarantees no guarantees
so like a big sort of yeah the mugs when
you donate to charity
yeah the the feeling you get the
upwelling of emotion knowing that you're
doing something to like help oh it helps
for sure it upwells yeah
maybe there's like a like a big tear
I feel like I'm freaking doing like
there's a lot of people not doing
nothing I'm doing something you're doing
so much
oh it's just sort of a face like um you
know I'm happy that I chose instead of
inaction I chose action
I chose to do something good yeah
a fun thing about uh enjoying the Stream
with
so much progress already made is you all
already have a bunch of inside jokes
yeah references and so you okay you can
make us draw those things yeah you won't
know what what you're talking about yeah
and then you can laugh when we don't
know when we don't know because we're so
dumb
yeah uh uh oh the little hands really
add a lot Jacob that's that's helping
you think yeah absolutely
absolutely oh yeah yeah because I'll
draw it right after this yeah Lemon Lips
I see Lemon Lips no hips yeah I saw a
lot of Lemon Lips no hits yeah
and I'm seeing a lot of hummus as well
I mean demands Lemon Lips I'm pretty
sure I know what hummus is
yeah but not in this context yeah that's
a tasty it's a tasty dip
tasty dip no hips yeah hips no hips I've
often seen a lot of T-Rex
Tyrannosaurus Rex
Tyrannosaurus Rex yeah maybe that's a
Nathan yeah I would I'll draw that
if I if I Google these terms will
anything from the stream come up have
you have you already yeah good on these
things
like if I just Google Tyrannosaurus Rex
we got Tyrannosaurus Rex we got we got
it all today you all got a doc for the
Lord
foreign
[Laughter]
I'm going lemon with lips
yeah
interpretation I don't know if the lips
are supposed to be lemons
or it's sort of like the Sensation that
happens to your lips when you when you
suck on a lemon
yeah I got some Lemon Lips that's
difficult to
um draw The Sensation that happens to
your lips it would probably just be like
a person puckering because it's very
sour but I I am enjoying this
a lot
oh
okay oh beautiful who is she everyone's
talking about lemon's lips but what
about lemon's eye I like that lemon's
beautiful eye yeah what about lemon's
two beautiful eyes oh yeah it's sort of
a
yeah abstract
[Music]
she's feel like I've seen this in a
museum
I think Picasso like tried to do this
yeah he was like I can't he it's like I
can't yet I'm not good enough I'll have
to wait until
[Laughter]
okay and then I think maybe like the
hummus will get in here too yeah
okay I'm reading through the Lord Doc
and some of this okay
do you have any like cool info you can
yeah
oh there's a search feature
I misspelled it
maybe that's his name
when I'm trying to catch the bus that's
what I scream let me off let me on
please when you're in France and you're
trying to catch the bus
okay Hank ran a Poland tiltify to decide
the mascot for 2023. the options were
Lemon Lips hummus or T-rex despite
Valiant efforts on behalf of hummus
T-Rex was deemed Victorious is Lemon
Lips just like the the underdog yeah
Lemon Lips is not the this is not the
mascot you're telling us this is just
the people's the people's favorite the
people's Champion even though it didn't
win the people's vote foreign
why don't you love Lemon Lips
I can tell you right now if it had been
if it had been our stream if it had been
our turf
women lips would have been it
a little representation of lemon yeah
so they weren't thinking about it I
don't think it was a fair
election
the voters were missing important
information
so T-Rex is the mascot hummus was the
people choice and Lemon Lips is nobody
lemon lemon
lens is just living their best like you
know in the end
Lemon Lips is eating the hummus
so yeah yeah this was for the best
yeah we gotta we gotta like rally
together to bring Lemon Lips into public
Consciousness like they deserve
Jacob can you label the hummus with
hummus yeah yeah
okay
Lemon Lips refers to what happens when
hand crunches lemons in Winter no I
think this is Lemon Lips This is lemon I
don't think this is Lemon Lips
the thing is language is constantly
changing and evolving so maybe at one
point that's what Lemon Lips referred to
but I'm pretty sure it's this now yeah
it's this we've been streaming for like
13 minutes and we're already co-opting
all of the lore yeah our Lord now our
city now
yeah I mean go check go check the lore
dock this is it changed to this
uh this is Lemon Lips do you all like it
I think it's for the best I think
they're beautiful
yeah I think they're beautiful
how could you not you can get a taste of
those Lemon Lips come on
and we keep we the donations are just
flowing in from this so I think we're
well on our way to doubling the yeah
it can't it can't not
[Laughter]
thank you all so much for your donations
this is incredible generosity on display
thank you let's see if I share it this
time
it has my
okay choose what to share
you can do it Nathan
choose a window
program
yep yeah there it is hey
[Music]
[Applause]
great great all right so I'm drawing
Tyrannosaurus Rex
yeah yeah you are you are drawing T-Rex
I know what T-Rex looks like but you oh
you may not you can you describe it to
me can you give me something no I want
you to I want you to draw the T-Rex that
lives in your mind okay because it's
it's probably just gonna be a t-rex with
some like extra stuff yeah I don't I
don't know what like racks what are the
Rocks like of ribs like this well you
know lyrics that loves eating ribs
there's a lot of things that could be
considered racks you've got like your
SUV and you put the rack on top to put
like your bikes and your skis on it yeah
it's like that you just put the rack on
the T-Rex to hold your skis
[Music]
it's one option that's sort of a
s yeah I know you don't like that I I'm
here for donations not Sports
not uh outdoor activities I'm I'm an
indoor I'm doing this indoors
but
I mean maybe you can have some skis well
you know what else has racks
the oven the oven for bacon again
he's cooking a rack of ribs on the oven
rack yeah you do it's a cool Chef this
is a cool this is like his his
um cooking show and he has a huge Rack
in his oven and he and he does it off
the ribs
they like the Flintstone ribs yeah
I do a lot of oh go ahead Corina oh I
was just gonna say uh if you couldn't
tell by my interesting camera angle
compared to our usual I am not set up to
draw but if you would like I can draw
and then send it to one of the boys to
show oh nice you just can't watch me
draw I'm so sorry and what were you
gonna say Jacob
I was just gonna say that um a lot of
people in the chat are saying that Rax
is is an Eatery it's a food place
um I I don't think that's right
I disagree I'm sort of on the right
track then with the food yeah yeah
they're changing that one too
okay
Karina's tablet just like
moving to cover the camera
oh I'm trying not to I'm sorry
[Laughter]
I'm sorry should we get something for
Karina to draw like right now I can draw
oh sure Lemon Lips
you want to do a Lemon Lips yeah okay
do you want me to draw hot Lemon Lips so
that everyone loves Lemon Lips yeah
everyone already loves Lemon Lips but
yeah everyone can love Lemon Lips even
more
yeah you tell me chat is that what
you're into tonight
will you donate if I go all out with
lemon lips
oh gosh she sold out of posters already
wow
oh yeah hey go go us thanks for buying
everyone Thanks for donating
laughs
rip the posters
okay I'm seeing a lot of people are into
hot Lemon Lips really
really they're saying it
okay I also saw some people who were
asking um what who who are we which is a
fair question that's a loaded question
uh we are drawfee we're a YouTube
channel where we draw we do art
challenges and we do banter sort of like
an art podcast comedy improvised YouTube
it's it's like what we're doing enough
words yeah but it's all the time it's
just us all the time we never stop yeah
we never stop
so that's what it is you should check it
out it's fun yeah if you're if you're
enjoying this even a little bit yeah uh
you might like what we do you could even
start if you're here because of uh
because of Hank he was actually on an
episode yeah animals
oh that's true that's a great episode
too yeah
highly recommend that one you'll get to
hear Hank really uh really get upset by
some things that we produce
is the title of that episode I believe
[Laughter]
but yeah and if you don't like us well
hang in there buddy bro it's only going
to be you know it won't be 40 minutes so
we'll be out of your hair really soon
I'm sorry yeah I just want to make sure
we want to make sure the nation
[Laughter]
is important to me
laughs
but also if you um are thinking about
if you feel like you can only do one and
it's like either check out our Channel
or donate to charity you should
definitely donate to charity oh sorry
yeah sorry
yeah you should yeah yeah for sure
[Laughter]
where is Julia Julia is not here she had
some some stuff to do today so she's not
even at home yeah she's not even in this
building she's on her own Journey yeah
she's on her own Journey doing her own
thing
we'll have to do
Nathan those ribs look good thank you
they look like cartoon ribs I mean they
are cartoon ribs you tell me that's not
a photograph I'm telling you that's not
a photograph that's a cartoon rib and I
want to eat it I want to be in a cartoon
and eat those ribs
because cartoon food tastes better than
real food everyone knows this
yeah
certainly looks like it would
oh does he have like pecs I just noticed
his packs yeah he's got he's got racks
he's got Rags yes yeah
he looks sporty he looks like he maybe
goes skiing
maybe but that's not what he's doing
right now he's he's chaffing it up he's
got his little apron on he's just
wearing an apron
wow just for me
yeah he's looking at those ribs like you
like you like that
like you can see
I bet you do which racks you looking at
yeah whose racks which racks oh those
racks which racks my ribs are up here
[Laughter]
I like this guy Nathan if there was a
rib restaurant with this as a mascot I
would eat there every day until I died
whoa yeah I mean there's a place called
Dinosaur Barbecue they're really missing
out if they're not you know if they
don't have like a a hot T-Rex as their
mascot I don't know what their mascot is
but
family friendly
so let's let's be family friendly I
think I'm being family friendly I'm just
yeah I'm just saying so we know yeah
yeah yeah yes absolutely I want to make
sure we know so we don't say anything
unfamily friendly that's you that's good
to know we are a friend to families
we're friends and families families love
us
I've been told by many a family
some families statistically must enjoy
yes there's a non-zero chance that a
family
loves us
yeah yeah you can't prove it wrong
chat
yeah we'll be good and nice we're always
good and nice yeah but we'll be I don't
don't I just don't go to our Channel and
check that yeah just take our word for
it
[Laughter]
this is just like it's like Tony the
Tiger of ribs
yeah that's sort of yeah he's he's the
Tony the Tiger of ribs
and the mascot of the stream and I drew
him exactly
correct Karina is this how close did I
get
um not at all well you're pretty you're
like 50 close T-Rex is a T-Rex wearing
business attire
you're like a weekend T-Rex yeah this is
you can wear business attire other I
could give him a tie yeah okay it's also
uh
you know if you just like say not the
time with the apron and nothing else
he's business casual yeah
yeah dude
I feel like I've gotten better at
drawing packs since knowing you Karina I
love that for you I'm so glad and our
friendship is one that I cherish
all right there he is Nathan this is
great
I love this you've done a wonderful job
thank you
shall I pass it back to you yeah pass it
back to me and then like you know at the
end we can get Karina's drawing and
reveal that yeah okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna spend a while on this then
yeah do you if does that sound good
Karina yeah okay
again sorry I can't screen share but
you know what maybe it's for the best
I can't see the journey I'm going on
over here this is for the best just like
lemon lip says yeah just like just like
11 words
in
got it you got it I got it okay what
should I draw yeah what other things
what other things chat
what other things are there
is there anything else
in a sundress
um
crabulous I'm seeing lots of crabulous
[Laughter]
um I can draw crabilis
wow
I mean I I'm pretty sure
I know what crabulous is yeah I mean I
I'm from Maryland and you've hung out
with me so I'm pretty sure that's all
you need to know that's all you need
yeah
so I just Googled crab and it said
Google wants to use my current location
yeah yeah
you get to look at the crabs but the
crabs get to look at you too yeah you
want to see a crab well you better open
the door when it gets here the crab is
on its way to your location I see a lot
of people saying Bean pickle as well I
do I do see a lot of Bean
Bean yeah and I'm gonna do fabulous
those are just shapes that you like to
draw
a bean and a pickle that's very true
I feel like you could break down a lot
of your drawings into beans and pickles
but what about crabilis what about
crabilis
crabs are like
kind of hard to draw actually yeah but
is crabulous hard to draw yeah that's
the I think only you can answer that did
I put my desk crab
you got a desk crab oh yeah there it is
of course I do oh yeah
yeah
it's got little crab abs
did you get your crab breath
they just yeah I got crab I got crab
breath thank you it's like a
never-ending
train of donations y'all wow y'all are
doing it
so cool shout out to you
yeah good job
I really think okay so when I hear
crabulous I think about a crab like a
space crab
from another world who has come to
conquer
us
and I think a space crab would maybe
have like a like a man's face
yeah yeah
because it's more advanced it's a more
advanced crab yeah in space it's the
reverse of Earth instead of everything
uh go-to crab
go to everything okay grab go to
everything exactly
exactly
okay because it's just it's just Thanos
so it's not Thanos this is crabulos
okay
I am crap you lose
everything in perfect crab balance
the balance I just I just add crab to
popular expressions
another space fairing conquerors
uh have used
it's just something I heard it's just
something I heard
but I feel like he uses it like too
frequently he's like I'm going to crab
you all and they're like I don't know
what that means exactly yeah every time
you use it it's in a different context
and I'm not picking up you all must crab
immediately or face crab what do you
mean what are you saying to me
it's a simple Choice crab or crab
crab will be crabbed
you have crab seconds to comply
all right let's get some nice chin
action
do we think
so I know I definitely want stalk eyes
yeah
but do I also want human eyes
I think let's see how we feel after the
stock guys yeah okay now now this is an
ojama
[Music]
yeah you're not wrong when you put stock
eyes on a man's face it becomes an ojama
so
I think maybe I will go with some man
eyes too so that I can have an angry
brow
yeah you can just give both wait could
you do Angry brow no eyes
the brow indicates his his mood but
there aren't any eyes underneath
excuse me my eyes are up here my brow is
down here but but my eyes are up here
yeah
[Laughter]
you're gonna have to visualize no a
shadow oh yeah sort of an all my
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh no
gotta close your lines everyone it's
important to close your lines
that's a art tip plus crabs extra
I don't know what that means crab crab
crab truck
crab crab crab grab or else crab like
it's getting worse yeah crab Beyond
what I'm crying
I'm cravulus what are you saying
I don't think I could be any
more crab crab
the police are coming for me
too crab that Google promised is here
[Music]
the crab is arriving
now it kind of looks like he's got a
crab on his head that's like giving him
a hug
no
or he's coming out of a crab's mouth
this is the crab I know yeah I know I
don't know
I'm just saying what it looks like I
don't know what else to tell you
I don't know what else to grab you
[Laughter]
nice to crab your acquaintance
all right we got to get some claws in
here what time is it 6 30
. we're doing great
yeah I'm just flying by and the
donations they just keep coming wow
don't stop coming
I don't even see that where do you even
see the donations
you have to look on the um
on the actual YouTube stream it just
keeps showing up
keep showing them I don't actually have
a playing
wow oh no my cat's Foods just dispensed
so a cat is about to come in here and
start screaming at me
anymore
I don't know that I'm doing so fast
cats do not understand the concept no
cats don't know about the world's
problems
Jacob this is a good design
thank you this guy this guy is he shows
up everyone's paying attention to him
for sure yeah
even though he's just saying a lot of
nonsense yeah
I'm trying to listen to her or uh for us
on the stream we say a lot everyone has
to pay attention to us and we're saying
a lot of nonsense
and everyone's just trying their best to
have a good time yeah regardless okay I
don't think he means us any harm maybe
he does but he's
and what's he gonna do he's just a crab
with a man's face
oh he's got little guy legs
yeah he's coming
that's him coming to your location he's
coming to your location right now if
you're watching this
[Laughter]
because you only have as long as it
takes him to get there but he's not very
fast he's not very fast but he's
determined so yeah but he will not stop
when it follows yeah
yeah like crabs
oh I love that movie crabs
when he's got those other legs but those
are those don't do anything
well if he sucks in his his human legs
then he can skitter around on us
[Laughter]
except for going forward and backwards
and those legs are
for yeah exactly yeah
uh okay I mean I think I'm I think I'm
done
fabulous right this is definitely
fabulous
I'll beware
I'll be crab
yeah
crab out
I'm gonna stop sharing we can get some
more Nathan drawings yeah
yeah oh yeah you can also see the
donations at
project for awesome.com as well show us
the uh the donations the progress
[Music]
yeah again amazing oh I see
oh here's my let me go feed my cat real
quick
you can also see Bean pickle it looks
like
it's like lemon lips and bean pickle are
hanging out on project for awesome.com
oh
I just looked at the lower doc I'm
almost done with my guy
you're you're drawing Lemon Lips again
yeah
should I draw some some Bean pickle
fan art
yeah show me Bean pickle okay
because we only sort of he's sort of a
mysterious figure sort of thing
yeah you should probably do that before
I just start drawing yeah probably
probably want to see what I'm doing
don't you
okay so he's sort of like
he's sort of like a like doing like a
Bigfoot almost like we're we're looking
at him from
behind and he's got like he's got this
kind of a nose I guess that's a bean I
guess he's got a bean for a nose oh and
he's like
foreign
oh he looks like
uh
chowder
oh canuckles
from Flapjack there we go there we go we
got
yeah
please please don't make fun of me for
not knowing that
I guess I made it I made him look more
intense than he looks on the oh he's got
he's got these thick eyebrows
and uh does he have a mouth you don't
see it now look like he does kind of
look like Plankton it wait a nodes
this isn't for sure this is definitely
him
this this is one I I accidentally saw I
cheated hey here I am well then you get
to do like real fan art yeah this is fan
art
and then he's got it I was just like
sitting here talking for a while before
I realized that I was on standby
what did you talk about yeah what did
you say yeah I sat down and I was like I
was like oh is this Bean pickle and then
I was like listening to you guys talk
and then I was like Oh Captain canuckles
and then I was like don't worry Karina
you you knew it even if you didn't know
the name and then no one was responding
and I was like I don't think I'm on
I I appreciate it now
I was supporting you even if you didn't
know yeah
I'd stand by
leaving this pose does he have this is a
good pose I'm clear unclear yeah he's
he's getting ready he's getting powered
up Jacob
you can hear me right I'm here I can I
can but it'd be
don't don't do that no if you ignore me
people will stop donating to charity no
that's true
he's just gonna be
oh no
he's just covered in beans must he be
oh
that's just what I'm seeing you know
what you're seeing him is he in your
room
yeah he's here
wait Bean pickle didn't come to your
guys's Apartments too for the streets
in mine before the stream I don't think
that's supposed to happen
all right I mean well I don't
I don't know what to I don't know what
to tell you
we've been hanging out well that's cool
I guess he won't show me his friend
oh let me see
[Laughter]
please kitten show me your friend
color a lemon lip size I like that green
that makes sense yeah
or my keyboard clacks
you clack him are you quacking I'm on
AOL instant messenger over here I'm
chatting on the side uh oh dude what's
your screen name
add me add me
I mean I've I've told this story before
but my original screen name was Andrew's
cool89.
which I think was maybe one of the
coolest screen names ever concocted yeah
it kind of gives me the vibe that Andrew
is cool
cool
Andrew no Andrews Andrew's cool I'm
sorry Andrews is cool no no Andrew's
cool
89.
don't look at me
I'm looking
why are you all watching me everyone
stop watching me
turn off the stream
he's blowing it
we just we just end the stream during
our album no you never get invited back
again
[Laughter]
Nathan this is a vile image I just want
you to know that
mean don't be a hater Jacob
so I've got some uh some pretty hype
news to tell you right here yeah I've
been chatting in the back channels here
and apparently we're gonna offer some
prints of some of these drawings
um it's gonna be Lemon Lips T-Rex and
crabulous
and there's going to be 30 of of each of
them
whoa and they're gonna they're gonna be
up on the site
like like right now apparently oh wow
so that's that's pretty cool right
you can have these if you want to be in
your home
and you can pass them on to Generations
to come
I see Hank in the chat says Bean pickle
does not taste beautiful
have you tried
is that is did you
yeah did you eat Bean pickle Hank you're
not supposed to do that yeah I don't
think that's allowed
Hank you got to tell us right now if you
ate Bean pickle
it's best to your crime because we need
to report you to the authorities yeah
the crabs want to know your location
[Laughter]
crabulous is coming
laughs
Karina how's your secret drawing going
I'm just about done what's his
catchphrase again
his catchphrase is um I've already
forgotten this is for the best this is
for the best
uh so yeah this is this is being pickle
who is being
just just charging up
yeah what's he about to do we don't I
mean we have to double the donation
number and we're gonna find out
yeah I think his his progress bar his
like meter here
it's just like it's going you know
okay so once we hit four million 400
000 in the next yeah 15 minutes yeah
easy yeah okay I will send over my Lemon
Lips and we're gonna hit that goal yeah
okay do you want to just send me the uh
the clip file uh oh God don't delete it
crop it yes
frantically typing
also clip file or pinch
uh if you send me the clip file I can
share it easier probably okay because I
can open it in my should I okay so I'm
gonna stop I'm gonna stop sharing
so that Jacob can share yeah go ahead
you stop sharing
I'm done
sent it to you
file obtained
file file opening oh my God
excited
to see this one this is
I'm sharing the screen now I'm
depositing Lemon Lips into all of your
computers
arriving oh yeah
[Laughter]
can we get big Lemon Lips on the screen
please
everyone lips expand
living lips is saying my hummus this is
for the best it's filters hummus I
forgot to call the color in the hummus
on the shirt I'm a Fool Jacob colored in
for me oh yeah one second I got this
yeah color pick it
yeah yeah
let's get the darker color
this is lemon stain this is Lemon Lips
This is they thank you thank you Lemon
Lips has grown up Lemon Lips is an adult
now yeah Eden hummus and in their
t-shirt
oh cat loves it thank you Chad they love
Lemon Lips they're so excited
unanimously
all in favor
wow no one is upset is what is my
favorite part we're scared
this is so good
oh my God thank you I'm glad I'm glad I
was able
yeah the eyes
again everyone's coming out let's take a
moment
the eyes I think are
[Laughter]
really something as well
is this good
he sees what you're saying in chat
living lifts isn't even chat right now
laughs
[Music]
thank you for giving me a platform Jacob
you're so welcome
and here's the original Lemon Lips again
in case you yeah
yeah it feels like Lemon Lips ate hummus
until he grew a body yeah
it's so strong
um should I I should draw something else
huh yeah
I don't know how to like follow that
then the next 12 minutes just admiring
Lemon Lips
that we could but
we said it the people are here for yeah
on our own time yeah okay
yeah feel free to feel free to pull up
Lemon Lips in its own uh tab
and just you know glance at it
oh I am seeing we can also go to a
featured video should we watch a
featured video oh okay we're supposed to
do that in our segment right
right director
[Laughter]
and I'll I'll let you
yeah Play that video
oh wow we're back baby
did you enjoy that featured video
I didn't see it personally but I hope it
was good
right did you all see it
Jacob do you want to do one more draw to
bring us home almost being pickled
he's doing a little dance through my
apartment it's all you can see
[Laughter]
Lemon Lips Prince sold out
Lemon Lips purchased okay I gotta move
fast because I I have to draw five foot
nine Brown Eyes in a sundress people
keep saying it people keep saying it
you simply must and so I simply must why
don't I use a visible why don't I share
my screen also that would be yeah start
with that part or I can just like tell
you what I'm drawing and you have to
believe me
okay we gotta we gotta move fast here
yeah yeah
you got they're going to start with a
sundress shape uh-huh beautiful they're
like
sort of like this
yeah
the sort of dress that the sun would
wear yeah the sun loves this type of
dress yeah
and then it usually has like flowers on
it
sure
you know the sundress yeah the sundress
okay
yeah
the sun likes flowers
the sun loves
extremely
crab then I think it's just like
it's like eyes
yeah right yeah brown eyes brown eyes
five and nine
yeah
at least two of them I guess it could be
more
yeah there's no it just has a height it
doesn't say how many eyes yeah eyes all
the way down
yeah okay
this might be uh
not not full eyeballs though just sort
of like the way eyes look on your face
[Laughter]
I was like what do you mean they're not
usually the shape you're so weird
[Laughter]
she's just going to the park
she's just out having a good time
my eyes are up here and over there and
down here
and
and also
most places really
anywhere the sundress isn't
my eyes
this is the beach episode yeah
laughs
oh my gosh
it's like a it's like a peacock's tail
yeah
it's sort of like that it's more like
that
and I'm like eyeball feet
[Laughter]
nice I love it Chad this is what you
were talking about right this is what
you wanted
this is what yeah you you like it right
no one can say this isn't exactly what
they ask for this is just what you asked
for we're just trying what you asked for
so if you want to interrupt it you
should do a better job requesting
your feet the same way ahead brings you
like a dead mouse
[Laughter]
to show you how much I care lashes yeah
oh yeah of course because I love you
don't ask how there's lashes when
there's no lids yeah yeah you don't want
to know the answer
as well
yeah
yeah we can do that if you ever catch us
on on Twitch we end all our streams by
drawing our our favorite character
or a little guy or a little guy oh yeah
make sure okay
this to calculate the height of four
five four four five five five then five
yeah and then this is six up here that's
six up there and yeah perfect this is
the height we're at
yeah so close to Six but not not quite
not quite not quite oh my God my
doorbell's ringing
Julia is back though so she can get it
uh and then I'm doing a little porfo
we always end our stream with a porfo
yeah I mean pickles throwing up at your
place late
[Laughter]
the Stream
but you know you get to hang out with
being Pinnacle at least
porpo's gonna be like thanks for
watching
and and thank you for donating
for donating
[Laughter]
you know it doesn't say
the numbers right now aren't reflecting
that we doubled the amount but I think
that like once they get the full count
in yeah but we did
[Laughter]
seriously thank you
thank you all for donating uh yeah it's
awesome
it is awesome it is that's literally in
the name
and thank you to uh
thank you to the the
vlogbrothers for having us on the Stream
yeah
mostly but mostly thank you to Lemon
Lips
thank you Lemon Lips for being an icon
when everyone hated you we didn't
oh uh um so they're gonna reset the
stream now
yeah because probably because of all the
donations and then yeah the stream will
be back in a few minutes after they
reset to save the vods so hang around
don't leave this screen
and thanks so much for having us yeah
yeah thank you thank you
bye everybody